>> DAY 3 OF THE NFL DRAFT.
IT HAS BEEN ELECTRIC.
DAY 1 WE SAW TRADES.
DAY 2 WE SAW VALUE.
DAY 3 WE ARE GOING TO SEE
SLEEPERS.
HOW ARE WE FEELING RIGHT NOW?
>> I AM FEELING GOOD.
LOOKING GOOD.
PLAY GOOD.
WE ARE COMFORTABLE.
I HOPE YOU GUYS WILL BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THESE PICKS.
>> IF YOU STAYED WITH US ON DAYS
1 AND 2, WE HAD ADAM LEFCOE,
RICHARD SHERMAN.
WE ARE NOT DONE YET.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST JOINING
US TODAY.
A TRUE, AND I MEAN THE
DEFINITION OF THE WORD, LEGEND
OF THE GAME.
TORRY HOLT IS ON WITH US TODAY.
TORRY HOLT, HOW ARE WE FEELING
ON DAY 3 OF THE DRAFT.
LET'S GO.
>> DAY 3, MAN.
I FEEL GOOD.
AS MICHAEL JUST MENTIONED.
I AM COMFORTABLE.
I AM AT HOME.
I AM WATCHING THE DRAFT.
DAY 1 AND 2 HAS BEEN FANTASTIC.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT TODAY
WILL BE LIKE.
TODAY IS WHERE YOU BUILD THE
MEAT AND POTATOES OF YOUR
FOOTBALL TEAM.
GUYS THAT PLAY SPECIAL TEAMS,
ONES AND TWOS.
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR EVERYTHING
TODAY AND THERE IS A LOT OF
TALENT LEFT.
>> THIS IS WHERE YOU CAN GET
STARTING LEVEL TALENT FOR VALUE,
CHEAP.
WE ARE GOING TO LOOK AT MY BEST
PLAYERS AVAILABLE IN A MINUTE.
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT I WOULD
WANT TO TALK ABOUT HIS
FAVORITES.
NOT THE GUYS OF THE PREMIUM
POSITIONS.
THESE ARE GUYS HE SEES TALENT IN
THAT MAYBE SHOULDN'T BE SITTING
HERE MORE.
>> BRYANT, WE TALKED AT HIM WHEN
IT COMES TO THE REALITY HE IS A
REAL GOOD PLAYER OPPOSITE SAUCE
GARDNER.
KOEHLER, TIGHT END.
TWO GUYS FROM UTSA.
A CORNER AND A RUNNING BACK WHO
IS SHORT BUT NOT FOUL.
RIDGEWAY FROM ARKANSAS.
SMITH, THE FIRST TIME I SAW HIM
PLAYING TIGHT END.
AND KELSEY TALKED ABOUT THIS.
HE LIKES GUYS THAT ARE TIGHT
ENDS CONVERTED INTO OFFENSIVE
LINEMEN.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE WITH SMITH.
TY CHANDLER, A TENNESSEE GUY
THAT IS ULTIMATELY A RUNNING
BACK THAT CAN CHECK ALL OF YOUR
BOXES AND OBVIOUSLY BEING ABLE
TO CATCH THE BALL OUT OF THE
BACKFIELD.
>> SHORT BUT NOT SMALL, I HOPE
THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE SAY ABOUT
ME.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE BOARD
TODAY AND IS THERE ANYBODY OUT
THERE YOU REALLY, REALLY LIKE
AND WANT TO SEE COME OFF OF THE
BOARD IN THE FIRST COUPLE OF
PICKS?
>> MICHAEL MENTIONED TY
CHANDLER.
A VERY TALENTED GUY.
TRANSFERRED OVER FROM TENNESSEE.
HE CAN RUN THE FOOTBALL.
HE CAN CATCH IT OUT OF THE
BACKFIELD.
I THOUGHT THAT HE CAME ON REALLY
WELL LATE IN THE SEASON.
HE HAS GOT A LOT OF VALUE,
POTENTIAL AND UPSIDE.
HIS TEAMMATE SAM HOWELL WHO IS
STILL OUT THERE.
WILL ANOTHER QUARTERBACK GO?
THOSE ARE TWO GUYS INTRIGUING ME
OFF THE BAT.
>> I LIKE IT.
LET'S LOOK AT MY BEST AVAILABLE,
WHAT IS LEFT OF THE BIG BOARD.
YOU SEESAWIER AT THE TOP.
HE IS JUST VALUE.
MAYBE NOT THE MOST ATHLETIC OR
THE TALLEST WITH THE MOST
LENGTH.
HE COULD BE A TEN-YEAR STARTER
AT GUARD.
THE OPPOSITE GODZILLA, RIGHT
TACKLE IN THE FUTURE.
YOU SEE KENNARD.
IT IS GOING TO KICK INSIDE.
HE DID PLAY RIGHT TACKLE.
A NICE OFFENSIVE LINE TRIO AT
THE TOP OF THE BOARD.
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL BE
WAITING LONG.
YOU HEARD TORRY BRING UP SAM
HOWELL.
THE CREAM OF THE CROP OF WHAT IS
LEFT OF THE QUARTERBACKS.
AFTER THAT A LOT OF PROJECTS.
ZAPPE.
AND THE STORY OF THE DAY IN MY
EYES, AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT OFF
CAMERA, WILL BE THE RUNNING
BACKS.
HOW MANY YEARS DO YOU SEE
STARTING RUNNING BACKS TAKEN ON
DAY 3.
THE BUCS HAVE TAKEN ONE.
THE JETS ARE EARLY TAKING BREECE
HALL.
YOU NEVER KNOW ABOUT THE TEXANS
AND THE BROWNS.
I BELIEVE KAREEM HUNT IS ON THE
FINAL YEAR OF HIS DEAL.
YOU HAVE NICK CHUBB.
THEY ROTATE THEIR RUNNING BACKS
OVER AND OVER.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE ACTION ON
THE RUNNING BACKS IN THE FOURTH
ROUND.
FELDER, WE HAVE THE BUCS KICKING
IT OFF, SUPER BOWL CONTENDER.
PROBABLY LOOKING FOR GUYS THAT
CAN PLAY NOW.
>> YES.
>> ANYONE WE ARE THINKING ABOUT
FOR TAMPA?
WE SAW RASHARD WHITE, LOGAN
HALL.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU LIKE HERE?
>> GO ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
BALL.
WOOLLEN, A LONG CORNER, FITS
WELL.
HE CAN DO INSANE THINGS WITH
THAT LENGTH.
SO FOR ME I AM LOOKING IN THAT
DIRECTION.
THEY HAVE GONE ALL OFFENSE.
>> I AM WITH YOU.
YOU TALK ABOUT TODD BOWLES, HE
LOVES HIS CORNERS.
HE IS ONE OF THE BEST IN THE
GAME AT DEVELOPING DEFENSIVE
BOOKS.
TARIQ WOOLEN, STILL FIGURING IT
OUT.
THE HOUSTON TEXANS, I WILL LOVE
TO SEE THEIR PICKS.
I THINK THEY HAVE DONE A GOOD
JOB.
THIS IS A ROSTER THAT THEY
REALLY HAD TO FILL IT OUT.
THEY HAVE TAKEN A LOT OF PLAYERS
AND GUYS THAT CAN START RIGHT
AWAY.
IT IS NOT JUST DEREK STINGLEY.
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO SEE WHAT
THE TEXANS DO TODAY.
I THINK MY ONE QUESTION WITH
THEM IS THAT THEY LIKE DAVIS
MILLS.
IS THAT A LANDING SPOT FOR SAM
HOWELL WHERE YOU MAKE THINGS
INTERESTING SORE SAY YOU ARE A
GUY I AM LOOKING TO BRING IN
COMPETITION FOR YOU.
>> DO YOU WANT TO MAKE HIM
COMFORTABLE?
OR DO YOU WANT TO MAKE HIM FEEL
LIKE HE HAS TO PRESS.
YOU FIND WEAPONS.
YOU FIND GUYS HE CAN GROW WITH.
IF YOU WANT A COMPETITION, SAM
HOWELL IS YOUR ANSWER.
>> WE ARE GO TO KEEP THAT GOING.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THE BROWNS.
SEATTLE HAS DONE A LOT OF NICE
THINGS IN THE DRAFT.
THEY INVESTED HEAVILY IN THE
OFFENSIVE LINE.
WE SAW TAMPA TAKING A GUARD.
HOUSTON IS A TEAM THAT NEEDS
OFFENSIVE LINE HELP AS WELL.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL BE LONG
BEFORE WE ARE TAPPING INTO THE
BEST AVAILABLE.
WHEN YOU ARE LOOKING AT KENNARD.
WHY DO YOU THINK THESE GUYS ARE
HERE?
YOU USUALLY COME OFF OF THE
BOARD EARLY.
>> HE IS STILL KIND OF YOUNG IN
THE WORLD OF FOOTBALL.
HE IS A PROJECT.
EVEN THOUGH HE IS AN ELITE
TALENT.
KINNARD, HIS CENTER GOT TAKEN
BEFORE HIM.
IS HE RESISTANT OF THE IDEA OF
KICKING DOWN TO GUARD?
I THINK THAT IS THE BIG THING.
I THINK HE CAN DO IT.
THEY PLAYED WITH SERIOUS ENERGY.
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THIS.
>> SPEAKING OF THE TRENCHES, A
LOT OF GOOD BLOCKING TIGHT ENDS
ON THE BOARD.
>> YES.
>> WE SAW LAST NIGHT END WITH
MAYBE A PREVIEW OF WHAT IS
TODAY.
THE JETS TOOK JEREMY RUCKER.
WE SAW THE PASS CATCHER.
WE WILL SEE A CHARLIE KOEHLER
PLAYER THAT WILL GO TODAY.
BELLINGER, JAKE FERGUSON.
IS THERE A GUY YOU LIKE OUT OF
THE GROUP AND DO YOU THINK THEY
ARE SURE FIRE FOURTH ROUNDERS.
THEY COULD ALL START OR BE THE
TIGHT END 2.
>> JAKE FERGUSON, A GOOD
ATHLETE.
NOT QUITE THE ATHLETE AS RUCKER
BUT I THINK HE FITS IN A SIMILAR
MOLD.
HE WAS A RELIABLE OPTION FOR
THEM.
FERGUSON I WOULD PUT ON THE
LIST.
A GUY THAT CAN SEE HIM PLAY.
WHERE HE FITS INTO THE MIX.
HE IS ANOTHER ONE THAT COULD
COME IN.
AND THAT CREATES A REALLY GOOD
OPTION.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO WE HAVE OUR FIRST PICK OF THE
DAY.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT WITH THE
BUCS, LOOKING FOR IMPACT
PLAYERS.
I HAVE HEARD FOR A WHILE THE
BUCS WERE ALL OVER PLAYERS LIKE
McBRIDE.
THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO GET HIM.
NOW WE LOOK AT A GUY WITH A TON
OF EXPERIENCE AS BOTH A ZONE AND
GAP RUN BLOCKER.
THAT IS WHAT HE CAN DO.
HE CAN CATCH THE BALL IN THE 5
TO 12-YARD AREA, MOVE THE CHAINS
AND GET FIRST DOWNS.
ONE THING, EXPERIENCE.
HE HAS PLAYED MANY, MANY REPS OF
FOOTBALL.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ROB GRONKOWSKI
COME BACK.
I REALLY LIKE THE PICK FOR THE
BUCS.
MY 78 FTH OVERALL PLAYER AND WE
ARE AT PICK 106.
I THINK HE CAN PLAY RIGHT AWAY.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF PLAYER THAT
TOM BRADY, SURE HANDS, MIDDLE OF
THE FIELD.
>> I THINK HE IS SOMEONE THAT
WILL EAT UP THE MIDDLE OF THE
FIELD.
SOMEONE THAT WILL SET UP,
BECAUSE HE BLOCKS SO WELL.
THE IDEA HE CAN SET UP FOR A
SCREEN.
THAT IS A STRAIGHT LINE THROW.
HE CAN DO THOSE THINGS.
A GUY THAT A LOT OF FOLKS VIEWED
THIS IS A GREAT PICK.
HE HAS GOT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE AN IMPACT IMMEDIATELY.
HE IS WELL TAUGHT.
HE IS SURE-HANDED.
HE UNDERSTANDS WHERE HE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE OPEN ON THE
FIELD.
>> TORRY HOLT, YOU KNOW A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT CATCHING THE FOOTBALL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
SELECTION FOR THE BUCS.
>> I LIKE IT A LOT.
WE ALL KNOW.
IF YOU KNOW THE HISTORY OF
PATOM
BRADY, HE LIKES TO THROW THE
FOOTBALL TO THE TIGHT ENDS.
A FOUR-YEAR STARTER, SUDDEN,
REALLY GOOD FEEL FOR RUNNING
ROUTES.
WE SAW A CLIP THERE, HE IS
WORKING OVER THE MIDDLE OF THE
FOOTBALL FIELD.
TOM BRADY LIKES TO THROW THE
BALL OVER THE MIDDLE OF THE
FOOTBALL FIELD AND IT WILL OPEN
UP THINGS FOR MIKE EVANS WHEN
YOU HAVE A TIGHT END THAT CAN
FILL THE MIDDLE OF THE FOOTBALL
FIELD.
I LIKE THE PICK UP BY THE TAMPA
BAY BUCCANEERS, GIVING TOM BRADY
ANOTHER WEAPON HE WILL USE.
>> I DO TOO.
NOT A GUY YOU THINK WILL SIT FOR
A YEAR.
FOR A BUCS TEAM, THEY DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF NEEDS.
THEY WENT INTO THE DRAFT.
THEY GOT A PASS RUSHER AND A GAP
SHOOTER.
TIGHT END WAS ONE OF THE LAST
THINGS FOR THEM.
YOU HAVE ONE OF THE STARTING
PLAYERS.
NOW WE ARE WAITING ON THE
HOUSTON TEXANS.
THEY HAD A REALLY GOOD DRAFT.
LET'S LOOK AT WHAT THE TEXANS
HAVE DONE IN THE DRAFT.
THEY TOOK A BIG SWING FOR THE
FENCE PICK EARLY IN DEREK
STINGLEY.
NOW DO YOU THINK THIS IS THE
PART OF THE DRAFT YOU TAIL OFF.
STINGLEY.
KENYON GREEN.
A I LOT OF THE GUYS PLAYED A LOT
OF FOOTBALL AND IN BIG TIME
GAMES, CHRISTIAN HARRIS AND JOHN
METCHIE.
S.E.C., S.E.C., BIG TEN, S.E.C.,
PAC-12.
BIG PLAYERS FROM BIG SCHOOLS
THAT CAN GET THE JOB DONE.
>> TOOK ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYERS ON THE BOARD TODAY.
>> THERE IT IS DAMIAN PIERCE,
107 OVERALL.
A RUNNING BACK FROM FLORIDA.
THIS GUY CAN PLAY.
THE COOL THING ABOUT WATCHING
DAMIAN PIERCE PLAY, YOU ARE
GOING TO GET A GUY WHO WAS NOT
THE RUSHING LEADER ON HIS TEAM.
EMERY JONES.
BUT HE UNDERSTANDS HOW TO BE
TOUGH AND STRONG.
I LOOK AT THE WAY THAT HE RUNS
THE FOOTBALL.
HE WANTS TO GET WIDE.
HE IS IS NOT AFRAID OF CONTACT.
HE IS A LITTLE BOWLING BALL.
I LOVE IT ABOUT HIS GAME.
I THINK HE HAD A REALLY BIG
OFF-SEASON.
HE HAD A GREAT COME-UP ONCE WE
GOT PAST THE SEASON WHERE
FLORIDA WAS UP AND DOWN AND GOT
INTO THE PREDRAFT WORK HE
STARTED TO SHOW HIMSELF.
>> I GOT TO SEE HIM AT THE
SENIOR BOWL.
HE WAS THE DUDE OUT THERE.
DAVID MONTGOMERY.
THAT IS THE PLAYER THAT I THINK
OF.
A GUY WHO FORCES A TON OF MISSED
TACKLES.
WHEN HE GETS TO THE SECOND
LEVEL, CAR CRASH THE
LINEBACKERS, SAFETIES, CORNERS,
YOU DON'T WANT TO RUN INTO HIM.
I SAW A SCISSOR KICK MOVE THAT I
HAVE NOT SEEN IN A LONG TIME.
HE IS AN UNBELIEVABLE OPEN FIELD
GUY THAT DID NOT GET THE BALL
ENOUGH.
HE GETS TO THE SENIOR BOWL.
HE WAS MY FOURTH RATED RUNNING
BACK IN THE DRAFT.
VALUE IS GREAT.
TOP 80 PLAYER ON THE BOARD.
TEXANS COULD NOT RUN THE
FOOTBALL LAST YEAR.
NOBODY CAN BREAK A TACKLE.
THAT GROUP WILL LOOK A LOT
BETTER.
THEY BELIEVE IN DAVIS MILLS.
I AM GOING WITH AN A MINUS.
DAMEON PIERCE, ONE OF THE MORE
UNDERRATED PLAYERS.
I IMAGINE TEXANS FANS ARE JACKED
UP OVER THIS ONE.
>> THIS IS A GUY THAT CAN PLAY.
THE BIG THING FOR ME IS BREAKING
TACKLES.
THEY WILL GIVE YOU TEN.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE ONE GUY MISS.
EITHER YOU ARE BREAKING THE
TACKLE OR SHAKING.
HE CAN DO A LITTLE BIT OF BOTH.
HIS ABILITY TO DO BOTH.
GET YOU SOMEONE THAT CAN DO
BOTH.
>> THAT IS WHAT THEY SAY.
>> HE IS A GUY THAT WILL MAKE
YOU MISS AND RUN THROUGH THE
ARMS.
HE WILL PUT HIS SHOULDER DOWN
TOO.
>> YEAH.
IT IS HARD TO FIND ROOKIE
RUNNING BACKS THAT CAN COME IN
AND STAND UP BLITZING
LINEBACKERS.
DAMEON PIERCE IS SOMEONE THAT
CAN DO THAT.
THE NEXT PICK WILL BE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST TALKING POINTS ON THE AT
A.
PERRION WINFREY GOING TO THE
CLEVELAND BROWNS.
PICK 108 FOR WINFREY, A GUY THAT
THE TAPE, HOT AND COLD.
BUT WHEN YOU LET HIM SHOOT GAPS
AND BE A PASS RUSHING THREE THE
ATHLETICISM IS HIGH END.
SEEING HIM DOWN IN MOBILE
AGAINST GOOD OFFENSIVE LINEMEN
THAT ARE ALREADY OFF OF THE
BOARD IN THE DRAFT.
THEY COULDN'T TOUCH HIM.
EXCELLENT PASS RUSH MOVES.
HE CAN GIVE YOU A SWIM MOVE AND
RIP.
I WONDER ABOUT THE DISCIPLINE
AGAINST THE RUN.
YOU ARE TAKING HIM IN THE FOURTH
ROUND AND PUTTING HIM IN A
CLEVELAND BROWNS SYSTEM.
ALL OF THE ATTENTION CAN'T
ALWAYS BE ON MYLES GARRETT.
WINFREY CAN DO THAT.
VALUE, VALUE, VALUE.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT A PLAYER
WHERE THERE ARE NOT A LOT OF
GUYS LIKE THIS IN THIS CLASS.
77th OVERALL PLAYER.
WE ARE IN THE 100s.
IF YOU GET HIM DIALED IN HE
COULD BE CAPABLE AGAINST THE
RUN.
>> JORDAN ELLIOTT, TOMMY, YOU
THROW IN MYLES GARRETT.
THEY HAVE ALEX WRIGHT EARLIER IN
THE DRAFT.
THE BIG KEY FOR ME WITH PERRION
WINFREY WILL BE HIS ABILITY TO
BE A ONE-GAP PLAYER.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT A 4-3 SCHEME.
IF YOU ASK HIM TO BE A ONE GAP
PLAYER HE CAN GET IN THERE AND
DOMINATE.
DON'T ASK HIM TO TWO GAP OR ASK
HIM TO BE SOMEONE TO READ AND
REACT.
HE KNOWS I AM C OR B GAP THIS
PLAY.
I AM GOING TO GIVE IT AN A
MINUS.
IF WE SEE THE PLAN COMING TO
FRUITION.
>> TORRY HOLT, ONE OF THE BEST
PLAYERS ON THE BOARD GOING IN TO
TODAY.
IT FELT LIKE THERE ALWAYS COULD
HAVE BEEN MORE WITH PERRION
WINFREY IN OAKLAND.
WHA
-- OKLAHOMA.
>> YOU THINK OF ADDING MORE
DEPTH TO THE DEFENSIVE FRONT
LEADING THERE WITH MYLES
GARRETT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STRENGTHS
OF PERRION, EXPLOSIVE.
HE HAS GOT A LOT OF POWER.
HE WORKS THROUGH THE WHISTLE.
THAT IS ONE THING A LOT OF TEAMS
LIKE FROM HIM THAT EFFORT AND
MOTOR.
I THINK THE SCHEME WILL FIT.
HE SHOULD BE HIGHLY, HIGHLY
MOTIVATED PLAYING ON THE SAME
DEFENSIVE FRONT AS MYLES
GARRETT.
>> A TEAM THAT HASN'T BROUGHT
BACK JADEVEON CLOWNEY YET.
WE WERE WAITING ON THEM TO
ADDRESS THE DEFENSIVE LINE.
SEATTLE, WE HAVE GOT THE PICK
COMING IN.
THEY AN INTERESTING START TO THE
DRAFT, CHARLES CROSS AT NINE.
AN OFFENSIVE LINE THAT NEEDED TO
BE COMPLETELY RETOOLED.
ABRAHAM LUCAS.
COBY BRYANT, SAUCE GARDNER'S
RUNNING MATE AT CINCINNATI.
THE BALL SKILLS REALLY, THE
GREEN LIGHT CAME ON.
HE IS PATIENT.
I THINK HE CAN PLAY OFF.
I THINK HE HAS GOT THE SIZE TO
PLAY PRESS.
THE BEST CORNER ON THE BOARD.
7 3rd OVERALL PLAYER.
WE SAW CORNERS OVERDRAFTED FOR
UPSIDE.
WITH COBY BRYANT, WHAT YOU SEE
IS WHAT YOU GET.
A JALEN JOHNSON PLAYER, 6'2",
190 POUNDS.
LENGTH IS ADEQUATE.
THE INTERCEPTIONS STARTED TO
COME ON THIS YEAR.
SAUCE GARDNER, NOBODY WANTED TO
THROW HIS WAY.
EVERYBODY KNEW WHO SAUCE GARDNER
WAS IN 2001.
COBY BRYANT, ATTACK HIM.
HE LOVED IT AND HE EMBRACED
THAT.
I THINK HE IS A STARTER.
A STARTER AT A PREMIUM POSITION
IN ROUND 4.
HE HAS GOT PATIENT EYES.
HE DOES NOT OVERREACT TO ROUTES.
HE IS A HELL OF A PLAYER.
>> HE IS FANTASTIC.
WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE TABLE
REALISTICALLY IS SOMEONE THAT
WILL DO EVERYTHING.
HE PLAYED IN A MAN DOMINATED
SCHEME AT CINCINNATI.
WATCHING HIM DROP OFF IN ZONE
AND HE CARRIES AND DROPS AND
MAKES A TACKLE.
HE IS ALWAYS AROUND THE BALL.
THE BALL SKILLS, THE
INTERCEPTIONS, THE FORCED
FUMBLES.
JOHNNY ON THE SPOT TRYING TO
RECOVER FUMBLES.
HE BRINGS A LOT OF THOSE TRAITS
TO THE TABLE.
THE COOL THING THAT I LIKED
ABOUT HIM.
WHEN YOU KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO
BE THE GUY THAT WILL BE
TARGETED, YOU HAVE TO APPROACH
IT DIFFERENTLY.
THE SAME THING AS KYLER GORDON
AT WASHINGTON.
YOU HAVE TO BRING IT TO THE
TABLE EVERY DAY.
YOU GET HIM IN THE FOURTH ROUND.
THAT MEANS YOU ARE GOING TO GET
THE VALUE.
YES, A STARTER.
I THINK HE HAS GOT THE ABILITY
TO HAVE A LONG CAREER AND
BLOSSOM INTO SOMEONE PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO THROW THE FOOTBALL
TO.
>> I LIKE THIS KID.
WHAT I LIKE IN ALL OF THE
CORNERS HERE TODAY.
THEY ARE LONG, GUYS.
6'1", 193 POUNDS.
WE KNOW PETE CARROLL AND THAT
DEFENSE LIKE LONG CORNERS THAT
CAN GET UP AND PRESS.
GUYS THAT CAN PLAY COVER 3 ZONE,
REALLY GOOD INSTINCTS AND WILL
TACKLE ON THE PERIMETER.
HE DOES A GOOD JOB OF READING
ROUTES.
I LIKE THE PICK FOR THE SEATTLE
SEAHAWKS.
IT REMINDS ME OF HOW LONG THEY
WERE.
THE PLAYMAKING ABILITY THAT THE
GUY WILL BRING.
IT IS A GOOD PICK FOR THE
SEATTLE SEAHAWKS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE BALTIMORE
RAVENS WHO HAVE HAD A TREMENDOUS
DRAFT.
LET'S TAKE A BREAK AND REMIND
YOU OF OUR LOVELY SPONSOR HERE
BY ROCKET MORTGAGE.
BALTIMORE RAVENS ON THE CLOCK.
IT STARTED TO FEEL LIKE THEY
WERE LAUGHING.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT HIGH
FLOOR PLAYERS OR PLUG AND PLAY
STARTERS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT POTENTIAL
ALL-BLOWS.
KYLE HAMILTON, DAVID OJABO,
DRAFT AND STASH.
2023 MIGHT BE DYNAMITE FOR HIM.
TRAVIS JONES IN THE THIRD ROUND.
325-POUND GUY RUNNING A S
SUB 5.00 40.
YOU HAVE TO LOVE THE DRAFT
CLASS, RIGHT.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST OUT
THERE, RIGHT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE RAVENS,
THE JETS, THE EAGLES, SHOUT OUT
TO LEFCOE.
THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF TEAMS
THAT REALLY HAD SUCCESSFUL
DRAFTS AND THEY ARE USING PICKS.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THEY GO WITH
THIS ONE?
>> I THINK THEY CAN GO BACK TO
THE OFFENSIVE LINE.
YOU LOOK AT A GAP BLOCKING
SCHEME THAT VALUES THE BIGGEST
HUMAN BEINGS ON EARTH.
YOU HAVE KINNARD THERE.
IT IS NORTH TO SOUTH.
IT IS NOT REACHING AND GETTING
INTO SPACE.
I THINK THE OFFENSIVE LINE BOARD
HAS FALLEN INTO THEIR HANDS AND
THE PICK IS DANIEL FAALELE.
THIS IS WHAT BALTIMORE LIKES.
THEY GOT AN UNDERSIZED GUY FROM
THE INTERIOR.
HOW DO THEY LIVE WITH IT?
THEY SUPPLEMENT IT BY PUTTING
GODZILLA ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
FAALELE ONE OF THE BEST PLAYERS
ON THE BOARD.
COMING FROM AUSTRALIA OBVIOUSLY
HE HASN'T BEEN PLAYING FOOTBALL
FOR THE LONGEST TIME.
ING ACADEMY GUY.
WITH MORE COACHING HE CAN PLAY
ON RIGHT SIDE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE FEET TO PLAY
LEFT TACKLE.
HE IS SO BIG, STRONG AND HARD TO
GET AROUND.
IN THE FOURTH ROUND TACKLES THIS
BIG AND THAT ARE THAT GOOD IN
PASS PRO DON'T HANG AROUND THIS
LONG.
BALTIMORE IS PLAYING THE VALUE
GAME.
WHO IS THE BEST PLAYER ON THE
BOARD AND WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
HIM.
HE ALSO FITS THEIR SCHEME.
I AM GOING WITH AN A FOR DANIEL
FAALELE.
>> IT IS UNBELIEVABLE TO SEE
WHAT HE IS ABLE TO DO.
WHEN YOU WATCH HIM PLAY, THIS IS
A GUY WHO HAS GOT ALL OF THE
TOOLS TO BE YOUR SET UP RIGHT
TACKLE FOREVER.
HE MOVES VERY WELL.
WE SAW HIS ABILITY TO GET THAT
PUNCH IN THERE AND KNOCK A GUY
DOWN.
HE IS STRONG.
YEAH.
I LOVE WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE.
BRINGS.
HE PUNCHES.
HE MOVES.
RUN GAME, YOU NEED TO WORK ON
HIS PAD LEVEL.
THERE IS NOTHING THEY CAN DO
WITH YOU.
>> KIND OF A TRENT BROWN SORT OF
PLAYER.
BECAUSE THE SIZE.
BECAUSE OF THE ABILITY TO MOVE
PEOPLE OFF OF THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE BUT IN A PHONE BOOTH.
HE IS NOT GOING TO CLIMB AND GET
OUT WIDE.
RAVENS CONTINUE AN EXCELLENT
DRAFT.
JETS ARE ON THE CLOCK.
THEY HAD A VERY, VERY STRONG
DRAFT.
THEY HAD A LOT OF HOLES.
THEY ARE TAKING MAX MITCHELL.
A DEVELOPMENT OFFENSIVE TACKLE
THAT REALLY HAD A NICE RUN HERE.
PLAYER 104 FOR ME IN MAX
MITCHELL TO THE JETS REMINDED ME
OF WALKER LITTLE.
SOMETHING YOU SAID BEFORE, I
THINK THAT LEVERAGE HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE.
WHEN IT IS A LACK OF LEVERAGE IT
COULD BE QUESTIONS WITH THE
ANKLE.
MAX MITCHELL, HE IS NOT COMING
IN TO START.
WE NEEDED A BIG GUY.
WE NEEDED SOMEONE WITH LENGTH TO
FILL IN ON THE LINE AND MAYBE
DEVELOP INTO A LONG-TERM STARTER
DOWN THE ROAD.
FOR MAX MITCHELL GOING TO THE
JETS.
LOUISIANA PRODUCT.
A LONG TIME STARTER.
6'6".
FITS THE SKYSCRAPER MOLD AT
TACKLE.
THIS IS JUST PROVIDING DEPTH.
I WILL GO WITH A B MINUS.
LONG-TERM I DO NOT SEE A
LONG-TERM STARTER.
THAT IS OKAY.
>> I THINK HE IS A DEVELOPMENTAL
STARTER.
I AM GOING TO GO WITH A B.
I AM CURIOUS TO WATCH HOW THEY
RAISE HIM UP.
HOW MUCH BIGGER CAN HE GET AND
LEARN TO PLAY WITH LEVERAGE.
>> GAINING MORE LOWER BODY MASS,
BUILDING THE ANCHOR.
I THINK HE HAS THE FEET TO
PROTECT THE EDGE.
BUT WHEN YOU ARE FACING THE NFL
BULL RUSHERS.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THIS GUY TO
BE A CONTRIBUTOR FURTHER DOWN
THE ROAD.
TORRY HOLT, MAX MITCHELL GOING
TO THE JETS.
>> I LIKE MAX MITCHELL.
I LIKE THE DEPTH HE PROVIDES.
THIS DUDE RIGHT HERE, BIG AS HE
IS, THIS GUY CAN MOVE.
HE HAS GOT REALLY GOOD BODY
CONTROL.
HE IS PRETTY FLEXIBLE FOR A GUY
HIS SIZE.
HE CONSISTENTLY DOES A GOOD JOB
OF GAINING LEVERAGE, 6'6".
THE WINNIPEG JETS ARE SAYING
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE GOOD
OFFENSIVELY WITH SPEED.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE DEPTH.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE SIZE.
WE ARE GOING TO LOOK LIKE THE
BIG TEAM OUT THERE WHEN WE GET
OFF OF THE BUS WHEN YOU ADD
SOMEONE LIKE MAX MITCHELL.
>> JETS GETTING SOME OFFENSIVE
LINE DEPTH.
THE GINEW YORK GIANTS ARE ON TH
CLOCK.
THEY CAME OUT SWINGING DAY 1 AND
2.
THEY GOT HELP AT CORNER.
WE SAW COBY BRYANT AND DANIEL
FAALELE GOING BACK-TO-BACK.
THE JETS TAKE MAX MITCHELL.
THE GIANTS TOOK DANIEL
BELLINGER, AN ATHLETIC BLOCKING
TIGHT END FROM SAN DIEGO STATE
AND PERCY BUTLER OFF OF THE
BOARD TO THE WASHINGTON
COMMANDERS.
I THINK THAT IS HOW DAY 3 CAN
START.
TEAMS ARE SURPRISED AT THE
PLAYERS THAT FELL.
I THINK THAT WE TALK DANIEL
BELLINGER HERE.
THIS IS A NEW YORK GIANTS TEAM
THAT NEEDED TIGHT END HELP.
EVAN ENGRAM LEAVES IN FREE
AGENCY.
THEY CUT KYLE RUDOLPH.
A LOT OF POTENTIAL STARTING
TIGHT ENDS OR TIGHT ENDS 2s ARE
ON THE BOARD.
BELLINGER, ANOTHER SENIOR BOWL
GUY.
HE CAN BLOCK, DO THE DIRTY WORK
AND HE CAN ABSOLUTELY RUN.
DANIEL BELLINGER WILL BE THE
PICK FOR THE GIANTS.
GIANTS ARE BACK ON THE CLOCK.
DANIEL BELLINGER, HE CAN HELP
THE TACKLES CHIP.
HE IS SMART ENOUGH TO TAKE ON
BLITZERS.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE TOUGH
RUNNING AFTER THE CATCH.
THEY HAVE EVAN ENGRAM WHO IS NOT
MUCH OF A BLOCKER.
THEY WANT GUYS WITH A BIG CATCH
RADIUS, MAKE LIFE EASIER ON
DANIEL JONES.
PLAYER 13 ON THE BOARD GIANTS
CONTINUE TO GET HELP IN THE
DRAFT.
I WILL GIVE THEM A B PLUS.
I LIKE THE GROUP OF HIM, JAKE
FERGUSON, CHARLIE KOEHLER.
IT IS A MATTER OF WHAT YOU NEED
AND THE GIANTS PREFERRED THE
BLOCKING ABILITY OF BELLINGER.
>> I THINK BELLINGER IS A GOOD
PLAYER.
I THINK HE PLAYED IN A SYSTEM
THAT WILL TRANSLATE WELL TO THE
NEXT LEVEL.
THEY ARE A RUN-HEAVY SCHEME.
HE HAD TO BLOCK.
TO GET THE BALL HE IS OBVIOUSLY
ABLE TO WORK THE SEAM.
HE CATCHES THE BALL OUTSIDE OF
THE FRAME.
I WILL GIVE HIM A B.
I WONDER ABOUT WHERE HE FITS
INTO THE LIST.
BELLINGER IS A GOOD PICK.
A GUY THAT CAN COME IN AND GIVE
GOOD PUSH IN THE RUN GAME.
>> ONE THING ON TAPE, THEY USED
HIM IN THE BACKFIELD AS A LEAD
BLOCKING FULLBACK.
TORRY, ANOTHER PASS CATCHER.
>> THIS IS GOOD.
WHEN YOU THINK OF THE NEW YORK
GIANTS AND WANTING TO GET BACK
TO CONTROLLING THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE ON THE OFFENSIVE SIDE
OF THE BALL WITH SAQUON BARKLEY,
YOU HAVE TO ADD TIGHT ENDS.
HE CAN MOVE PEOPLE.
I LIKE THE DRAFT PICK.
HE WILL PROVIDE MORE DEPTH.
HE WILL PROVIDE USAGE TO HELP
THE GIANTS GET BACK TO RUNNING
THE FOOTBALL WITH PHYSICALITY.
>> I LOVE IT.
YEAH.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
THEY WANT TO GET TOUGHER,
CONTROL THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE
AND GET BACK TO SOME OF THOSE
TEAMS THAT HELPED THEM TO WIN
SUPER BOWLS.
THE EVAN NEAL PICK.
BROCK T
KAYVON THIBODEAUX.
TIGHT END, PLAYS IN THE
BACKFIELD.
YOU ARE SEEING PASS CATCHING
JUICE AS WELL.
A NEW IDENTITY FOR THE NEW YORK
GIANTS TEAM.
THE WASHINGTON COMMANDERS TOOK
PERCY BUTLER.
GIANTS BACK ON THE CLOCK AGAIN.
>> FELTON IS A GUY COMING FROM
IOWA.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY DO.
THEY PLAY COVER 2.
THEY PLAY COVER 3.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WILL GET WITH
BELTON.
LINED UP, UNDERSTANDS WHAT HE
HAS TO DO AND HE IS A SHOOTER.
HE TAKES A RISK.
HE RUNS THE GAP.
HE WANTS TO MAKE A PLAY.
HE IS REALLY GOOD COMING
DOWNHILL.
HE IS AN ENFORCER, COMING
THAT IS WHAT YOU WANT.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE AFTER.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR IDENTITY.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR AN
ATTITUDE.
YOU ARE GETTING A BOX SAFETY.
I WILL GIVE IT A B MINUS.
I THINK THERE ARE BETTER
SAFETIES ON THE BOARD.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR A BOX
SAFETY THIS IS A GOOD ONE TO
PICK UP.
>> HE PLAYED IN THE SLOT A
LITTLE BIT.
NOW YOU ARE SEEING A GIANTS TEAM
THAT MIGHT LIKE IN THE
SHORT-TERM WHAT THEY ARE SEEING
ON THE OUTSIDE.
HE CAN PLAY IN THE BOX.
HE CAN KICK OUT TO THE SLOT.
THIS MIGHT BE THEIR TIGHT END
MATCHUP PLAYER.
THIS IS A B MINUS.
YOU KNOW MAYBE McKINLEY,
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SAFETIES.
BELTON HAS A DEFINED ROLE.
GIANTS ROOM, THEY ARE FIRED UP.
A GOOD START FOR THE NEW REGIME.
THE BRONCOS PICK BACK-TO-BACK.
CURIOUS TO SEE IF THEY WILL
TRADE ONE OF THESE PICKS.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE BRONCOS HAVE
DONE IN A SHORT TIME.
THEY BROUGHT BACK MELVIN GORDON.
BRONCOS, VERY ACTIVE IN THE MOST
COMPETITIVE DIVISION IN
FOOTBALL.
>> THE DIVISION IS REALLY GOOD.
IT KEEPS GETTING BETTER.
THEY HAVE SHORED UP THE
QUARTERBACK SPOT.
THAT I HAVE AN ALL-PRO AT
QUARTERBACK.
THEY HAVE A GUY THAT CAN GET TO
THE QUARTERBACK IN RANDY
GREGORY.
PICK IN.
THE BRONCOS ARE SELECTING
DEMARRI MATHIS.
DEMARRI MATHIS IS GOOD.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE THE
PHYSICALITY.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT COMES
FROM HEAD COACH PAT NARDUZZI.
HE INSTILLED THAT INTO THIS PITT
FOOTBALL TEAM.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT A GUY THAT
HAS AN ABILITY TO PLASTER TO
WIDE RECEIVERS.
I LOVE HIM IN PRESS COVERAGE.
A LOTERS RELY ON THEIR
SPEED TOO MUCH.
I AM SURE TORRY HOLT SAID YOU
COULD DISRUPT THE TIMING OF THE
ROUTE.
IT IS NOT JUST WITH YOUR SPEED.
YOU WIN BY GETTING HANDS ON AND
DISRUPTING THE ROUTE.
I THINK THAT MATHIS HAS GOT THE
SKILLS TO BE A STARTER AT CORNER
VERY SOON.
I DO NOT WANT HIM IN THE SLOT.
I WANT HIM AS AN OUTSIDE CORNER.
I WANT HIM IN PRESS SO THAT HE
USES THE SKILLS THAT THEY BUILT
IN THE MINI NO-FLY ZONE IN
PITTSBURGH.
>> THIS IS TAKING A DYNAMIC
ATHLETE AND TRYING TO TAP INTO
THE POTENTIAL.
THE 43 1/2 INCH VERTICAL.
ONE OF THE BEST ATHLETES IN THE
ENTIRE DRAFT.
I THINK THE INSTINCTS AND
FINDING THE FOOTBALL ARE NOT
THERE YET.
MATHIS IS SOMEONE THAT YOU WANT
TO USE THE PHYSICALITY.
YOU WANT HIM TO PLAY ON THE
BOUNDARY AND DRIVE GUYS TOWARDS
THE SIDELINE AND MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM AT THE CATCH
POINT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM COMING DOWNHILL.
INCREDIBLE ATHLETE.
I LIKE THE DEVELOPMENTAL CORNERS
ON THE BOARD A LITTLE BETTER.
I AM GOING TO GO C PLUS.
MORE SO WHAT ELSE IS LEFT HERE
ON DAY 3.
TORRY HOLT, ONE OF THE BEST
ATHLETES AT HIS POSITION IN THE
DRAFT.
WE KNOW THAT DENVER LOVES TO ADD
TO THE SECONDARY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> VERY EXPLOSIVE.
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO WATCH
HIM A LOT THIS YEAR.
AND HE IS A CONFERENCE CHAMPION.
HE BRINGS A WINNING ATTITUDE TO
THE DENVER BRONCOS ROSTER, AND
WE ALL KNOW THEY ARE TRYING TO
CHANGE IT.
THEY BROUGHT OVER RUSSELL WILSON
WHO CHANGED THE DYNAMICS AND THE
THOUGHT PROCESS OF THE TEAM IN
DENVER.
YOU BRING IN MATHIS WITH A
WINNING PEDIGREE AND NARDUZZI.
WE KNOW WHAT TYPE OF PLAYER HE
LIKES.
YOU TALK ABOUT A KID THAT IS
GOING TO COMPETE.
HE IS IS VERY PHYSICAL.
HE IS IS VERY EXPLOSIVE WITH THE
VERTICAL JUMP.
AND THEN THE ABILITY TO COME
DOWN THERE IN PRESS COVERAGE AND
MAN UP.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO DO THAT IN
THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE.
THERE WILL BE TIMES YOU HAVE TO
WIN YOUR ONE-ON-ONE MATCHUP.
I THINK MATHIS GIVES THE DENVER
BRONCOS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
MORE PRESS COVERAGE.
I LIKE THE SKILL SET OF THIS
GUY.
THE BRONCOS BACK ON THE CLOCK.
LET'S TAKE A BREAK.
>> McKINLEY, KOEHLER, WOOLEN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GUYS LEFT.
I AM HAPPY WITH THE GUYS OFF OF
THE BOARD THAT HAVE BEEN DRAFTED
SO FAR.
I LIKE DEMARRI MATHIS.
HE IS SOMEONE THAT ALWAYS WANTS
TO BE HANDS ON.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT MY BIG
BOARD.
HE HAS REALLY RUBBED OFF ON ME.
I CAN NARD, A THEME THERE.
ISIAH SPILLER.
DAMEON PIERCE COMES OFF OF THE
BOARD.
AND CALVIN AUSTIN.
HE IS SMALL, A TRACK GUY.
THERE ARE NOT MANY GUYS THAT RUN
AND MOVE LIKE THAT.
HE IS A GOOD ROUTE RUNNER.
I SAW HIM ABLE TO GET OFF OF THE
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE.
GET MY RELEASE.
GET TO MY ROUTE.
GET OPEN.
IF YOU GIVE HIM SPACE TO CATCH
AND RUN WITH THE BALL, GOOD-BYE.
THE BOARD IS GOOD.
I AM READY TO GET TO SOME OF THE
PICKS.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE MOVING TODAY.
WE ARE PUSHING THROUGH.
WE HAVE UWAZURIKE.
AWESOME.
A GUY THAT CAN GO OUT THERE AND
MAKE PLAYS.
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO PLAY IN
THE 2-4-5 DEFENSE FOR IOWA
STATE.
ANYWHERE FROM A ZERO TO A TWO
AND HE WAS ABLE TO GET THE JOB
DONE, SHOOTS THE GAP AND MAKES
PLAY.
I LOVE HIS ABILITY TO CREATE
SPACE BY ALIGNMENT DRAWING
EYEBALLS FROM THE CENTER AND
DRAWS EYEBALLS FROM THE GUARD.
THEN YOU USE THE SPACE AGAINST
THEM AND CREATE SPACE FOR HIS
LINEBACKERS TO MAKE THE PLAYS.
>> EYIOMA UWAZURIKE GOES TO THE
BRONCOS.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A LITTLE
BREAK.
WE WILL REMIND YOU A MESSAGE
FROM OUR FRIENDS FROM ROCKET
MORTGAGE.
ROBBER THE NEXT PICK, EYI
EYIOMA UWAZURIKE.
HE USES THOSE HANDS.
A SIX-YEAR SENIOR.
FOUR-YEAR STARTER.
ONCE AGAIN, THE SIZE AND THE
VERSATILITY IS SOMETHING WE
LIKE.
>> FOR SURE.
>> NEW YORK JETS ARE ON THE
CLOCK.
THE PICK IS IN.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE BROWNS MADE A
TRADE.
BROWNS HAVE MADE A TRADE FOR THE
VIKINGS' PICK AT 118.
OKAY.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE THE JETS
PICK.
JETS AT 117 STAY PUT AND TAKE
MICHAEL CLEMENS.
I AM GOOD.
DO DID YOU FEEL PASSIONATELY
ENOUGH TO BREAK IT DOWN.
>> NOT PARTICULARLY.
>> LET'S KEEP IT MOVING.
THE VIKINGS.
THE VIKINGS MOVED ALL AROUND THE
DRAFT TODAY OBVIOUSLY WITH A NEW
GM, COMING FROM CLEVELAND.
CREATIVE HOW THEY USE PICKS.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT
HERE, SOMEBODY WHO IS TRYING TO
GET MORE DARTS.
WE SAW THEM MOVING BACK FROM 12.
LEWIS CINE.
IS THERE A PICK ON THE BOARD
STANDING OUT TO YOU?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT HIM LAST
NIGHT, BRIAN HE BRINGSA A LOT OF
ENERGY TO THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
YOU LET HIM RUN AROUND.
I THINK HAVING A BIG NICKEL WILL
HELP YOU IN 12 PERSONNEL.
HE IS A LINEBACKER THAT WILL
STILL BE ON THE FIELD AS A
NICKEL TYPE GUY.
HE STOPS YOU FROM HAVING TO
BRING IN A SMALLER CORNER OR A
SAFETY.
BUT THEY STILL HAVE LARGE SIZE
PASS CATCHERS IN THE GAME AND
GUYS THAT CAN ACTUALLY STILL
BLOCK.
>> WE HAVE GOT THE VIKINGS HERE.
THEY MOVED UP FOR SOMEONE.
THE PICK IS IN AND IT IS EVANS.
CORNER, AGAIN.
>> MORE SECONDARY.
>> THIS IS A TEAM THAT NEEDED A
LOT OF CORNER HELP.
THE VIKINGS HAVE 156 AND A
FUTURE FOURTH ROUNDER TO COME UP
TO 118.
SOMEONE THEY FEEL STRONG ABOUT.
FASCINATED WITH THE TEAM.
LEWIS CINE PICK, SAFETY HEALTH.
ANDREW BOOTH WHO WE THINK WILL
BE A STARTER.
EVANS, THE SAME SPOT OR BACK TO
THE DEMARRI MATHIS TRAIN OF
TRAITS AND DEVELOPMENT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT IS TRAITS AND
DEVELOPMENT.
I THINK HE HAS GOOD RECOVERY
SPEED AND PLAYS THROUGH THE
WHISTLE.
THAT TRAIT FOR ME ONE OF HIS
LEAD TRAITS IS RELENTLESSNESS.
I WILL GIVE IT A B MINUS.
EVANS DID IT AGAINST ELITE
COMPETITION.
THERE IS THE IDEA THAT HE WAS
ABLE TO GO OUT THERE AND MAKE
PLAYS.
IF HE WANTS TO PLAY PRESS, HE IS
GOING TO IMPROVE.
IF HE IS GOING TO PLAY OFF, HE
WILL WORK ON COLLISION TO
RECEIVER.
THAT WILL BE AN INTERESTING
ELEMENT.
IN ZONE HE IS AN ADEQUATE
TACKLER.
THAT IS THE KEY FOR ME WATCHING
EVANS.
>> WE KNOW HE HAS LENGTH, 6'2".
I THINK WITH AKAYLEB EVANS IT
MIGHT BE A LACK OF BEING ON THE
FIELD.
TORRY HOLT, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> I AM WITH YOU ON A LOT OF
MISSED GAMES.
SO WHAT IS MINNESOTA SAYING
HERE.
WE BRING IN A GUY 6'2", 197
POUNDS, LENGTH, A GUY WE CAN
DEVELOP.
A GUY THAT WILL HELP US ON
SPECIAL TEAMS TOO.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
GREEN BAY PACKERS ARE DOING WITH
CHRISTIAN WATSON, THE 6'4" KID
THEY DRAFTED.
YOU LOOK AT THE BEARS.
YOU LIKE AT THE LIONS.
YOU ARE GOING TO NEED CORNERS
WITH LENGTH THAT WILL COVER AND
YOUNG PLAYERS THAT CAN PLAY ON
SPECIAL TEAMS AND GIVE YOU
TREMENDOUS VALUE THERE.
I THINK EVANS CAN DO THAT.
>> KICK COVERAGE, PUNT GUNNER.
>> ABSOLUTELY A GUNNER AND A
JAMMER.
>> AKAYLEB EVANS.
15 SNAPS PUNT COVERAGE.
A TON OF SNAPS COVERING KICKS.
LET HIM PLAY ON SPECIAL TEAMS
AND DEVELOP HIM AS A CORNER.
GIANTS GETTING MORE SECONDARY
HELP IN DANE BELTON.
BRONCOS BACK-TO-BACK WITH
ATHLETICISM.
THE NEW YORK JETS TAKING MICHAEL
CLEMONS.
AKAYLEB EVANS OFF OF THE BOARD.
LET'S TAKE A BREAK.
SAM HOWELL IS ON THE BOARD.
>> WHERE DO WE SEE SAM HOWELL?
>> WASHINGTON TO PLAY BEHIND
CARSON WENTZ IS WHAT I THINK
MAKES THE MOST SENSE.
CARSON WENTZ HAS BEEN HURT A LOT
AND GOES THROUGH SPELLS OF NOT
TAKING CARE OF THE FOOTBALL.
TORRE HOLT, THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING A DUDE PEOPLE SEE HAS
ABILITY AT THE POSITION.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT TO SOMEONE
LIKE YOU?
>> ONCE THE STARTER GOES OUT YOU
WANT TO PICK UP WHERE YOU LEFT
OFF AS BEST AS YOU CAN.
ARE THE ARM TALENT AND ABILITY
TO COMPETE, HE POSSESSES ALL OF
THAT.
YOU WANT THE SECOND TIER
QUARTERBACK TO COME IN AND
CONTINUE TO RIGHT THE SHIP.
BE EFFICIENT WITH THE FOOTBALL.
RUN THE OFFENSE EFFICIENTLY.
KEEP THEM IN FAVORABLE DOWNS.
THAT WILL BE SAM HOWELL'S
RESPONSIBILITY.
HE WILL BE A ■SECOND STRING
QUARTERBACK.
BUT I THINK HE HAS THE ARM
TALENT.
>> PLAYING IN STRUCTURE IS WHAT
I LOOK FOR IN SAM HOWELL.
NOT EVERYTHING NEEDS TO BE A
BREAKDOWN OUT OF THE POCKET RUN.
THE BALTIMORE RAVENS MADE A
PICK.
THIS IS ONE OF THE CORNERS THAT
I HAVE BEEN COMPLAINING ABOUT
GUYS GOING AHEAD OF HIM.
JALYN ARMOUR-DAVIS.
A LOT OF SIZE/SPEED CORNERS.
WE HAVE A TRADE COMING IN HERE.
WASHINGTON MOVING OUT.
THINGS ARE FLYING.
PANTHERS CAME UP FOR BRANDON
DAVIS. ARMOUR-DAVIS, YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT A CORNER THAT CAN
TURN AND RUN EVEN WHEN BEAT
VERTICALLY.
ONE-YEAR STARTER WHO IS STILL
PUTTING IT ALL TOGETHER.
BIG TIME EXPECTATIONS.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT AT ALABAMA.
A ONE-YEAR STARTER.
HE IS A GUY WHO IS A GOOD FRONT
SEVEN.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT SPEED.
LOOKING FOR HIM TO FIND THE
FOOTBALL MORE.
IT IS ALL THERE AND IT IS ALL
THERE FOR ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
DO.
I WANT TO SEE HIM BE A MAN COVER
CORNER.
ONE OF MY TOP CORNERS ON THE
BOARD.
I KNOW HE WAS TESTED LAST YEAR.
SOMEONE LIKE HUMPHREY WHO WILL
BE ABLE TO TAKE IN ARMOUR-DAVIS.
WE COME FROM THE SAME PROGRAM,
FOLLOW MY LEAD.
THAT WILL BE GREAT FOR HIM.
I LIKE THIS ONE HERE.
>> HERE IS THE THING, I DO NOT
CARE IF HE PLAYS MAN OR ZONE.
HE IS PLAYING ZONE COVERAGE.
HIS ABILITY TO SINK OR SLIP OFF
AND MAKE THE INTERCEPTION,
WATCHING HIS ABILITY TO RE-ROUTE
GUYS OR IN COVER 2.
CERTAINLY A HIGHER CEILING THAN
HIS TEAMMATE.
HE IS LINED UP THERE OVER A
BIGGER BODY, SLOW, PATIENT,
STILL ABLE TO GO THERE.
AWARENESS WITH THE FOOTBALL.
HE DENIES ONE ROUTE.
HE CAN LOOK BACK AND TAKES THE
BALL AWAY.
MAKES THE TACKLE THERE.
HE IS DOING MULTIPLE THINGS IN A
PLAY.
HE CAN PLAY MAN.
HE CAN PLAY ZONE.
I LOVE HIM IN ZONE COVERAGE.
I THINK HE HAS GOT THE LENGTH
AND THE CAT-LIKE ABILITY TO
SLINK AROUND AND KEEP EYES ON
THE QUARTERBACK.
I WANT HIS EYES ON THE
QUARTERBACK.
I AM GOING TO GO WITH AN A MINUS
PICK.
SOMEONE LIKE TARIQ WOOLEN MIGHT
BE A BETTER PLAYER BECAUSE OF
HIS LENGTH BUT THEY HAVE A
SIMILAR STYLE.
I THINK THAT GIVES IT AN A
MINUS.
THE RAVENS AND ALABAMA.
THEY FEEL THAT.
>> REMINDED ME OF ELI APPLE
COMING OUT.
HE JUST FINDS HIS WAY AROUND.
TORRY HOLT, ONE OF THE -- A
ONE-YEAR STARTER AT CORNER.
BUT THERE WAS BIG EXPECTATIONS
IF ARE THIS GUY AND HIS BEST
BALL MIGHT BE AHEAD OF HIM.
>> NO DOUBT.
I AGREE.
DOWN IN THE D.C. AND THE
BALTIMORE AREA THESE
ORGANIZATIONS LOVE PLAYERS FROM
ALABAMA.
WASHINGTON, BALTIMORE RAVENS.
I LIKE THIS KID.
HE IS 6'1".
HE CAN RUN.
YOU LOOK AT THE RAVENS'
SECO
SECONDARY, THEY WERE HURT LAST
YEAR AT TIMES.
NOW KYLE HAMILTON.
TREMENDOUS TALENT AT THE SAFETY
POSITION WHO BRINGS SIZE.
COUPLE IT NOW WITH THE KID DAVIS
FROM ALABAMA.
THERE IS MORE SIZE AND THERE IS
MORE LENGTH TO THIS RAVENS'
DEFENSE IN THE SECONDARY.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO COVER.
PLAYING IN THE A.F.C. NORTH, YOU
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO TACKLE.
>> THAT IS RIGHT AND SOMETHING I
THINK HE IS WILLING TO DO.
MICHAEL CLEMONS, THE BIG EDGE
FROM TEXAS A&M TO THE JETS.
VANZ, WE HAD TWO PICKS OFF OF
THE BOARD.
BRANDON SMITH, ONE OF THE BEST
ATHLETES IN THE DRAFT.
JACK JONES.
ONCE UPON A TIME SOMEBODY I
THOUGHT WOULD BE DRAFTED OR
EARLIER.
I WAS A LITTLE LOWER ON HIM BUT
ABSOLUTELY DEVELOPED AFTER
LEAVING USC FOR ARIZONA STATE.
>> HE CAME IN AS ONE OF THE GUYS
THAT IT WOULD BE A PART OF THE
CLASS USC WOULD BE BACK WITH THE
CLASS.
HE ENDED UP AT ARIZONA STATE.
ALL OF THE ISSUES THEY HAVE OFF
OF THE FIELD.
ON THE FIELD THEY DEVELOPED
QUALITY BALL PLAYERS.
HE IS ONE OF THEM.
HE UNDERSTANDS HOW TO READ HIS
KEYS, PLAYS HIS ROLES AND HE IS
NOT AFRAID TO BE IF PHYSICAL AT
THE CORNERBACK SPOT.
WATCHING HIM PLAY HAS BEEN A
TREAT.
>> ONCE AGAIN, IT HAS BEEN A
LONG ROAD FOR JACK JONES.
BRANDON SMITH.
ONE OF THE MOST ATHLETIC
LINEBACKERS IN THE DRAFT.
IT FELT LIKE HE NEVER TRULY GOT
COMFORTABLE AT PENN STATE.
REMINDED ME A LITTLE OF BROWNING
AT OHIO STATE.
YOU ALWAYS SAW THE SPEED AND
ATHLETE IN HIM.
MAYBE LOOKING FOR MORE OF A
COVERAGE BACKER YOU CAN DEVELOP?
>> YEAH.
HE IS THE REVERSE OF MICAH
PARSONS.
BRANDON SMITH, FOLKS WERE LIKE
HE IS GOING TO BE A BIG NICKEL
GUY.
HE IS LINED UP WIDE.
HE CAN DO THAT.
HE CAN PLAY, READ, REACT, MAKE A
TACKLE.
THAT IS THE BIG THING.
FOLKS VIEWED HIM IN THE ISIAH
SIMMONS ROLE.
WHEN YOU COME DOWN IN THE BOX IS
WHERE HE STRUGGLED TO FIND OUT
WHERE HE WILL FIT.
FOR ME WITH BRANDON SMITH.
I AM STILL GOING TO GIVE IT A B.
I THINK HE HAS GOT THE ABILITY
TO GO OUT THERE AND TO BE A
CONTRIBUTOR.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
I THINK HE CAN FIT IN THAT TYPE
OF A ROLE.
IF YOU GIVE HIM THAT TYPE OF A
ROLE HE WILL BE SUCCESSFUL.
HOW HE CAN RUN AND HOW EXPLOSIVE
HE IS.
I WONDER IF THEY WILL GIVE HIM A
LOOK AS A PASS RUSHER AS WELL.
BRANDON SMITH, AN INTERESTING
PLAYER.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A PICK AND
THIS IS AN EXCITING ONE.
A POWER BACK FROM GEORGIA.
TWO ACL TEARS AND HE IS HEALTHY.
HE RAN A 4.4.
TOUGH RUNNING.
CONTACT BALANCE.
THIS IS YOUR BETWEEN THE TACKLES
POWER GUY BEHIND AN OFFENSIVE
LINE THAT CAN BULLY PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE DEVANTE ADAMS AND
DARREN WALLER AND HUNTER
RENFROW.
NOT JUST A CHANGE OF PACE GUY
BUT A TACKLE BREAKER THAT CAN
MOVE THE CHAINS.
>> IT IS STAYING HEALTHY.
I LOVE HIM WITH A LEAD BLOCKER.
THIS IS A GUY FROM NORTH
CAROLINA.
ANOTHER ONE OF THE GUYS THAT
ENDS UP AT GEORGIA, THE SAME
THING WITH TODD GURLEY.
HE CAN GET THE JOB DONE.
HE IS SO TALENTED.
AS LONG AS HE IS HEALTHY HE WILL
GO OUT THERE AND MAKE PLAYS.
I WANT HIM WITH A LEAD BLOCKER.
I WANT HIM WITH GUARDS PULLING
IN FRONT OF HIM.
>> YEAH.
A LITTLE BIT OF A THROWBACK FOR
ME.
RYAN GRANT.
WHEN YOU GET HIM ROLLING DOWN
THE TRACKS, HE HAS THE SPEED AND
THE BIG BODY TYPE TO TAKE IN THE
CONTACT.
WHITE, A BIG TIME RECRUIT AND
EXPECTATIONS AT GEORGIA AND IT
WAS GREAT TO SEE HIM GOING OUT
ON A HIGH NOTE WITH A NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP AND THEIR LEADING
RUSHER.
>> MICHAEL IS RIGHT.
ANOTHER NORTH CAROLINA KID I HAD
TO SEE LEAVE THE STATE AND GO
PLAY FOOTBALL SOMEWHERE ELSE. HE
WAS A TOP TEN NATIONAL RECRUIT
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
HE CAN PLAY.
COMPETITION HE WILL NOT SHY AWAY
FROM.
HE HAS JACOBS.
SOMEBODY HE CAN LEARN FROM.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS INTERESTING
WITH THE RAIDERS.
I DON'T THINK THEY PICKED UP
JACOBS OPTION.
THIS CERTAINLY GIVES THEM
CUSHION AND SOME DEPTH BRINGING
IN WHITE WHO HAS PLAYED IN A
VERY TALENTED AND COMPETITIVE
CONFERENCE AND IS A NATIONAL
CHAMPION.
THIS IS A KBOOD IF I CAN FOR A
LAS VEGAS RAIDERS TEAM THAT
ADDED DAVANTE ADAMS AND OTHERS.
THE RAIDERS ARE SAYING THAT WE
ARE GOING TO THROW IT AND WE ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE ABLE TO RUN IT
WITH TWO LEGIT BACKS.
>> OBVIOUSLY JOSH McDANIELS
FINALLY LEAVING NEW ENGLAND.
WE KNOW NEW ENGLAND IS A
FRANCHISE LIKING TO SIGN AND
DRAFT CHAMPIONSHIP PEDIGREE
PLAYERS.
DO YOU THINK THE TREND FOLLOWS
OVER TO LAS VEGAS AND THE
DRAFTING OF ZAMIR WHITE?
>> YEAH.
I THINK ZAMIR WHITE AND THESE
GUYS CAN STAND UP ON THIRD DOWN
AND PROTECT DEREK CARR AND GIVE
HIM MORE TIME.
THESE GUYS CAN SERVICE, THEY ARE
THREE-DOWN BACKS.
DOWNHILL GUYS THAT CAN CATCH OUT
OF THE BACKFIELD AND GOT SOME
WIGGLE AND ARE STOUT ON THIRD
DOWN.
>> PERMANENT TEAM CAPTAIN OF THE
GEORGIA BULLDOGS, ZAMIR WHITE.
DRAFT RECAP.
WE ARE FLYING.
WE DID THE ZAMIR WHITE PICK.
HE ARE NOT SKIPPING THE NEXT
ONE.
IT IS ISIAH SPILLER OFF OF THE
BOARD TO THE CHARGERS.
ISIAH SPILLER, A FUN ONE FOR A
TEAM THAT KIND OF NEEDED THIS
DYNAMIC.
SPILLER, A GOOD FEET.
YOU CAN SEE THE ABILITY TO
CHANGE DIRECTION.
A LOT OF EXPERIENCE AS AN INSIDE
RUNNER.
SOME LE'VEON BELL.
THE CHOPPY FEET BEHIND THE LINE
OF SCRIMMAGE.
I CAN MAKE YOU MISS WHEN TRAFFIC
IS IN THE BACKFIELD, SHAKE A
DEFENDER OR RUN THROUGH A
DEFENDER.
I DID NOT THINK HE WOULD STILL
BE HERE.
WE KNOW AUSTIN EKELER WHAT HE
DOES IN THE PASS GAME.
ISIAH SPILLER, THAT BIG FRAME
CAN CARRY THE LOAD.
FOR ME THIS IS AN A.
I LOVE THE VALUE.
I LOVE THE PLAYER.
I LIKE TO SEE HIM IN THE
CHARGERS' OFFENSE.
>> I LOVE ISIAH SPILLER.
I TALKED TO MARK DOMINIC, THE
FORMER TAMPA BAY BUCS GM.
HE THOUGHT ISIAH SPILLER WOULD
BE THE FIRST RUNNING BACK OFF OF
THE BOARD.
I HAVE TO GIVE IT AN A PLUS.
FOURTH ROUND, SOMEONE PEOPLE
THOUGHT WOULD BE A SECOND OR
THIRD ROUND GUY.
HE IS SHIFTY.
HE IS A POWER RUNNER THAT NEEDS
A LEAD BLOCKER.
SPILLER IS A ZONE RUNNER.
WE ARE WATCHING HIM RUNNING IN
ZONE.
EXPLODE.
SEE THE CREASE.
HIT THE CREASE AND GO.
ZONE, FAKE INSIDE.
EXPLODE AND GET UP THE FIELD FOR
A BIG GAIN.
I LOVE THE WAY THAT HE PRESSES
THE HOLE.
>> I AM WITH YOU.
PATIENTNESS BEHIND THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE AND THE FEEL AS A
RUNNER.
TORRE
TORRY HOLT WHEN YOU SEE ISIAH
SPILLER, BIG EXPECTATIONS.
GREAT TO SEE HIM COMING OFF OF
THE BOARD HERE TO AN EXPLOSIVE
OFFENSE.
>> NO DOUBT.
VERY EXPLOSIVE OFFENSE.
JUSTIN HERBERT HAS TO BE SAYING
THANK YOU.
AUSTIN EKELER THAT CAN CATCH IT
OUT OF THE BACKFIELD AND RUN
BETWEEN THE TACKLES. AND THEN
YOU BRING IN ISIAH SPILLER.
HE IS A 4.6 GUY.
HE IS NOT GOING TO RUN AWAY FROM
ANYONE.
IT SAYS A VOLUME CARRY RUNNING
BACK, GOOD SIZE, TALENT AND CAN
BE CONSISTENT AS A PRO.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE L.A.
CHARGERS NEED.
A SOLID RUN GAME.
YOU HAVE JUSTIN HERBERT WHO CAN
THROW THE FOOTBALL.
KEENAN ALLEN AND THOSE GUYS.
L.A. CHARGERS ARE A LITTLE MORE
THICKER AND BROADER WHEN YOU ADD
IN ISIAH SPILLER.
>> I LOVE IT.
I AM WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
THE CHARGERS ARE MUST-WATCH ON
SUNDAYS THIS YEAR WITH THE YOUNG
TALENT.
LET'S TAKE A RESET AND LOOK AT
THE BIG BOARD.
THAT IS THE GUY.
WE TALKED ABOUT FERGUSON, CALVIN
AUSTIN.
TY
MALCOLM RODRIGUEZ.
A GUY I AM HIGHER ON.
A TACKLING MACHINE.
>> I LIKE HIM.
>> TALK ABOUT MALCOLM RODRIGUEZ.
>> HE IS A GUY THAT MOVES SIDE
TO SIDE REALLY WELL.
I DO LIKE THE FACT THAT HE CAN
RUN YOU DOWN.
HE PLAYED FOR A DEFENSE THAT WAS
REVAMPED THIS YEAR AND A TEAM
PLAYING A LOT OF COVER 0 AND
COVER 1 AND A TEAM THAT ASKED
HIM TO BE READY TO PEEL, WHICH
HE WAS ABLE TO DO AND ADD
YOURSELF TO NOT JUST THE RUN MIX
BUT THE PASS MIX AND DID THAT AS
WELL.
RODRIGUEZ IS A GOOD PLAYER.
HIGH QUALITY.
A HIGH I.Q. GUY.
HE RECOGNIZES THE SCHEME.
>> ALL RIGHT ARE WE GOING TO
BREAKDOWN THE KICKER PICK OF THE
DRAFT, CADE YORK.
>> I LITERALLY WAS LOOKING AT
GABE.
WE ARE NOT DOING THIS PICK.
NO.
WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF MY FAVS
ON THE BOARD.
WE ARE PAST THE HALFWAY POINT OF
THE FOURTH ROUNDS.
WE HAVE THE DOLPHINS ON THE
CLOCK RIGHT NOW?
>> YEAH.
WE DO.
WE ARE UP TO THE DOLPHINS.
THE BROWNS TOOK CADE YORK.
CADE YORK, THE REASON HE WAS
DRAFTED THIS HIGH, A LONG OF 56
LAST YEAR.
LONG OF 57 THE YEAR BEFORE.
BIG LEG KICKER.
I AM NOT A BELIEVER OF DRAFTING
KICKERS IN THE FOURTH ROUND.
THEY HAVE TO BE REALLY SPECIAL
TO GO IN THE FIFTH OR SIXTH.
I DON'T THINK HE IS THAT.
WE WILL SEE WHERE HE GOES.
>> I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT
KICKERS.
>> NOT REALLY IN THE JOB
DESCRIPTION.
BUT YOU DO KNOW ABOUT THESE
GUYS, McKINLEY.
INSTINCTUAL PLAYER ON THE BACK
END.
I THINK OUT OF ALL OF THE DBs
OFF OF THE BOARD IS ABOUT
McKINLEY'S TIME.
>> I LIKE HIM A LOT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER TRADE COMING UP.
THE RAIDERS TRADED PICK 126.
ANOTHER TEXAS TECH WIDE RECEIVER
OFF OF THE BOARD TO THE
DOLPHINS.
>> EZUKANNMA.
THAT IS AN EXCELLENT TRADE.
REALLY THE BARGAIN SHOPPING JUMP
BALL GUY OF THE CLASS.
IT IS NOT HIS FAULT.
I WILL SAVE IT FOR WHEN WE ROLL
THE TAPE FOR EZUKANNMA AND THE
RAIDERS CAME BACK UP TO GET HIM.
>> THE DOLPHINS.
THE RAIDERS NOW HAVE MOVED OUT
OF THEIR PICK.
NOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
THE RAIDERS/VIKINGS.
VIKINGS TRADED 126.
THE RAIDERS TRADED 165 TO 169.
>> DID NOT GET A LOT OF HELP.
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE JAYLEN
WADDLE.
THOSE GUYS ARE SPEED.
SHIFTINESS.
THEY CAN TAKE THE TOP OFF OF THE
DEFENSE.
EZUKANMA.
A JUMP BALL TARGET.
HE CAN GET VERTICAL.
LIKE DRAKE LONDON DOES NOT HAVE
TO RUN A 4.3.
>> HE CAN WORK UNDERNEATH.
HE IS NOT AFRAID TO SACRIFICE
HIS BODY TO MAKE THE CATCH.
THAT PUTS MORE TRUST AND FAITH
IN YOU.
>> I COMPARE HIM TO DAVANTE
PARKER.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE GETTING.
HIGHS AND LOWS OF COLLEGE PARK.
>> WHEN HEPARKER.
>> WHEN HE WAS HEALTHY, HE WAS
GOOD.
WE SAW THE RAIDERS TRADING UP
INTO THE SELECTION.
WE ARE SEEING NEIL FARRELL
COMING OFF OF THE BOARD.
WE TALKED ABOUT PERRION WINFREY
EARLIER IN THE DAY.
A GAP SHOOTER THAT CAN RUSH THE
PASSER.
NEIL FARRELL.
HE CAN TAKE ON BLOCKERS, STUFF
THE MIDDLE OF THE DEFENSE, STOP
THE RUN AND REALLY CONTROL
EVERYTHING AT THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE.
>> HE IS A BIG BOY.
I THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT SPOT
FOR HIM TO GO.
HE IS LARGE AND IN CHARGE IF YOU
WILL.
WHEN I WATCH HIM PLAY, HE DOES
HAVE THE ABILITY TO OCCUPY TWO
AND HE WILL DO IT WILLINGLY.
WATCHING WHEN HE PUTS THE PAWS
ON YOU, YOU ARE NOT GOING TO RUN
AWAY OR GET ANYWHERE OR REACH
THE SECOND LEVEL.
LET'S KEEP OUR LINEBACKERS
CLEAN.
LET'S KEEP OUR LINEBACKERS OPEN.
>> SOMEBODY THAT CAN EAT SPACE
AND NOT GET MOVED OFF OF THE
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE.
YOU ARE SEEING A LOT OF PLAYERS
WITH PLAYER COMPARISONS TO THOSE
THAT WERE ON THE TEAM AND NOW
THEY ARE TRYING TO REPLENISH THE
PLAYER TO THE TEAM.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE NEIL
FARRELL.
HE CAN PLAY NOSE, THREE, I LIKE
HIM IN THE MIDDLE.
>> SAME.
>> THE RUN STUFFER, CONTROLS THE
GUARD AND THE CENTER AND
REDIRECTS THE RUNNING BACK TO A
DIFFERENT LANE.
THAT IS GOOD SPEED FOR A GUY
THAT CARRIES A LOT OF WEIGHT.
I THINK HE PLAYS AROUND 330,
335.
GET THE BLOCKER OFF OF YOU.
KEEP THE MOTOR RUNNING HOT TO
RUSH THE PASSER.
A GOOD VALUE PICK HERE.
NOT A LOT OF GUYS IN THE CLASS
HERE ON DAY 3 THAT CAN CONTROL
THIS MUCH OF THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE.
NEIL FARRELL, I LIKE IT.
ROTATIONAL EARLY DOWN PLAYER.
THIS IS A B FOR ME FOR FARRELL.
>> I LOVE HIM TOO.
I THINK HE IS A REALLY GOOD
FOOTBALL PLAYER.
I THINK HE BRINGS A LOT TO THE
TABLE.
HE IS SOMEONE I WOULD GIVE A B
PLUS.
HE GOES OUT THERE TO MAKE PLAYS.
THE EFFORT AND THE WAY THAT HE
CARRIES HIS WEIGHT.
HE RAN A 5.41.
YOU CAN SEE THE BURST HE BRINGS
TO THE TABLE WHEN HE IS ON THE
FIELD.
I THINK THAT HE PROBABLY PLAYS
FASTER THAN THE 40 TIME AND HE
GIVES YOU EFFORT CONSISTENTLY
AND THAT IS WHY I THINK HE WILL
BE ON THE FIELD MORE OFTEN THAN
SOME EXPECT.
>> THE PATRIOTS, I BELIEVE,
FINALLY MADE A PICK.
PIERRE STRONG.
SMALL SCHOOL RUNNING BACK.
HE WILL KICK INSIDE TO CENTER.
THORNTON, THE BURNER.
JONES.
NOW PIERRE STRONG.
YOU ARE SEEING A THEME.
SPEED.
THAT IS WHAT IT IS.
NOW THE GUY RUNNING BEHIND HIM
IN PIERRE STRONG JR.
SOMEONE THAT HAS BEEN SUPER
PRODUCTIVE.
HE HAS GOT THE VISION.
HE HAS THE 4.3 WHEELS AND CAN
GET DOWN THE FIELD IN A HURRY
FOR THE BREAKAWAY SPEED.
I THINK THEY CAN GET CREATIVE
WITH HIM.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM USING JAMES
WHITE.
HE CAN WORK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
FIELD.
PIERRE STRONG, A SMALL SCHOOL
PLAYER WITH THE SPEED ON THE
TRACK SHOWS I CAN RUN AWAY FROM
NFL DEFENDERS.
NEW ENGLAND WENT SMALL AND
VALUED HIGH END ATHLETICISM.
STRONG, ONE OF MY FAVORITE DAY 3
RUNNING BACKS.
THE VALUE CHECKS OUT HERE.
I LIKE THE PRODUCTION TOO.
HE WAS A 100-YARD RUNNING BACK
IN 2019.
1694 IN 2021.
7.1 PER CARRY, 18 TOUCHDOWNS, 22
RECEPTIONS.
YOU WILL SEE NEW ENGLAND DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS FOR HIM.
THEY WILL DO THE SAME WITH
PIERRE STRONG JR.
AND I THINK HE HAS THE MENTAL
FORTITUDE AND THE PHYSICAL
CAPABILITY TO HANDLE THE LOAD HE
WILL BE ASKED TO DO.
I LIKE THE PICK.
I LIKE THE VERSATILITY HE
PROVIDES TO THE PATRIOTS'
OFFENSE.
>> I LIKE IT AS WELL.
PIERRE STRONG, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> HE REMINDS ME OF TRAVIS
ETIENNE.
IT IS THE SPEED.
IT IS THE SPEED TO THE WEAVE.
IT IS THE WEAVING STYLE THAT
GETS HIM TO THE END ZONE.
I GO WITH A B PLUS.
THE BIG KEY FOR HIM IS HIS
ABILITY TO WEAVE AND CATCH IT
OUT OF THE BACKFIELD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE IS IN PASS
PRO.
>> ALL OVER IT.
IT WILL BE CURIOUS TO SEE.
NEW ENGLAND HAS NO PROBLEM
TAKING A RUNNING BACK.
MOVING ON, THE BALTIMORE RAVENS
CONTINUE THEIR TREND OF LOVING
EVERY PICK.
THEY GOT MARK ANDREWS.
THIS IS A GUY WHO PLAYED A
SIMILAR ROLE IN COLLEGE.
HE WAS A LONG TIME PLAYER THERE.
KOLAR, MY 80th OVERALL PLAYER.
I THINK HE FELL TOO FAR.
TYLER HIGBEE IS WHO I SEE.
NOT A LOT OF 6'6" GUYS CAN RUN
AND CATCH.
IS HE AN ELITE BLOCKER, NO.
6'6", 252 POUNDS.
CHANGE OF DIRECTION AT THAT SIZE
IS RARE.
THAT PLAYS INTO HIS ROUTE
RUNNING.
A BIG FAN OF THE PICK.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE SOME KOLAR
BUZZ.
>> I LOVE THIS GUY.
HE ALWAYS BELIEVES HE HAS GOT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THE
CATCH.
HE MAKES CATCHES AWAY FROM HIS
BODY.
THERE YOU GO.
BACK OF THE END ZONE.
HE CAN SNEAK OUT.
HE CAN BLOCK.
HE IS NOT THE BEST BLOCKER.
HE CAN BLOCK A LITTLE.
I WILL GO WITH AN A PLUS.
I LOVE HIS ABILITY TO HELP YOU
TO STRETCH THE FIELD AND HIS
ABILITY TO WORK IN THE
INTERMEDIA AND OCCUPY PEOPLE.
WHETHER YOU HAVE HIM ON A
SPACING RUN OR A DIG, HE HAS GOT
THE ABILITY TO CREATE SPACE AND
TO OCCUPY THE VISION OF THE
SAFETY AND GUESS WHAT YOU GET.
WHEN THE SAFETY IS LOOKING AT
CHARLIE KOLAR, NOW YOU GET
SOMETHING BEHIND.
THIS IS AN A PLUS PICK FOR THE
RAVENS.
>> I AM WITH YOU AS WELL.
A PLUS FOR ME.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CATCH
RADIUS, 34.5 INCH ARMS, HE IS
PLAYS INTO IT.
KOLAR, EVERYTHING IS SUPER WIDE.
HE SEES AND TRACKS THE BALL
REALLY WELL AND HE KNOWS HOW TO
RUN.
SO, BIG HANDS.
YOU SAW THE ONE-HANDED CATCH.
HE CAN BE A A SEAM MONSTER.
FOR THE RAVENS' OFFENSE, WE SAW
THEM TRADING HOLLYWOOD BROWN.
THEIR ROOTS ARE 12 PERSONNEL,
SOMETIMES 22 PERSONNEL.
TWO TIGHT ENDS.
RUN NORTH TO SOUTH.
MAKE LIFE EASIER ON LAMAR
JACKSON.
THIS IS A NICE PICK IF YOU WANT
TO PAIR THEM WITH MARK ANDREWS,
THAT IS A PROBLEM.
LET'S TAKE A LITTLE BREAK TO
THANK OUR FRIENDS AT ROCKET
MORTGAGE.
OUR CRAFT COVERAGE IS BROUGHT TO
TU BY ROCKET MORTGAGE.
YOU LIKE THAT?
>> THAT WAS SMOOTH.
THE DALLAS COWBOYS ARE ON THE
CLOCK.
I HEARD THE COWBOYS' ROOM WAS
FLYING LAST NIGHT.
DALLAS FANS ARE VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT THE JONES' FAMILY DRAFT
PICKS YEAR AFTER YEAR.
LET'S SEE WHAT DALLAS HAS DONE
IN THE DRAFT.
IT WAS GREAT TO SEE THEM ADD A
WIDE RECEIVER LAST NIGHT IN
TOLBERT AND GOT OFFENSIVE LINE
HELP.
THE LAST COUPLE OF PICKS COMING
IN IF.
THEY ARE GOING WITH JAKE
FERGUSON.
THE TIGHT END RUN CONTINUES.
ANOTHER TREND CONTINUES BECAUSE
MY COMPARISON FOR JAKE FERGUSON,
DALTON SCHULTZ.
SO, DALLAS GETS ANOTHER VERSION
OF DALTON SCHULTZ, A GUY THEY
ARE PAYING FRANCHISE TAG MONEY.
YOU LOOK AT DALTON SCHULTZ, IF
YOU DECIDE NOT TO EXTEND HIM
LONG-TERM AND YOU LIKE WHAT YOU
SEE YEAR ONE FROM FERGUSON, YOU
HAVE A GUY ON A ROOKIE CONTRACT.
THIS IS A GREAT PICK TO
BREAKDOWN AND LET'S GET INTO IT.
JAKE FERGUSON TO DALLAS.
HANDS WENT FROM GOOD TO GREAT
AND CAUGHT AT LEAST 30 PASSES
ALL FOUR SEASONS, PRODUCTIVE.
IT IS FUN TO WATCH HIM IN THE
TRENCHES AS A BLOCKER, MOVING
PEOPLE OFF OF THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE.
GET HIM MOVING OUT WIDE TO TAKE
ON SAFETIES COMING DOWNHILL AND
OUTSIDE LINEBACKERS COMING
DOWNHILL.
FERGUSON, EXTREMELY RELIABLE
HANDS.
HE HAS BUILD-UP SPEED IF YOU
WANT TO RUN HIM DOWN THE SEAM.
HE IS IS A THREE-DOWN PLAYER.
YOU CAN PLAY HIM ON THE LINE,
OFF THE LINE OR HAVE HIM WORKING
IN THE BACKFIELD.
THIS IS GREAT INSURANCE FOR
DALTON SCHULTZ, AN A PLUS PICK
AND A TOP 100 PLAYER ON THE BIG
BOARD.
>> I LOVE HIM.
I DIDN'T THINK THERE WAS A BIG
GAP BETWEEN RUCKER AND FERGUSON.
FERGUSON FELT LIKE A MIDDLE OF
THE SECOND ROUND AND NOW YOU GET
HIM HERE.
GREAT VALUE.
A PLUS.
I THINK THE KEY FOR ME WITH
FERGUSON IS UNDER VALUED
ATHLETICISM.
THIS GUY ALWAYS FOUND A WAY TO
GET OPEN.
HE UNDERSTANDS ROUTE RUNNING
REALLY WELL.
HE IS IS A QUARTERBACK'S BEST
FRIEND.
DAK WILL ABSOLUTELY LOVE THIS
GUY.
HE WILL BE SOMEONE THAT
CONSISTENTLY IS OPEN.
CONSISTENTLY  LY CATCHES THE
FOOTBALL.
HE WILL BE SOMEONE THAT IS OPEN,
CATCHES THE FOOTBALL, MAKES A
PLAY AND MOVES ON FROM THERE.
HE WILL BLOCK.
MOVE BODIES FOR YOU WHETHER YOU
LINE HIM UP AS AN IN LINE TIGHT
END, WING OR BACKFIELD.
YOU MOTION HIM ACROSS TO HELP IN
OVERLOAD AND CREATE PUSH AT THE
GOAL LINE.
HE WILL MAKE SURE YOU GET INTO
THE END ZONE.
>> TORRY HOLT, HOW ARE WE
FEELING FOR DALLAS?
>> BALTIMORE ADDED KOLAR.
THEY ARE GOING TO STAY WITH
THEIR 12 AND 13 PERSONNEL.
COWBOYS ADDING JAKE FERGUSON.
THEY WILL TRY TO FWETGET BACK T
ESTABLISHING MORE OF A RUN GAME
WITH EZEKIEL ELLIOTT.
YOU ADD MORE TIGHT ENDS THAT ARE
GOOD IN LINE BLOCKERS AND GIVE
YOU VALUE IN THE PASSING GAME.
LOOK FOR THE DALLAS COWBOYS TO
GO WITH SCHULTZ AND FERGUSON,
DOUBLE TIGHTS AND PUT BOTH GUYS
DOWN THE SEAMS OR BOTH GUYS ON
CORNER ROUTES OR WILL USE THEM
IN THE RED ZONE.
TRY TO STOP THAT PACKAGE.
BOTH GUYS CAN GET OPEN AND CATCH
AND ARE SOLID, PARTICULARLY
FERGUSON IN LINE BLOCKING GIVING
YOU STOUTNESS IN THE RED ZONE.
LET'S GET EZEKIEL ELLIOTT BACK
GOING.
THE WAY TO DO IT IS ADD MORE
LINEMEN AND GUYS TO MOVE THE
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE.
>> I LOVE IT TORRY.
LET'S SEE WHAT DALLAS HAS DONE
IN THE DRAFT SO FAR.
THEY GET OFFENSIVE LINE HELP IN
THE BULLY, TYLER SMITH, SAM
WILLIAMS AND LOOKING AT THE PASS
CATCHERS.
TOLBERT, HE HAS NUMBER TWO WIDE
RECEIVER UPSIDE.
THEY TRADE AMARI COOPER.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR FOR CEEDEE
LAMB AND MICHAEL GALLUP.
>> 155.
>> THEY NEED A SAFETY.
>> I THINK THERE IS A CHANCE.
McKINLEY COULD STILL BE THERE.
IF THEY DON'T GET A SAFETY, WHAT
DO THEY DO?
>> THEY COULD STILL KEEP TAKING
SWINGS AT OFFENSIVE LINE.
IT HAS BEEN SHALLOW OVER THE
YEARS.
I KNOW THEY TOOK TYLER SMITH.
I AM WITH YOU.
I WILL SAY THIS, THE PUNT GOD IS
ON THE BOARD AS WELL.
>> ANOTHER PUNTER HAS COME OFF
OF THE BOARD.
>> I HEAR JORDAN STOUT.
>> HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
>> THAT SEEMS INSANE TO ME.
>> IF YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE A
PUNTER IN THE FOURTH ROUND WOULD
YOU NOT TAKE THE PUNT GOD?
>> THE ALL WORLD PUNT GOD.
>> I AM SHOCKED BY THIS ONE.
NOW, AS MUCH AS I AM NOT THE
BIGGEST STACK THE BOARD WITH
SPECIALISTS THEY WERE BOTH ON
THE TOP 300 PLAYER BUT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT A 100 PLAYER
DEFENSE.
WE HAVE PUNT ER B ROLL.
THAT IS INSANE.
FOR ME IT HAS TO BE SOMETHING
MECHANICAL RELATED.
IT COULD BE HANG TIME.
>> SURE.
>> YOU ARE SEEING IT COME IN.
WOW!
JORDAN STOUT.
I WILL SAY MAYBE THE CONCERN IS
THAT COFFIN CORNER, PINNING THE
TOUCHBACKS RATHER THAN LEG
STRENGTH.
I THINK WE CAN KEEP IT ROLLING.
>> WHAT IS NEXT.
RAVENS ROOM.
THEY HAD A DRAFT WHERE THEY
COULD HAVE TAKEN A LONG SNAPPER.
>> COOL.
>> WE HAVE FOUR FIRST ROUND
PLAYERS.
WE DO NOT CARE.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE TENNESSEE
TITANS ON THE CLOCK.
IF I AM WRONG CORRECT ME IN MY
EAR.
I BELIEVE THE TITANS ARE ON THE
CLOCK.
WE SAW THEM GETTING MALIK WILLIS
LAST NIGHT.
I WANT TO KICK IT BACK TO TORRY
HOLT.
RYAN TANNEHILL IN PLACE AND WE
KNOW THAT IS NOT CHANGING.
MALIK WILLIS, WAITING IN THE
WINGS NOW.
IT IS GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
HE HAS MORE TRAITS THAN RYAN
TANNEHILL BUT YOU NEED TO SEE
SOMETHING.
IS THERE PRESSURE IF THINGS
START TO FALTER WITH TANNEHILL.
MAYBE BY THE END OF THE YEAR DO
YOU LOOK AT THE GUY SITTING ON
THE BENCH SAYING WE KNOW HE
NEEDS TIME BUT HE IS MORE
EXPLOSIVE OF A PLAYMAKER.
>> I THINK YOU WAIT AS LONG AS
YOU CAN.
THAT IS THE GOAL.
THAT BOILS DOWN TO THE PROBLEM
IS THESE DECISIONS ARE NOT MADE
IN A VACUUM.
IF IT WERE UP TO THEM, WE MIGHT
LOSE OR WIN THIS GAME CLOSER
THAN WE WANTED TO WIN IT BY.
IF WE PUT THE NEW GUY IN MAYBE
IT WILL WORK.
YOU HAVE FANS CALLING IN TO
SPORTS RADIO.
YOU HAVE MEDIA ASKING QUESTIONS.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO SEE HIM.
THAT IS THE PART WHERE YOU JUST
HOPE THINGS WITH TANNEHILL KEEP
GOING WELL SO THAT YOU CAN WAIT
IT OUT.
THAT IS THE ULTIMATE GOAL.
YOU WAIT IT OUT.
IF YOU ARE FORCED INTO PLAYING
HIM BEFORE YOU ARE READY, YOU
CAN RUIN THINGS BEFORE IT GETS
STA
STARTED.
>> WE ARE GOING TO GET THERE IN
A SECOND.
THE TITANS MADE THEIR PICK.
IT IS HASSAN HASKINS.
THEY LOVE THEIR DOWNHILL
PHYSICAL RUNNING BACKS.
THEY KNOW WHO THEY HAVE IN
DERRICK HENRY.
HASKINS FROM MICHIGAN, A
DOWNHILL NORTH/SOUTH RUNNER AND
TACKLE BREAKER.
>> HE IS GOOD.
THIS GUY IS REALLY GOOD.
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN HE IS PLAYING
AGAINST TEAMS THAT HAVE A BUNCH
OF GUYS LIKE GEORGIA.
THE REALITY OF IT IS WITH HASSAN
HASKINS, HE IS A GUY THAT WAS
DOMINANT OVER THE COURSE OF THE
SEASON IN THE BIG TEN.
HE SHOWED HE CAN GET DOWNHILL
AND MAKE PLAYS.
>> ANOTHER PUNTER IS OFF OF THE
BOARD.
>> DID THE PUNT GOD HAVE TO GO?
>> NO.
JAKE CAMARDA FROM GEORGIA GOES
TO TAMPA BAY.
HE IS A DOWNHILL RUNNER.
THAT IS WHAT HARBAUGH BUILT HIM
TO BE.
I LIKE THE ABILITY TO COME IN
THERE AND SUPPLEMENT WHAT YOU
GRING TO GET OUT OF THE BIG GUY,
DERRICK HENRY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JAKE CAMARDA RAN A 4.56.
FASTER THAN NINE RUNNING BACKS
AND WIDE RECEIVERS AT THE
COMBINE.
WOW.
I DON'T THINK HE WILL BE RUNNING
DOWN THE FIELD AND MAKING A LOT
OF TACKLES WITH THAT SPEED BUT
MAYBE A POSITION SWITCH?
I AM JUST KIDDING.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE IS NOT
HAPPENING, MORE PUNTER TALK.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ROMEO DOUBS.
WE ARE EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT
GOING TO GREEN BAY.
THEY HAVE CHRISTIAN WATSON GOING
DOWN THE FIELD.
THEY TRADED UP FOR HIM.
NOW THEY GET ROMEO DOUBS FROM
NEVADA.
A TALL, SLENDER GUY AND YOU WILL
SEE IT HERE.
HE KNOWS HOW TO GET OVER THE TOP
OF THE DEFENSE AND FIND THE
FOOTBALL AND MAKE A PLAY
VERTICALLY.
WHEN I LOOK AT HIM, DARIUS
SLAYTON.
HE HAD STRAIGHT GAS.
THE QUARTERBACK COULDN'T GET HIM
THE BALL.
GOOD FOR HIM STRONG COULD GET
HIM THE BALL.
BEAT THE SAFETY.
I LIKE THE PICK FOR GREEN BAY.
I THINK IT WILL BE ONE OF THE
BETTER VALUE PICKS BECAUSE IT
FITS THE OFFENSE.
WHEN THINGS BREAK DOWN FOR AARON
RODGERS, THIS IS THE TYPE OF GUY
WE LOOK FOR.
WE HAVE SEEN IT FVALDEZ-SCANLIN.
>> ROMEO DOUBS, 6'2", 210.
THREE THINGS THAT STOOD OUT TO
ME ABOUT HIM.
ONE OF THOSE IS THAT HE IS A GUY
THAT WILL PLAY.
HE IS PASS INTERFERED WITH BUT
HE IS NOT BEGGING FOR A FLAG.
I LOVE THAT ABOUT HIM.
HE IS A BIG RECEIVER THAT CAN
WORK IN THE SLOT GAME.
THAT CAN WORK IN THE SLOT OR THE
SCREEN GAME.
HE IS NOT JUST A VERTICAL CATCH.
HE HAS GOOD RUN AFTER CATCH.
THE REASON THAT I KNOW THAT IS
BECAUSE HE IS AN EXCELLENT
RETURN MAN.
HIS ABILITY TO BE A RETURN GUY
HELPED HIM OUT.
WE DON'T SEE GUYS 6'2", 210 YOUR
PRIMARY RETURNER ON PUNTS.
I AM GOING WITH AN A.
ONE OF THE GUYS WE THOUGHT COULD
GO EARLIER BUT ENDED UP HERE AND
THEY ARE GETTING AARON RODGERS
HELP.
>> TORRY HOLT, YOU HAVE TO LOVE
A WIDE RECEIVER THAT CAN WIN
DOWN THE FIELD WITH SPEED.
IF DOUBS WAS NOT BANGED UP I
THINK HE WOULD HAVE RAN WELL AND
IT WOULD HAVE MOVED HIS DRAFT
STOCK UP.
>> A RETURN GUY IN THE FOURTH
ROUND AT 132.
THAT IS TREMENDOUS VALUE.
HE CAN FLIP THE FIELD POSITION
FOR YOU IN THE RETURN GAME.
THIS IS ANOTHER GUY 1,000 YARDS
IN 2021.
1,000 IN
HE HAD 116 SLOT SNAPS.
MICHAEL TALKED ABOUT HIS ABILITY
TO PLAY IN THE SLOT.
HE CAN PLAY OUTSIDE.
BUT WHAT I LIKE ABOUT HIM, HE
IS -- LET ME MAKE SURE I GET TO
IT.
HE'S A REAL DEEP THREAT GUY.
YOU TALKED ABOUT HE HAS A
QUARTERBACK IN COLLEGE THAT CAN
GET HIM THE FOOTBALL.
HE HAD A QUARTERBACK IN GREEN
BAY THAT CAN GET HIM THE
FOOTBALL.
THEY LIKE TO THROW THOSE DEEP
PLAYS DOWN THE FIELD.
YOU HAVE A GUY IN ROMEO THAT CAN
FLAT OUT RUN AND FLAT OUT GO GET
IT.
STAM -- SAMMY WATKINS, CHRIS
WATKINS.
>> SAMMY WATKINS IS A PRO.
HE'LL HELP TO GET THOSE GUYS UP
TO SPEED AND HE'LL PRAOBABLY DO
IT A LITTLE MORE DEMONSTRATIVE
THAN AARON RODGERS.
>> HA
HAVING A GUY THAT IS A LITTLE
MORE GENTLE THAN AARON RODGERS
WILL PROBABLY HELP THEM.
WE'RE LOOKING AT GREEN BAY'S
RECAP.
THE UCLA TACKLE SHAUN RYAN.
BACK TO THE DRAFT HERE, THE
49ers.
WE HAVE A PUNTER RUN FOLKS, AND
THE PUNT GOD IS STILL SITTING
THERE.
HEREFORD.
A TWO-YEAR STARTER GUARD.
I LIKE HIM AT GUARD AT THE NEXT
LEVEL.
HE'S SOMEBODY WHEN YOU GET HIM
AS AN EXPLOSIVE POLE AR, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO WANT HIM IN YOUR
LINE OF SIGHT.
>> WHEN HE WAS A RUN ZONE, HE
WAS ALWAYS OUT IN FRONT.
AS A TACKLE, HE PUSHED OUT IN
FRONT, FOUND A WAY TO NOT JUST
REACH THAT DEFENSIVE END BUT
HOLD THAT WITH ONE HAND, THEN
HE'S GOING TO LOOK FOR A
LINEBACKER SAFETY WITH OERT
HAND.
THAT'S WHY McCORMICK WAS ON MY
LIST.
IF YOU WANT TO GO DOWN ON THE
GROUND, HE'LL LET YOU GO DOWN ON
THE GROUND.
YOU SEE HIM HERE.
HIS ABILITY TO GO OUT THERE AND
GET SET UP, GET EVERYTHING READY
TO ROCK AND ROLL.
HE PLAYED THROUGH THE BALL
PRETTY WELL, BUT I LOVE HIS WORK
IN THE STRONG GAME.
HE GETS OUT IN FRONT OF SCREENS
WHICH YOU LOVE TO SEE.
THEY'LL HAVE THREE GUYS PICKED
IN THIS DRAFT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
GRADE ON THIS?
>> I'M GOING WITH A B+.
I THINK HE'S SOMEONE WE'LL SEE
PLAY IN THE NFL FOR A DECENT
AMOUNT OF TIME.
HE'S A PLAYER.
HE'S GOING TO BE A CONTRIBUTOR.
HE HAD CHANCES TO GO PLAY
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
HAD A CHANCE TO PLAY DAY ONE AND
NEVER GOT OFF THE FIELD.
>> THIS IS PICK 134 FOR THE
NINERS.
HE IS PLAYER 132 FOR ME.
HE REMINDS ME OF DAKOTA DOZIER.
HE'S GOT GOOD P LENGTH.
MAYBE IN A PINCH PLAY TACKLE.
I'LL GO WITH AN A MINUS.
THE HIGHEST RECRUIT EVER FOR
THAT PROGRAM, AND HE LIVED UP TO
EXPECTATIONS PLAYING GUARD,
TACKLE, HE'LL GO BACK TO GUARD.
>>> THE PICK IS IN, AND THIS IS
ONE OF MY PICKS OF THE DAY,
JOSHUA WILLIAMS, THE CORNER FROM
FAYETTEVILLE STATE.
HE IS LONG, HE CAN RUN, HE CAN
PRESS, AND HE DOES NOT CARE THAT
HE PLAYED AT A SMALL SCHOOL.
HE GOT DOWN IN THE FIELD IN
MOBILE, ALABAMA AND HE GOT AHOLD
OF THE BALL IN THE SCRIMMAGE.
HE COULD STAY IN THE POCKET AND
THAT LENGTH IS GOING TO HELP
WITH BALL SKILLS AT THE NEXT
LEVEL.
THE CHIEFS LIKE THESE LONG
OUTSTANDING CORNERS THAT CAN
RUN.
JOSH WILLIAMS IS A GUY I'M
PRETTY EXCITED ABOUT IN THIS
SPOT.
MY 94th OVERALL PLAYER ON THE
BOARD.
>> IT'S GREAT VALUE.
HE'S SOMEONE I KNOW YOU REALLY
LIKE FROM FAYETTE FILL.
HE IS LONG AND THE LENGTH IS
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL.
RICHARD SHERMAN TALKED ABOUT IT.
HE'S DEVELOPMENTAL, SO THAT
MEANS HE'LL HAVE TO GET GOOD
COACHING AND TAKE GOOD COACHING.
THAT WILL HAVE TO BE THE KEY FOR
HIM SO HE DOESN'T GET OFF
BALANCE, DOESN'T GET
OVEREXTENDED.
BECAUSE THEY PICK HIM HERE
INSTEAD OF PICKING HIM IN THAT
TOP 100, THE PRESSURE IS A
LITTLE BIT LESSENED, AND HE CAN
DEVELOP INTO A GUY THEY REALLY
LIKE WHILE HE GETS WORK DONE ON
SECOND TEAM AS A GUNNER.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT THE LENGTH
THERE, FELDER.
THAT IS IN THE 96th PERCENTILE.
TERRY HOLT, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YES, MAN, I LOVE LENGTH AT
CORNER AND JOSHUA WILLIAMS
CERTAINLY PROVIDES THAT.
FAYETTEVILLE, MIKE, I KNOW
THAT'S YOUR HOMETOWN.
HE'S GOT PLENTY OF DOG IN HIM.
ANYONE FROM FAYETTEVILLE HAS
PLDOG
IN HIM.
I HEARD HIM IN AN ENTER AS HE
WAS GETTING READY FOR THE DRAFT,
AND HE WAS SO PROFESSIONAL, THE
THINGS THAT HE SAID, HOW IN TUNE
HE WAS WITH THE CORNERBACK
POSITION, THE WIDE RECEIVER
POSITION.
HE AND JACKSON WERE COMPETING
AGAINST EACH OTHER LEADING UP TO
THE DRAFT.
SO JUST THINK OF THOSE ONE ON
ONE, 6'3", GOING AT IT.
HE'S A SMALL SCHOOL KID SO HE
HAS A CHIP ON HIS SHOULDER, AND
KANSAS CITY NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE, BEING MORE PHYSICAL,
HAVING SOME LENGTH ON THE
PERIMETER.
I LIKE THIS PICK.
36 VERTICAL JUMP.
HE CAN GET UP AND PRESS WITH
THOSE LONG ARMS.
45-YARD DASH FOR SOMEONE THAT'S
6'3", 195 POUNDS.
HE CAN RUN.
KANSAS CITY JUST ELEVATED
THEMSELVES ON THE CORNER WITH A
GUY LIKE JOSHUA WILLIAMS.
>> I LIKE IT.
YOU SEE KANSAS CITY'S DRAFT
EARLY ON.
THEY TAKE THE OPPOSITE ON THE
CORNER.
THEY GOT A LITTLE BIT MORE -- I
WOULDN'T SAY PROJECT, BECAUSE I
WAS TRULY IMPRESSED WITH JOSH
WILLIAMS.
GEORGE LOFTIS IN THE TRENCHES.
THIS IS A VERY GOOD DRAFT.
BUDDY, I WOULD SAY KANSAS CITY
GOT MULTIPLE STARREDERS RIGHT
THERE.
>> LOU CHANEL, THAT'S A GOOD
PICK.
THEY CAN USE THAT LENGTH TO
BOTHER THE REST OF THE DIVISION
WHICH IS GETTING BETTER AND
BETTER.
>> WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS TEAM
FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY TAKE PLAYER 229 ON THE
BOARD.
FELDER, YOU GOT SOMETHING FOR
ME?
>> I GOT A QUESTION FOR YOU.
IS HE GOING TO PLAY TACKLE?
>> NO.
>> I KEEP SEEING HIM LISTED AS
TACKLE.
>> YOU DO.
>> YOU HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HIM
PLAYING AGAINST GUYS THAT ARE A
BIT LOWER CENTER OF GRAVITY.
HOW DOES HE HANDLE THAT?
IF HE IS GOING TO KICK INSIDE
THE GUARD, HOW DOES HE HANDLE
THAT?
IF HE DOESN'T HAVE THE FEET TO
PLAY TACKLE, THEN YOU BETTER
HAVE THE KNEE FLEXION TO PLAY
LOWER IN THE RUNNING GAME.
>> I THINK MY PROBLEM, FELDER,
IS YOU TOOK A GUY GOING FROM
TACKLE TO A GUARD, RIGHT?
BECAUSE OF THE LIMITATIONS,
THAT'S WHY HE'S DOING THAT?
WHY WOULDN'T YOU TAKE SAWYER OR
KENARD WHO PLAYED AT A HIGHER
LEVEL?
THIS IS TOUGHER FOR THE BENGALS.
MAYBE THEY SEE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
LET'S TAKE A BREATHER HERE.
I COULD HAVE A SIP OF WATER AND
GET A MESSAGE FROM OUR FRIENDS
AT ROCKET MORTGAGE.
>> SEE THE BIG BOARD HERE.
WE TALKED ABOUT SAWYER AND
KENARD.
SAM HOWE, STILL WAITING.
THIS IS A PLAYER THAT IF YOU ARE
INSANE LIKE ME AND HAD TO WRITE
OR READ A MOCK DRAFT THE WEEK
AFTER LAST YEAR'S DRAFT, HE WAS
IN THE FIRST ROUND IN ALL OF
THEM.
>> YES, HE WAS.
NOT JUST IN THE FIRST ROUND.
HE WAS IN THE TOP 10s, TOP 15s.
>> HERE WE ARE.
I KNOW WE HAD A DOWN YEAR.
MICHAEL FELDER, TALK ABOUT UNC'S
SITUATION FROM 2000 --
>> CAN WE BRING TOREY IN ON
THIS?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU LOSE MICHAEL KACARTER, Y
LOSE JAVONTE WILLIAMS, YOU LOSE
ALL THESE PLAYERS.
SAM HOWE WAS A GUY WHO RAN FOR
800 YARDS THIS SEASON.
EVERYBODY IS LOOKING AT HIS
PASSING OUTPUT BUT THE GUY HAD
NO RUNNING GAME UNTIL THE LAST
FOUR GAMES OF THE YEAR, FIVE
GAMES OF THE YEAR WHEN TY
CHANDLER CAME ON PRETTY STRONG.
HE DID MORE THIS YEAR THAN THE
YEAR BEFORE.
HIS CONCERNS ARE THE SAME AS
THEY WERE GOING INTO THE SEASON,
WHICH ARE HE DOESN'T THROW WELL
BETWEEN THE HATCHES AND HAS SOME
ACCURACY ISSUES IN THE
INTERMEDIATE.
BUT HE WAS STILL A TOP 15
PROJECTED GUY WITH ALL THOSE
ISSUES, SO, TOREY, WHEN YOU
WATCH SAM HOWE, WHEN YOU SEE
PEOPLE TAULK ABOUT SAM HOWE,
WHAT'S DIFFERENT FROM A YEAR AGO
IN SEPTEMBER UNTIL NOW.
>> WHEN CARTER AND WILLIAMS AND
ALL THOSE GUYS WERE ALL THERE,
THEY WERE FANTASTIC.
HE HAD BACKS THAT COULD RUN THE
FOOTBALL AND HE OBVIOUSLY HAD
TALENT ON THE PERIMETER.
WHEN ALL THOSE GUYS LEFT AND
WENT TO THE DRAFT, HE WAS ASKED
TO DO A WHOLE LOT MORE.
YOU SAW HIM WITH THE RPO STUFF.
HE'S A TOUGH COMPETITOR AT THE
QUARTERBACK POSITION, AND THE
ABILITY TO THROW TO ME, I THINK
HE THROWS ONE OF THE BETTER DEEP
BALLS IN ALL OF COLLEGE BALL OUT
OF ALL THE GUYS THAT HAVE BEEN
CONSIDERED TO BE DRAFTED THIS
YEAR.
BUT WHAT I WANT TO SEE WITH SAM
HOWE GOING FORWARD IS SPEEDING
UP THE CLOCK INSIDE OF THE
POCKET IS WHAT I WANT TO SEE HIM
BE BETTER AT, AND MINIMIZE IN
THE TURNOVERS, MINIMIZE IN SOME
OF THE PLAYS THAT KILLS DRIVES.
WHEN THEY'RE IN SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY'RE MOVING DOWN THE FIELD TO
SCORE.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO SEE SAM
HOWELL IMPROVE, CERTAINLY, IS
SPEEDING UP THE CLOCK, AND YOU
MENTIONED BEING MORE AK RACCURAN
THE INTERMEDIATE PASSES.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT PART OF
FOOTBALL IS CRITICAL.
IN BETWEEN THE HASHES, OVER THE
MIDDLE WHERE A LOT OF THROWS ARE
MADE.
QUARTERBACKS ARE ASKED TO FIT IN
THE TIGHT WINDOWS.
SAM HOWELL HAS TO DO THAT.
HE HAS TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
THERE.
BUT IN TERMS OF COMPETITIVENESS,
IN TERMS OF THE DEEP BALL THROW,
A GUY THAT'S GOING TO GO OUT
THERE AND GIVE YOU EVERYTHING
THAT HE'S GOT, SAM HOWELL
CERTAINLY HAS THOSE.
IT'S THE OTHER ISSUES HE HAS TO
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE ON TO REALLY
HELP HIMSELF.
>> SPEAKING OF QUARTERBACKS,
GUYS, WE DO HAVE ONE OFF THE
BOARD AND IT IS NOT SAM HOWELL.
IT IS BAILEE ZAPPY HERE GOING TO
THE NEW ENGLAND PATRIOTS,
KNOWING THEY ARE IN THEIR
QUARTERBACK SITUATION.
IT'S SHOCKING, NUMBER ONE, BUT
KNOWING IT'S NEW ENGLAND, IT'S
NOT THE CRAZIEST THING.
BECAUSE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
TOTALLY DIFFERENT PLAYERS.
SAM HOWELL NOT ALWAYS PLAYING IN
BETWEEN.
YOU SEE ZAPPY, A GUY THAT WENT
TO HOUSTON BAPTIST, SET AY TON F
RECORDS.
A DOMINANT PLAYER THERE AND IT
CARRIED OVER WHEN HE TRANSFERRED
TO WESTERN KENTUCKY.
ARM STRENGTH, BELOW AVERAGE.
BUT ACCURACY?
IT'S THERE.
DECISIVENESS?
ONE, TWO, GET THE BALL OUT.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS. .
HE GOES THROUGH HIS READS.
GET THE BALL IN HIS HANDS,
HOPEFULLY THEY'RE SPACED.
HE CAN PLAY THE BALL WITH QUICK,
SHORT PASSES.
>> WHO IS HE BACKING UP NOW?
>> HE'S BACKING UP MATT JONES.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SAYING, HOW IS THIS NOT SAM
HOWELL?
THAT'S NOT THE GUY THEY WANTED.
THEY WANT THE GUY, DO WHAT WE
TELL YOU TO DO.
>> DO THE SAME THING THE OTHER
GUY ALREADY DOES.
THIS IS A ONE TO ONE FOR ME.
MATT JONES, STRONGER ARM, SURE.
BUT MATT JONES DOESN'T HAVE THE
STRONGEST ARM.
THIS IS A ONE TO ONE.
THIS IS WHERE YOU SEE A TEAM
PICKING A BACKUP, A GUY THEY
KNOW DOESN'T PUT ANY FEAR IN
MATT JONES.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE'S DOING?
THIS IS A GUY THEY KNOW IS GOING
TO LEARN THE PLAYBOOK, HE'S
GOING TO KNOW WHAT TO DO, HE'S
GOING TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO HELP
AND HE'S GOING TO HELP MATT
JONES OUT.
HEY, I SAW THIS, HEY, I KNOW
THIS, HEY, WHAT ABOUT THIS.
HE'S GOING TO BE INQUISITIVE,
HE'S GOING TO LEARN.
I SEE A GUY WHO THROWS INTO THE
INTERIOR.
HE THROWS A NICE, LAYERED DEEP
BALL.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT HE'S NOT IN
THE MIDDLE.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT HE
UNDERSTANDS WHEN THE BALL COMES
OUT.
HE DOESN'T BUY TIME.
HE KNOWS WHEN IT HITS, AND WHEN
IT HITS, HE'S GONE.
IF IT'S NOT THERE, HE'S GOING TO
GET THE BALL OUT OF HIS HANDS SO
THEY DON'T TAKE A SACK.
THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF HIS GAME,
AND IT'S A ONE TO ONE FOR MATT
JO
JONES.
IT'S CRAZY WHEN YOU SEE A
TEAM -- WHO WAS IT, MICHAEL
VICK?
THIS IS A GOOD ONE TO ONE.
YOU BRING IN A GUY THAT CAN DO
THE SAME THINGS THAT THE STARTER
CAN DO, JUST NOT QUITE AS WELL.
>> WE SAW THE B ROLL.
EVERYTHING IS THE SAME.
EVERY PLAY LOOKS THE SAME.
TOREY HOLT, SAM HOWELL GOES
SOMEWHERE THAT HAS HAD A SYSTEM
IN PLACE FOR A LONG, LONG TIME.
WHAT DO WE THINK ABOUT THIS
SELECTION?
>> I THINK IT FITS WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO.
HE'S GOING TO BE ASKED TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT MATT DOES.
A 57% COMPLETION PERCENTAGE.
HE COMPLETES A LOT OF PASSES.
WHAT DID NEW ENGLAND DO WHEN TOM
BRADY WAS THERE?
THEY MOVED THE BALL,
MATRICULATED THE BALL DOWN THE
FOOTBALL FIELD COUPLED WITH THAT
RUN GAME IN THE PLAY ACTION PASS
AND HIGH PERCENTAGE OF THROWS.
I THINK ZAPPE COMPLETES EXACTLY
WHAT NEW ENGLAND WANTS TO DO.
YOU HAVE A SOLID BACKUP IN
BAILEY ZAPPE AND HIGH-POWERED
THROWS.
THERE WAS TALK ABOUT THEM NOT
BEING A STRONG DRAFT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY THINK OF THESE
PLAYERS.
THESE ARE BACKUP QUARTERBACKS
THAT ARE COMING OFF THE BOARD.
BAILEY ZAPPE HAS A LOT OF
POTENTIAL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND I LIKE THE NEXT PICK THAT
CAME OFF THE BOARD HERE.
THE PITTSBURGH STEELERS WERE ON
THE CLOCK AS YOU SEE THE RECAP
HERE.
VERY INTERESTING DRAFT.
A LOT OF SMALL SCHOOL PLAYERS IN
NEW ENGLAND BUT GOOD ATHLETES.
VERY BELICHICK-ESQUE PLAYERS.
A THIRD ROUND GREAT FOR ME.
LET'S DIVE INTO CALVIN AUSTIN
WHOLY REMINDS ME OF -- THIS IS
PART OF THE DRAFT WHERE THE
STEELERS CHOOSE A FUTURE IMPACT
WIDE RECEIVER.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT CALVIN AUSTIN IS.
THAT 4'5" SPEED PLAYER.
ELECTRIC WITH THE BALL IN HIS
HANDS, ELECTRIC WITHOUT THE BALL
IN HIS HANDS.
SPRINTER IN HIGH SCHOOL.
BROUGHT BACK TWO IN MEMPHIS.
PLAYED OUT WIDE ON OVER 70% OF
HIS SNAPS, GUYS.
JUST BECAUSE HE'S 5'8", DON'T
MISTAKE HIM STRICTLY FOR A SLOT
RECEIVER.
GRADUATED WITH TWO DEGREES.
SO THIS GUY IS EXTREMELY SMART.
HE CAN HANDLE ANYTHING YOU THROW
AT HIM AT THE WIDE RECEIVER
POSITION.
HE CAN PLAY INSIDE, HE CAN PLAY
OUTSIDE.
HE HAS SPECIAL TEAMS EXPERIENCE.
THIS IS HIGHWAY ROBBERY FOR THE
PITTSBURGH STEELERS.
AN A+ PHENOMENAL PICK.
HE'S GOING TO BE HAPPY WHEN HE
WALKS INTO PITTSBURGH AND SEES
THE GUY GETTING OFF THE FLIGHT
BEHIND HIM.
KENNY PIGG IS GOING TO HAVE TO
KEEP UP WITH HIM.
YOU'RE GETTING HIGH VALUE, HIGH
PRODUCTION, THE ABILITY TO WORK
IN THE RETURN GAME, WHICH IS
GOING TO BE FUN, BECAUSE
PITTSBURGH HASN'T BEEN ELECTRIC
IN THE RETURN GAME SINCE WHAT,
BROWN?
I THINK THE KEY HERE IS STEALING
YARDS IN THE RETURN GAME,
HITTING YARDAGE, YOU FIND THOSE
HIDDEN YARDAGE PLAYS AND THAT'S
GOING TO HELP MAKE FIELDS S
SHORTER, KEEP THE FIELDS FLIPPED
AND THEN YOU HAVE BIG WIDE
RECEIVERS ON EITHER SIDE.
LET HIM RUN UP THROUGH THE
MIDDLE.
THOSE GUYS RUN THE SEVENTH, LET
HIM RUN INSIDE THAT LITTLE
SCENE.
LET THE SAFETY MAKE A DECISION,
AND IF THOSE TEAMS THINK THEY'LL
GET AWAY WITH TAMPA, TOO, YOU'RE
ABOUT TO SCREW YOURSELF TO THE
FLOOR.
>> I MEAN, YOU GOT JACE
CLAYPOOL, CALVIN AUSTIN, THE
WRINKLE THROWN IN.
TOREY HOLT, THIS GUY CAN FLY.
WHAT DO WE SEE?
>> YES, HE CAN.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WENT TO A HALL OF FAME SOURCE
ON THIS ONE.
I HIT UP MY PARTNER ISAAC ROOS
WHO PLAYED AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MEMPHIS, HALL OF FAMER, AND I
SAID, ISAAC, TELL ME A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT CALVIN AUSTIN III?
HE AIN'T SCARED, A WALK-ON
SCHOLARSHIP PLAYER, TEAM MVP,
PLAYS BIGGER THAN HIS SIZE AND
HAS LEGITIMATE TRACK SPEED.
THAT'S COMING FROM THE HALL OF
FAMER BRUCE ISAAC ABOUT HIM.
THE WIDE RECEIVERS ARE ALL FAST.
CALVIN AUSTIN III, HE CAN PLAY
INSIDE, HE CAN PLAY OUTSIDE, AND
HE CAN GIVE YOU SOME VALUE IN
THE RETURN GAME, AND YOU'RE
GOING TO MEET, AS WE CONTINUE TO
GO THROUGHOUT THE DAY, SPECIAL
TEAMS AND HOW CRITICAL THEY ARE.
CAN YOU FIND RETURNERS WHO CAN
FLIP THE FIELD FOR YOU, PUT
YOURSELF IN FAVORABLE POSITIONS
OFFENSIVELY.
YOU CAN DO SOME TALL SWEEPS WITH
HIM, YOU CAN DO JET SWEEPS WITH
HIM, YOU CAN DO SCREENS.
YOU CAN DO A LOT WITH CALVIN
AUSTIN III BECAUSE HE AIN'T
SCARED.
>> GREAT STUFF FROM ISAAC BRUCE.
THAT IS BIG TIME PRAISE FOR
CALVIN AUSTIN.
THE RAVENS PICKING HIM.
THEY MIGHT BE A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED THAT CALVIN AUSTIN
WENT OFF THE BOARD.
>> THE RAIFVENS LOOKING FOR A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF TIGHT END.
ZACH THOM FOR CENTER.
EL BE A CENTER FOR GREEN BAY.
THEY LOVE THE ATHLETICISM THERE.
I KNOW THEY DRAFTED JOSH MEYERS
LAST YEAR.
DON'T FORGET, WE ARE A COUPLE
PICKS FROM THE FIFTH ROUND.
NOT EVERYTHING HAS TO BE A
STARTING PLAYER.
DEPTH, DEVELOPMENTAL TALENT, AND
TOMORROW DARIO WILLIAMS FROM
HOUSTON WENT TO THE RAVENS AS
WELL.
I THINK WE KICKED BACK TO THE
ISAIAH LIKELY PICK FOR A SECOND
AND GET AWAY FROM THE OFFENSIVE
LINE FOR A SECOND.
FELDER, BIG TIME PRODUCTION
AGAINST NORTH CAROLINA.
ONE OF THE MORE DYNAMIC PLAYERS
WITH THE TIGHT END POSITION WITH
A BALL IN HIS HANDS.
WHAT IS HIS TRANSITION WALKING
INTO A ROOM AND BEING THE THIRD
GUY.
>> I DON'T THINK HE VIEWS
HIMSELF AS THE THIRD GUY.
>> HE NEVER HAS BEEN.
>> WHAT IS HE, 129 VERSUS --
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
US?
>> COMPETE P. MARK ANDREWS MIGHT
BE THE GUY, BUT HE'S NOT AS FIRM
AS COHEN.
WHEN YOU WATCH THEM PLAY, THIS
IS A GUY THAT FINDS A WAY TO GET
FOAM.
.
THAT IS A SAFETY HE'S BEATING.
HE'S STILL GOT SOME NICE SCOOP
TO HIS GAME.
A IRCHT GAME, BUT --
>> RUN AWAY.
RUN AWAY.
>> HE'S NOT JUST AN IMPRESSIVE
GUY, BUT WHEN YOU WATCH HIM
PLAY, YOU SEE HIS ABILITY TO RUN
AWAY FROM GUYS -- SOME OF THESE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FOUR, FOUR
GUYS.
I GO WITH AN A RIGHT HERE.
YOU GO OUT OF COASTLY.
THIS GUY IS GOING TO BE A PLAYER
FOR THEM.
NOW THIS GIVES THE RAVENS 13
PERSONNEL?
BUT WITH THREE PASSES TO TIE IT
IN, WHAT DO YOU DO?
USUALLY THAT MEANS YOU PUT YOURT
BIG BOYS IN, YOU THROW IN A
BEARFRONT F. MANY YOU COME IN
BEHIND THESE GUYS, YOU MIGHT
HAVE GUYS THAT ARE LEAKING OUT.
ISAIAH IS THE PERFECT
LINEBACKER.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
YOU WANT TO GET HIS BALL.
MARK ANDREWS IS ONE OF THE BEST
PASSERS IN THE LEAGUE.
THAT'S WHAT THE RAVENS DO.
THEY RETOOL.
THEY DON'T SPEND AYTO TON OF MO
IN THE AGENCY.
TOREY HOLT, WHAT ARE WE THINKING
FOR BALTIMORE?
ANOTHER TIGHT END ON THE BOARD.
>> THAT'S WHERE JACKSON AND HIS
OFFENSE ARE VERY COMFORTABLE.
YOU MENTIONED HOW MANY LONG
PLAYS HE HAD THERE IN COASTAL
CAROLINA.
I THINK YOU'LL HAVE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE WITH THE
BALTIMORE RAVENS.
IT BRINGS HIM TO A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF ATHLETICISM.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE BALTIMORE
RAVENS, I LIKE THE TIGHT ENDS
THAT THEY HAVE AND WHICH THEY'RE
DRAFTING, WHICH IS COOL.
BUT WHO IS GOING TO PRESS THE
ISSUE OUT ON THE PERIMETER.
I KNOW IN THE FIRST ROUND PICK
LAST YEAR, WHO IS REALLY
LEGITIMATELY GOING TO PRESS THE
ISSUE OUT ON A PERIMETER WHEN
LAMAR JACKSON CAN MAKE THOSE
FREE THROWS, BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
MIDDLE OF THE FIELD HAS BEEN
FOUPD.
I WANT TO WAUCHL.
BUT TIGHT ENDWISE, WE'RE SET.
>> I'M WITH YOU, TOREY.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER IF THEY GOT
JUMPED A LITTLE FROM THEIR
WOO
WOOIFLS.
>>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
BALTIMORE RAVENS DRAFT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
I THINK THEICALLY GET HIM A
BETTER FINISH IN TYLER LINDEN
BALM LD.
TROY ANDERSON, DO YOU SEE THE
SPEED THERE?
I BELIEVE IT WENT TO IT IF THE
ROUND 1 PLAYER FOR ME.
SKY SCRAPER GOT BRILLIANT, GUYS,
AND I'M READY TO SAY IT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PICKS LEFT TO
DO, I WON'T PUT THE ACTUAL
FUNERAL.
>> THE BALTIMORE RAVENS, AS IT
STANDS, THIS IS AN A FOR ME,
GUZ.
TLFLSZLY, LEARNING OFF OF OZZIE,
HAD TO RETOOL THE ROSTER.
>> THEY'RE DOING WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY'RE A RUNNING FOOTBALL TEAM.
THEIR RUN IS BREADED WITH THE
END GAME P.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT OVER THE
TOCHLT.LY.
P I THINK THAT'S THE NEXT STEP
FOR THE RAVENS TO GET BACK TO
WHERE THEY WANT TO BE.
>> I'M WITH YOU, FLEMPLT.
>>> WE HAD SOME PIKS COME IN.
A PLAYER FROM HOUSTON THAT HAS
PLAYED OUTSIDE IN THE SLOT, IN
THE BOX, AS A LITTLE BIT OF A
SAFETY QUICK HITTER ON DEMAR
WILLIAMS IF YOU.
HE'S THE GIMPLT.
YOU THINK HE'S A STEADFAST GUY,
NOT AS FAST AS JONES.
BUT HE IS SOMEONE THAT PLAYS LOT
OF DEFINLT.
I SAID IRV TO GET THIS
STRAIGHTENED OUT BEFORE THE
QUARTERBACK PUTS A BALL IN ART.
AND HE DOES THAT REALLY, REALLY
WELL.
>> THE RAMS WERE ON THE CLOCK
AND MADE A SELECTION.
THEY WENT WITH KOBE DURANT FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA STATE WHO I DO
WANT TO PAUSE HERE AND BREAK
QUICKLY.
LITTLE BIT OF A -- NOT A 4
EIGHT-WHEELS T.
>> HE IS A BAITER, RIGHT?
THIS GUY LIKES TO DEBATE YOU AND
TAKE THE BALL AWAY.
I THINK HE CAN DO THAT PLAYING
IN THE CONFERENCE HE PLAYED IN,
BUT HE ALSO HAD A COUPLE
INTERCEPTIONS AGAINST CLEMSON.
HE'S SOMEONE THAT WANTS TO -- HE
TRUSTS HIS RECOVERY SPEED
TREMENDOUSLY, AND HE UNDERSTANDS
WHEN THE BALL IS GOING TO COME
OUT SO HE UNDERSTANDS WHEN TO
ACCELERATE.
WE TALK ALL THE TIME WITH THEM
PLAYING WITH TEMPO.
I THINK KOBE DURANT IS P A RARE
BACK THAT UNDERSTANDS THAT HE
TEMPO.
HE KNOWS WHERE TO ACCELERATE TO
MAKE A PLAY.
>> WE HAD SHIGA KWACONQUO FROM
MARYLAND.
YOU CAN MOVE OFF THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE.
HE'S A FASCINATING PLAYER TO ME,
FELDER.
I THINK THIS IS A CLASSIC
TENNESSEE.
YOU SEE WHAT THEY'VE HAD OVER
THE YEAR.
DELANIE WALKER, THEY LOST A
TIGHT END TO D.C.
>> I LIKED HIM.
I LIKED HIM COMING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
I WAS GLAD HE STUCK AROUND AND
WENT TO MARYLAND.
THIS IS A GUY THAT CAN RUN FAST.
IF HE'S GETTING SIDE BY SIDE
WITH THE LINEBACKER IN THE
MIDDLE, I THINK HE'S IN HIS BEST
PROBABLY -- I WANT HIM TON IN
THE RED IN HIS WAR ZONE, BUT I
THINK HE'S BETTER AT THAT ACROSS
THE AREA.
THAT'S WHEN HE'S AT HIS BEST.
THE FIELD IS STILL WAY BIGGER.
I THINK HE'LL FIND A WAY TO BE
MORE OF A THREAT IN THE RED ZONE
WHERE THE FIELD GETS CHOKED
DOWN.
>> WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS
FOR A WHILE.
WE'RE ON THE CLOCK TO KICK OFF
ROUND 5 TODAY, AND SAM HOWELL IS
OFF THE BOARD.
WHAT DID I SAY EARLIER IN THE
SHOW ABOUT CARSON WENTZ?
A GUY THAT HASN'T BEEN BANGED
UP, A GUY THAT CAN PLAY OUT OF
STRUCTURE LIKE SAM HOWELL DOES.
YOU'RE PAYING HIM FOR ONE YEAR
OF GUARANTEED MONEY.
SAM HOWELL, YOU KNOW IT'S THE
FIFTH ROUND.
HE'S NOT COMING IN TO BE ALY.
HE'S NOT GOING TO PLAY THIS YEAR
IN CASE CARSON WERNLTS BIG ARM,
CAN PUSH THE BALL DOWN THE
FIELD.
A LOT OF.
IF HE COULD DIAL IT DOWN DAUSH I
DON'T NEED EVERYTHING TO BE A
DRAWBACK PASS.
CAN YOU GET IT TO WHERE YOU'RE
CAPABLE IN STRUCTURE?
THAT WOULD BE A BIG TIME WIN FOR
SAM HOWELL O., WHUL WE DI-- YOU
GET AHIM AT 145.
>> YOU HAVE TERRY McLAUREN, HE
CAN STRETCH THE BALL DOWN THE
FIELD.
HE CAN PUSH IT VERTICALLY VERY,
VERY WELL.
WE HAVE TO WORK ON GETTING THE
BALL IN THE HATCHES.
EVERYTHING HE DOES ON THE
SIDELINE OUTSIDE THE NUMBERS ARE
BEAUTIFUL.
LOVER TO SEE THAT.
HE'S GOT TO WORK BETTER AT
GETTING THE BALL IN BETWEEN THE
HASHES SO HE CAN GET THEM TOLY.
URNG..
THEY WILL BE A THING PUTTING HIM
IN POSITION TO ROLL OUT.
IT PUT HIM IN THE POSITION TO
ROLL OUT, ONCE THE PLAY BREAKS
DOWN, FIND SOMETHING ELSE.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT AN A+.
THE REAL KEY FOR ME IS THEY'RE
GETTING A PLAYER THAT IS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT THERE IF
PRESSED.
THIRD QUARTER, THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE IN THE FOOTBALL GAME.
WENTZ GOES DOWN.
LET'S BRING IN SAM OFF THE
BENCH.
HE'S GOING TO TRY TO CHUCK IT UP
THERE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> THERE ARE YOUNG QUARTERBACKS
THAT CAN RUN THAT ARE
UNDERDEVELOPED.
IT BUYS THEM TIME TO DEVELOP.
BECAUSE WHEN ALL ELSE FAILS, YOU
CAN RUN.
YOU CAN FORCE THE LINEBACKERS
UP.
YOU CAN GET CREATIVE.
TOREY HOLT, SAM HOWELL OFF THE
BOARD HERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THE 101s, THEY'RE GOING TO GO
DEEP BECAUSE HE'S THROWING TO A
GUY, THROWING TO A COLLEGE HE'S
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH.
I LIKE SAM HOWELL'S ATHLETICISM.
NOW YOU HAVE HIM IN THE FOLD.
YOU CAN DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY
OFFENSIVELY.
HE'S REALLY ATHLETIC AND AGILE
WITH HIS FEET.
AS MIKE MENTIONED, TOO, THE BALL
DOWN THE FIELD, HE'S THE BEST IN
THIS DRAFT CLASS.
HE'S ONE OF THE ELITE WIDE
RECEIVERS IN THE ACC COMING
BACK.
I LIKE SAM HOWELL'S MOXY.
HE COMPLETED 22% OF HIS PASSES.
HE CAN LEARN BEHIND CARSON WENTZ
AND CARSON WENTZ HAS A LOT TO
SHARE WITH HIM.
HE'S HAD A JOURNEY HIMSELF IN
THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE HE
CAN SHARE WITH SAM HOWELL.
SAM HOWELL IS A VERY
COMPETITIVE, VERY COMPETENT
QUARTERBACK THAT DOESN'T, AGAIN,
HAVE TO COME IN AND SAVE
WASHINGTON, BUT BECAUSE OF HIS
WILLS AND HIS DEEP BALL
ACCURACY, HE CAN HELP.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A THEME
HAS JAMARI BROWN.
THIS IS A GUY THAT IT SEEMS LIKE
A PLAN TO ME.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY'RE THROWING
ALL THEIR CHIPS ON A FOURTH
ROUND QUARTERBACK, BUT YOU CAN
SEE OFFENSE DEVELOPING.
CAN YOUR BACKUP COME IN AND
EXECUTE THE OFFENSIVES?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE WE
ARE IN THIS DRAFT RIGHT NOW.
UP NEXT ON THE CLOCK, GIANTS,
GIANTS, BEARS, WASHINGTON,
BEARS.
A LOT OF DOUBLE RUNS HERE.
DAY THREE GETS NUTS.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF DEFENSIVE
PICKS, TRADED PICKS, LOTS OF
MOVEMENT.
WE
WE HAVE THE QUARTERBACK PICTURE
HAS KIND OF COME FULL CIRCLE.
WE SAW PICKETT GO ABOUT ONE,
MALIK WILLIS TO TENNESSEE.
BAILEY ZAPPE.
WE STILL HAVE CARSON STRONG ON
THE BOARD.
LET'S DISCUSS WHERE WE ARE ON
THESE DRAFT PICKS.
WE HAVE THE CHIEFS IN ROUND 5.
ONE OF THE BEST PLAYERS IN
DERRICK -- DARIAN KENNARD.
>> WE THOUGHT HE WOULD BE A
SECOND ROUND GUY.
ENDED UP IN FIFTH ROUND.
GOOD BALL PLAYER, A FIGHTER.
SOMEONE YOU SEE HERE AS YOU GO
INTO IT.
DARION KINNARD, TO CREATE SPACE
FOR THAT VIOLENT KENTUCKY DRAFT.
HE CAN DO THOSE THINGS AT THE
TACKLE SPOT.
WE EXPECT HIM TO MOVE TO GUARD,
BUT HE'S ABLE TO PICK UP THE
SPIN MOVE, PUSH HIM DOWN INSIDE
AND THEY END UP WITH A
TOUCHDOWN.
I REALLY LIKE DARION KINNARD.
I GIVE HIM AN A+.
YOU CAN'T PLAY HIM EARLY BUT YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PLAY HIM
EARLY IF YOU NEED TO.
WE KNOW HE'S GOING TO BE A
CONTENDER TO GET SOME EARLY
PLAYING TIME IF THERE'S AN
INJURY.
>> 61st OVERALL PLAYER FOR ME IN
THIS DRAFT.
IT BUILDS THE WAY, REDIRECTS --
I LOOK AT THIS AND THINK ONE
THING BESIDES VALUE.
IT TOOK TREY SMITH IN THE SIXTH
ROUND LAST YEAR.
HE GOT INTO CAMP, WAS BETTER
THAN EVERYBODY, EARNED A STARTER
JOB.
WE KNOW TREY SMITH HAD SOME
MEDICAL SITUATIONS IN TENNESSEE.
WHEN HE'S ON THE FIELD, HE'S
AMAZING.
WHEN TREY SMITH GETS BANGED UP,
HE CAN GO IN AS RIGHT TACKLE.
61st OVERALL PLAYER.
THE CHIEFS, I THINK, WILL BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A PHYSICAL
RUNNING TEAM.
THEY'LL ALWAYS BE A RUNNING
TEAM.
ONE OF THE MOST CONSISTENT
CONTENDERS, AND LET'S HEAR IT.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT -- THEY'VE
PUT OUT SOME GUYS IN THE DRAFT
THIS YEAR.
AS YOU GUYS MENTIONED, YOU CAN
MOVE HIM DOWN INSIDE IF YOU WANT
TO.
HE'S GOT LONG ARMS, A PUNCH,
37-INCH ARMS AND BIG HANDS SO
HE'S PACKING A PUNCH.
BUT HE CAN MOVE SOUTH AND PLAY
GUARD.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE KANSAS
CITY CHIEFS WANT TO DO, THEY
WANT TO BE PHYSICAL WITH MU
MULAIRE, WHICH I THINK WILL BE
HIS BREAKOUT YEAR, AND KINNARD
PROVIDES THEM THE DEPTH.
THE PERIMETER ON THE OUTSIDE
TACKLE POSITION, AND IF YOU WANT
TO KICK HIM INSIDE AND BRING
SOME MORE PHYSICALITY, BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO RUN THE FOOTBALL,
YOU CAN KICK HIM INSIDE AS WELL
ALONG WITH THE REST OF THE
OFFENSIVE LINE.
I LIKE THIS PICK FOR KANSAS
CITY.
AS YOU MENTIONED, CONNOR, THE
VALUE OF WHERE THEY'RE GETTING
HIM BUT THE VERSATILITY HE
PROVIDES.
HE'S PLAYED IN THE SCC -- YOU
KNOW WHAT THE SCC HAS, THEY HAVE
PREMIERE DEFENSIVE TACKLES THAT
CAN GET AFTER YOU.
THIS GUY HAS SEEN THEM ALL.
I THINK DARION KINNARD CAN FILL
IN VERY WELL WITH ANDY REID AND
HOW THEY DEVELOP THEIR PLAYERS.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE GOT A LITTLE
BIT OF TRADE ACTION HERE.
CHICAGO HAS TRADED UP TO 148.
THEY TRAIDED 148 TO BUFFALO.
THE GIANTS ARE PICKING BACK TO
BACK.
I DO NOT WANT TO SKIP THE
GIANTS.
WE GOT THE FIRST ONE WHICH IS
MICHAEL McFADDEN, INDIANA,
LINEBACKER.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE BIG
BOARD.
TYLER ALLGEIER, THE RUNNING
BACK, BO MULLEN FROM RUTGERS.
>> WE'VE GOT KOHLER -- KOLAR ON
THE BOARD.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GUYS THAT ARE
STILL QUALITY BALL PLAYERS UP
THERE.
THE CRAZY THING IS, YOU LOOK AT
THIS SHEET, AND PIERCE STRONG,
HE'S A BALL PLAYER.
THAT'S NOT A MOUTHFUL.
>> NAILED IT.
>> YOU THROW IN BAILEY ZAPPE,
ANOTHER GUY I WATCH A LOT PLAY
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO DYNAMIC IN
BRINGING OVER THE RECEIVER.
AND A REALLY COOL THING TO WATCH
OVER THE COURSE OF THE SEASON,
THIS HAS BEEN REALLY INTERESTING
TO SEE HOW THINGS HAVE SHAKEN
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS.
YOU ONCE THE DUST SETTLES,
WHAT'S UP WITH JAMARI SALYER,
MAYBE HE'S DEALING WITH THINGS
AS WELL.
>> WE HAVE THE BIG LINEMAN FROM
ARIZONA STATE.
I WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS ON
DAVIDSON WHICH I THINK IS ONE OF
THE LAST ONES.
227 POUNDS, SOMEONE WHO CAN HOLD
BLOCKS, REACT AGAINST THE RUN.
HE WAS NOT DEEP IN THIS AREA.
HE SAW FERRELL GO TODAY.
I THINK WE'RE SEEING A LITTLE
BUILT OF IDENTITY FOR THE GIANTS
HERE WITH MARTINDALE WANTING TO
GET A LITTLE BEEFY WITH THE
OFFENSE.
>> THIS IS THE REALITY OF
FOOTBALL.
EVERYTHING PLAYS THROUGH THE
MIDDLE.
THE QUICKEST WAY TO GET TO THE
END ZONE IS A STRAIGHT LINE.
WHAT YOU TRY TO DO IS FORCE
EVERYTHING TO BOUNCE.
THAT'S WHY WE SEE TEAMS PLAY
WITH THAT PINCH FRONT.
THAT'S WHY WE SEE TEAMS SQUEEZE
THE MIDDLE, BLOCK THE INTERIOR
AND WANT EVERYTHING TO BOUNCE
WIDE.
THAT'S THE WAY FOOTBALL WORKS,
AND I THINK THE BEAUTY OF IT ALL
IS WE'RE SO OBSESSED WITH THIS
HORIZONTAL FOOTBALL.
AND THE REALITY IS IF YOU CAN
SEE PEOPLE RUNNING SIDEWAYS, WE
CAN'T GAIN ANY GROUND.
>> LET'S BRING BACK TOREY HOLT
IN HERE.
I KNOW HE HAS SOME THOUGHTS ON
THE GIANTS LATEST PICKS.
IF YOU SEE GIANTS' LATEST
OFF-SEASON MOVES.
TOREY, WHAT ARE WE THINKING
HERE?
>> THE GIANTS, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT HOW BAD THEY WERE AT TIMES
LAST YEAR OFFENSIVELY ANDDEFENS.
DEXTER LAWRENCE, LEONARD
WILLIAMS, THIBODAUX.
YOU BRING IN JORDAN DAVIS.
THEY CERTAINLY COULD USE MORE
DEPTH AT THE LINEBACKER
POSITION, CROWDER.
I LIKE THEM SAYING, WE'RE GOING
TO BE THICK AND PHYSICAL UP
FRONT TO STOP ANY RUN, ANYBODY
WHO IS COMING AT US, AND WE HAVE
SOME LINEBACKERS THAT CAN GET
DOWNHILL AND MAKE SOME PLAYS FOR
US.
THE GIANTS SAYING, WE'RE GOING
TO BE BETTER OFFENSIVELY AND
WE'RE GOING TO RUN THE FOOTBALL.
>> WE ARE GOING TO BRING BACK
TOREY HOLT IN JUST A MOMENT,
BECAUSE THE BILLS TRADED UP AND
TOOK ONE OF THE BEST WIDE
RECEIVERS ON THE BOARD IN KAHLIL
SHAKIR.
HE'S PLAYED ALL OVER THE PLACE.
YOU SEE HIM MOTIONING OUT FROM
THE BACKFIELD TO GET A
MANUFACTURED TOUCH.
TOUGH GUY WITH A BALL IN HIS
HANDS.
HE REMIND MED OF STERLING
SHEPARD, RIGHT?
A PLAYER WHO IS NOT GOING TO WOW
YOU WITH SIZE, NOT GOING TO WOW
YOU WITH SPEED.
HE JUST GETS THE JOB DONE.
HE PLAYS BIGGER AT THE CATCH
POINT BECAUSE OF HIS SIZE.
GO UP AND WIN THE FOOTBALL.
I DON'T CARE THAT I'M NOT SIX
FEET TALL.
I'M GOING TO FIND A WAY TO GET
THE FOOTBALL.
HE'S A GOOD TACKLE BREAKER AS
WELL.
THIS IS A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
IDEA FOR THE BILLS TO GET DEPTH
AT THE WIDE RECEIVER POSITION.
YOU GAVE DAVIS A MUCH EARNED
CONTRACT POSITION.
NOW YOU GET A GUY THAT FITS ON
THE INSIDE, AND THEY WANT MORE
GADGET PLAYS TO PROTECT JOSH
ALLEN.
THEY DON'T WANT JOSH ALLEN
TAKING ON THAT KIND OF CONTACT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN THE
REGULAR SEASON.
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
SWEEP PITCH PASSES, CLEAN
SWEEPS.
HE WAS NEAR THE TOP OF MY BOARD,
ONE OF THE TOP RECEIVERS.
THEY KNOW HOW TO COUNT SKILL
DOWN ON THE DAY OF THE DRAFT.
>> I GIVE AN A+ TO THIS BAD BOY
BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT HE BRINGS TO
THE TABLE.
HE'S A FOOTBALL PLAYER THAT
PLAYS WIDE RECEIVER.
HE KNOWS EXACTLY WHEN HE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE OPEN.
HE'S ABLE TO DO EVERYTHING.
HE'LL PLAY OUT OF THE BACKFIELD,
HE'LL CROSS THE BACKFIELD.
HE'LL TAKE A JET SWEEP, HE'LL
TAKE ALL THOSE LITTLE THINGS,
BUT WHEN YOU ASK HIM TO GET DOWN
THE FIELD, WHEN YOU ASK HIM TO
STEM INSIDE TO GET OUTSIDE.
THE THING I LOVE -- I WANT TO
HEAR TOREY'S THOUGHTS ABOUT
THIS.
THE THING I LOVE ABOUT HIM IS
HIS ABILITY TO LEAVE HIMSELF
ROOM.
TOO MANY WIDE RECEIVERS FADE
HARD TO THE SIDELINE, DON'T
PROVIDE THEMSELVES SPACE.
HE LEAVES HIMSELF ROOM SO THE
QUARTERBACK CAN MAKE A
SUCCESSFUL PASS.
THIS IS A GUY, DON'T FORGET,
PLAYED WITH A FRESHMAN
QUARTERBACK, A SOPHOMORE
QUARTERBACK, THE LAST TWO
SEASONS AND STILL FOUND A WAY TO
BE INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL.
HE'S A GUY WHO KNOWS WHEN HE'S
SUPPOSED TO BE OPEN.
HE'S A TOUGH GUY ON THE STRETCH.
TOREY, TELL ME YOUR THOUGHTS ON
KHALIL SHAKIR.
>> HE GIVES HIMSELF ROOM ON THE
SIDELINE TO MAKE THE CATCH.
AND FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND, HE'S
REALLY GOOD WITH THE CIRCUS
CATCHES.
HE'S LIKE THE CIRCUS CATCH KING,
A HIGHLIGHT REEL WAITING TO
HAPPEN WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
KHALIL SHAKIR, 146 POUNDS, TOP
SPEED.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN BUFFALO IN JOSH
ALLEN WHO CAN THROW A BALL
ANYWHERE ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD,
KHALIL SHAKIR HAS TO BE EXCITED.
YOU TALK ABOUT PRODUCTION.
HE WAS A THOUSAND-YARD RECEIVER
LAST YEAR.
HE HAD A 529 PASS.
THEY HAVE ANOTHER WEAPON IN
KHALIL SHAKIR.
>> THEY SURE DO.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A HERO BUT
HE COULD SURE GET THEM THE
FOOTBALL.
JAMES COOK, PAST COOKING AND
RUNNING BACK WITH A LOT OF
JUICE.
A BIT OF A MONEYBACKER THAT YOU
CAN GET ON DIME PACKAGES, NICKEL
PACKAGES.
THIS IS WHAT GOOD TEAMS DO.
THEY'VE LAID THE FLOOR, THEY PUT
THE ROOF ON THE THING, NOW
THEY'RE JUST PUTTING THE PLANTS
AROUND THE HOUSE.
MANY.
SUBPACKAGE PLAYER AND KHA
KHALIL SHAKIR.
THIS IS WHAT SMART TEAMS DO,
THEY REHAUL, AND IT'S KIND OF
LIKE THE CHERRY ON TOP RIGHT
NOW.
>> THEY CAME IN WITH A PLAN AND
THEY'RE EXECUTING THE PLACN,
WHICH IS WHAT I WANT TO SEE.
>> CLOSING THOUGHTS ABOUT
KHALIL SHAKIR?
>> HE'S A HIGH CHARACTER GUY.
THAT MATTERS.
WHEN YOU'RE COMING IN IN THE
FIFTH ROUND AND YOU'RE BATTLING
AND WORKING YOUR BUTT OFF TO
MAKE THE TEAM, YOU NEED GOOD
CHARACTER, AND THIS GUY IS A
HIGH-CHARACTER FOOTBALL PLAYER.
AS YOU ALL MENTIONED, I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO PLAY OUT VERY,
VEL WELL WITH HIM IN BUFFALO.
>> MOVING FOR THE BILLS WHO
CONTINUE TO DO GOOD THINGS.
THEY TOOK NEVADA TIGHT END COAL
TURNER.
294-P
294-POUND.
LY.
>> YOU ARE L FOR COLE TURNER,
KIND OF A DANGEROUS PROCESS FOR
ME, GUYS.
DID NOT TEST LIKE A TYPICAL
TIGHT END.
I LOOK AT HIM AS A MOVING
TIGHTENED.
IF HE HAD MOVED BETTER, I THINK
WE WOULD HAVE SEEN HIM COME OFF
THE BOARD AT 3 OR 4.
>> WHEN YOU PUT THE TAPE IN, HE
DOESN'T CATCH THE BALL SMOOTHLY
ALL THE TIME, BUT HE DID CATCH
THE FOOTBALL.
THAT'S AN AMAZING CATCH, BUT
IT'S A DOUBLE CATCH.
YOU SEE HIM HERE, THAT'S A GREAT
CATCH.
IT'S UP AND DOWN, UP AND DOWN.
YOU DON'T WANT THE DOUBLE CATCH,
BUT YOU LIKE THE FACT HE'S
WILLING TO GO UP AND GET IT.
RIGHT THERE HE SECURES IT.
IT'S NOT PRETTY ALL THE TIME,
BUT HE HAS STRONG HANDS AND HE
HANGS ONTO IT.
HE'S STRONGER, AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY HE IS A STRONG GUY.
I'M GOING TO GIVE HIM A B+.
HE WON'T BE BLOCKING FOR YOU
VERY OFTEN.
WHAT HE IS ABLE TO DO, THOUGH,
IS A.
AND GUESS WHAT?
SFL.
HE CAN'T DO ANYTHING THAT'S T.
THE CATCHES DON'T ALWAYS LOOK
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL ALL THE TIME,
BUT HE HANGS ONTO THE FOOTBALL,
AND I LOVE THE FACT HE'S GOLT
THOSE STRONG HANDS.
>> THE ONLY REASON IT WASN'T A
C+ FOR ME.
MAYBE HE HAD TO STEP AWAY, I
THINK HE PLAYS FASTER THAN
TESTING NUMBERS.
THEY PUT ON A BIT MORE WEIGHT.
CAN YOU GET ANYTHING OUT OF
SNEM.
>> SO FOR R ME HIT.
TIGHTENED ARE GOING F.
>> THIS IS A GUY THAT PLAYS A
LITTLE MORE LIKE A WIDE
RECEIVER, THOUGH.
WHAT DO WE THINK WITH COLE
TURNER?
>>LY.
>> THEY HAVE TERRY McCLARION,
THEY HAVE SANDERS WHEN.
THEY CAN FIND VALUE SOMEWHERE
ELSE WITH THEIR TIGHT END AND
THEIR RUNNING BACK, AND I THINK
THEY CAN DO SOME OF THAT WITH
COLE TURNER.
HE'S 6'6".
YOU TELLING ME YOU CAN'T LINE
HIM UP IN THE END ZONE AND SAY,
WE'RE GOING TO THROW A 50-50
BALL TO YOU AND SEE IF YOU CAN
GO GET IT?
I THINK HE COULD, AND AS HE
CONTINUES TO DEVELOP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GOOD STUFF, THIS IS THE KIND OF
PLAYER THEY NEEDED.
.
THEY TOOK THOMAS BOOKER, THEN
WE'LL GET TO THE FAL DONZ.
REALLY GOOD ATHLETE.
HOT AND COLD FILM.
THERE ARE TIMES IT GOT RUSHED
OUT AGAINST THE RUN WHCHLT WE
HEARD IT, HE'S ANOTHER HIGH
CHARACTER PLAYER, ANOTHER BRIGHT
GUY COMING OUT F.Y. WE TALKING
ABOUT THOMAS BOORK EARLY.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A TEAM THAT
LIVED IN A MOUNTAIN OFF EYES.
>> SAZ A PROGRAM, THEY SAY
THERE'S BEEN SOMEIE VEGS ROEGS.
NOBODY IN THAT FRM, AND HE'S A
VICTIM OF THAT, SO WITH WATCHING
THEM AND ESPECIALLY AS THEY
STRUGGLE TO WATCH FOOTBALL
GAMES.
DAVIS MILLS ANOTHER ONE.
A GUY I THOUGHT WOULD BE A FIRST
ROUND DRAFT PICK FOR SURE.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO -- OR DOES
HE BULK UP AND HE LIVES AT 6'3",
AND I THINK HE HAS TO DECIDE
WHAT POSITION HE'S GOING TO PLAY
AT THE NEXT LEVEL.
>> AFTER THOMAS BOOKER WENT OFF
THE BOARD, WE HAD THE SAN
DIEGOANS GUY FROM BYU.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT TYLER AL
ALLGAIER, HE CAN DIP THAT
SHOULDER DOWN, BUT ALSO A LITTLE
BIT OF JUICE, A LITTLE BIT OF
WILBUR.
I DON'T CARE THAT HE RAN A 4640.
HE ACCELERATES IN THAT LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE.
THAT CREATES EXPLOSIVE PLAYS FOR
HIM.
I JUST LOVE THAT YOU CAN PROTECT
HIM FROM THE FIELD.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT THAFR TRYING
TO DEFINE PLAY MAKERS.
THEY GOT CORDARRELLE TOMLINSON.
THIS IS AN A FOR ATLANTA.
THEY'VE DONE A REALLY, REALLY
NICE JOB, THOUGH.
FELDER, WHAT DO YOU SEE IN
ALLGAIER?
>> THIS DUDE IS A BRUISER.
WATCHING HIM PLAY, IT FEELS LIKE
YOU'RE WATCHING FOOTBALL IN THE
'90s.
HE'S NOT GOING TO MAKE ANYBODY
MISERABLE.
HE'S GOING TO MAKE YOU PAY.
HE'S GOING TO DARE TO TACKLE,
AND BY THE END OF THE GAME,
FOLKS ARE GOING TO GET TIRED.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF THAT ANGER,
THAT VIOLENT RUNNING STYLE TO
HIS GAME.
I LIKE TO WATCH HIM PLAY.
THIS IS AN "A" FOR ME AS WELL.
HE'S SOMEONE THAT WILL ADD SOME
TOUGHNESS TO A FALCONS TEAM THAT
WE DISCUSSED THEIR ABILITY TO
PLAY MISMATCHES A LOT.
NOW YOU BRING SOME OF THAT
TOUGHNESS IN THE BACKFIELD AND
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL KEEP HIM IN
THAT RUN GAME.
>> TOREY, OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
FALCONS SCENE THAT THE NEAL
JONES ERA IS LONG OVER.
THEY GOT KYLE PITTS, THEY GOT
DRAKE LONDON.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN TYLER
ALLGAIER TO THIS OFFENSE?
>> I LIKE THE WAY TO STABILIZE
THAT QUARTERBACK IS TO GET YOU
SOMEONE LIKE ALLGAIER.
HE'S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO WOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE, BUT THERE IS ALSO
NOT MUCH TO DISLIKE ABOUT THIS
GUY.
6'
224 POUNDS, 5'11", AND HE'S
EXPLOSIVE.
HE CAN HELP THEM IN PASS PRO.
HE CAN HELP THEM A LOT IN THE
PASS PRO, BUT HE BRINGS THE
PHYSICAL RUN STYLE TO THE
ATLANTA FALCONS.
ATLANTA WANTS TO ESTABLISH A
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE, AND THE WAY
YOU DO THAT, YOU RUN THE BALL
CONSISTENTLY WITH A BRUTE.
ALLGAIER SUPPLIES THAT.
>> WE JUST TALKED ABOUT TURNER
GOES TO DENVER, THEN FOR SOME
REASON WHEEZER IS PLAYING IN THE
DRAFT.
LET'S GO TO TARIQUE MULLEN
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO BREAK INTO
ONE OF THE MOST FASCINATING MEN
IN THE DRAFT.
WHEN YOU SEE A GUY THAT
EVERYTHING IS IN A RARE GROUP,
YOU HAVE TO BREAK IT DOWN.
HE IS A CORNER TALLER THAN 6'4".
HE'S 205 POUNDS, MICHAEL FELGER.
HE JUMPED 42 INCHES IN THE
VERTICAL.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF GUY
WITH TENTACLES FOR ARMS.
WHAT I WILL SAY ABOUT TARIQUE
MULLEN, I LOVE THE ATHLETE.
I LOVE WHAT HE CAN BE.
HE'S STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHEN TO THROW THE FOOTBALL.
WHEN YOU'RE THAT BIG AND THAT
FAST, I THINK IT CAN BE SPECIAL.
THESE ARE THE ATHLETES THAT YOU
DROFT.
PLAY
-- DRAFT.
PLAYER 134 ON THE BOARD.
WE KNOW HE'S GOT THE LENGTH TO
PRESS, WE KNOW HE'S GOT THE
SPEED TO RUN.
FORMER DEFENSIVE BACK, TALK TO
ME.
>> HE WAS ONE OF MY FAVORITES OF
THE DAY.
HE IS A QUALITY BALL PLAYER.
I LOVE WHAT HE BRINGS.
6'4", 240 SNL SFLZ THIS IS A
GUY -- ZONE OR MAN.
HE LEARNED HOW TO SINK BELOW
THAT CLOUD COVERAGE TO GET HIS
HANDS UP.
HE WANTS TO TACKLE.
HE STILL NEEDS TO LEARN THE
RIGHT WAY TO APPROACH TACKLING.
WE'VE SEEN THE WAY HE TAKES THE
BALL AWAY ON A BREAK.
TO ME TARIQUE MULLEN IS AN A+.
THAT'S A GREAT PICK FOR THE
SEAHAWKS.
>> THERE WERE SOME RUMBLINGS HE
COULD HAVE GONE IN THE SECOND
ROUND WITH THOSE KIND OF
MEASURABLES.
I LIKE WHEN THESE HAPPEN.
I LIKE THAT HE CAN NOW COME IN
AND SETTLE, AND NOT BE A
SUPERHERO WHERE HE CAN BURN THEM
OUT.
LET HIM DEVELOP IN A PLACE THAT
THIS IS A TEAM THAT HAD BRANDON
BROWNER.
THEY LOVE BIG DP.
HERE WE GO.
YOU'VE SEEN IT RIGHT THERE.
HE DOES A GREAT JOB COVERING THE
DRAFT.
MULLEN IS A SENIOR QUARTERBACK,
EXCEPT THERE ARE NINE GUYS ON
THE EARTH BUILT LIKE HIM.
>>> LET'S JUMP BACK HERE BECAUSE
I DO WANT TO GIVE ALL.
I'VE WATCHED HIM AT 3.
>> KIN LEE COMING OFF THE BOARD.
HE'S GOT A REALLY HIGH CEILING
AS A GUY STILL NEW TO FOOTBALL.
LOOK AND SEE WHAT HE CAN DO, AND
RIDGEWAY, THE KID OUT OF
ARKANSAS, WE'RE GOING TO SEE
WHAT HE DOES.
>> LET'S BACK UP TO THE SAFETY
OUT OF OKLAHOMA.
5'10", RAN REALLY WELL.
TO ME A GUY YOU CAN MOVE AROUND
AND ASK A LOT OF IN COVERAGE.
I SAW CARL JOSEPH, BUT WHEN YOU
GRADE THIS PICK, THEY'RE
CONSTANTLY ADDING SECONDARY
PEETSZ REMEMBER.
>> FOR THE BRONCOS IF THEY GO
THREE SAFETY LOOKS, IS THERE A
PROJECTED PLAY RIGHT AWAY?
I SAW HIM AS A COVERAGE PIECE.
>> COVERAGE PIECE IS CRITICAL.
DOES THAT MEAN YOU PLAY HIM ON
THE SLOT OR TAKE ONE SAFETY AND
MOVE HIM DOWN.
HE'S THE GUY THAT I SAW VAST
IMPROVEMENT OF FROM OKLAHOMA,
RIGHT SNT DID W--?
I THINK I WOULD MOVE THE SAFETY
DOWN AND LET HIM COME DOWN TO
MAKE PLAYS INSTEAD OF HAVING HER
UP IN THE BOX SO HE KANLT MANY.
HE'S A BETTER TACKLE LER THAN HE
WAS IN 2020.
I LOVE THE FACT HE'S IMPROVED
CONSISTENTLY.
IT SHOWED ME HE COULD TAKE
COACHING, HE CAN TAKE THE
CRITICISM, DO YOU WANT ME TO
GIVE THIS ONE A GRADE?
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH THAT
SPOT.
>> WE'LL FLASH IT ONE MORE TIME
BEFORE WE THROW IT OFF THE
SCREEN.
THE JA JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS TAK
IT.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING THAT IT'S
HIM VERSUS A GUY LIKE JEREMY
LEE.
THAT'S THE PART THAT STOOD OUT
MOST TO ME WAS WATCHING SOMEONE
WHO I THOUGHT WAS A LITTLE
MORE -- WHAT'S THE WORD I'M
LIKING FOR?
>> EXPLOSIVE?
>> EXPLOSIVE, POLISHED.
SO CONNOR WAS BASICALLY THEIR
NUMBER TWO GUY.
HE HAD SOME BREAKOUT GAMES.
HE'S REALLY GOOLD.
I THINK HE CAN DEVELOP AT THE
NEXT LEVEL.
YOU WATCH HIM HERE AND YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE THAT TIGHT END
KOCHLT THERE'S A NICE HOLE THERE
TO GIVE HIM AN EDGE.
.
WHAT THEY WANT HIM TO DO IS PLAY
MORE DOWNHILL, AND HE DOES LOOK
LIKE A GUY WHO WANTS TO BE SIDE
TO SIDE.
I WOULD PLAY MORE DOWNHILL.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS TEAM IN
THE BACKFIELD, YOU HAVE JAMES
ROBINSON COMING OFF OF INJURY.
I THINK THEY WANT SNOOP CONNOR
TO BE MAYBE AN INSURANCE PIECE
OF THAT ROLE.
YOU HAVE TRAFLS OF ATM TO BE
YOUR PASS RUNNER AS WELL.
>> POWER BACK TO THIS PART OF
THE DRAFT AND ONE OF THE MORE
VALUABLE POWER BACKS IN EARLY
DECLARATION ONCE AGAIN.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I SEE
WHEN YOU DUCK MPL YOU HAVE TO
HAVE MULTIPLE BACKS IN TODAY'S
NLFL I WOULD ASSUME THEY
ENVISION THEMSELVES BEING IN RED
ZONE SITUATIONS WITH A TALENT
THEY'VE ACQUIRED IN FREE AGENCY,
PARTICULARLY ON THE PERIMETER.
THEN THEY HAVE A GUY LIKE TREVOR
LAWRENCE WHO IS REALLY GOOD.
WHEN HE'S COMFORTABLE IN THE
POCKET, HE CAN SHOW IT, HE CAN
RUN IT.
A SHORT YARD THIRD DOWN TYPE AS
WELL.
AND WE'LL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GO TO JACKSONVILLE TO COMPETE.
LY AS WE KEEP THE PICKS MOVING
RIGHT HERE.
FOR DEPTH AND DEVELOPMENT THEY
TAKE MATT WALENSKO FROM NORTH
DAKOTA.
I LOOK AT HIS HEIGHT AND BEING
4.8, 36-ARMS T. SDPCHLT HE
DEVELOP SFWHU?
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE KEY.
HE HASN'T DEVELOPED INTO IT TO
MAKE THOSE PLAYS.
CAN HE DO THAT?
CAN HE DEVELOP INTO THE GUY THAT
USES THAT LENGTH TO HIS OWN
ADVANTAGE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE KEY.
>> HE REMINDS ME OF WHAT STONE
FORSYTHE WAS GOING THROUGH.
6'8", 307.
YOU LOOV THE SIZE, YOU LOVE THE
LENGTH, BUT WILL RECALL.
>> LORETTA HALF IS GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT U.
>> IT'S A FUN ONE.
IT TALKS ABOUT HOW THE BROWNS
THEY'RE TAKING FORD FROM
CINCINNATI.
AN ALABAMA TRANSFER.
I SAY WE DIVE INTO JEROME FORD
ON THIS ONE.
OBVIOUSLY A TRADE FROM ALABAMA.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THIS GUY IS,
HE'S GOT THE RUMT.
PLAYS WITH AN EDGE.
I THINK HE'S GOT SOME JUICES OF
PAST CATCHER AS WELL.
BUT THAT STRAIGHT LINE,
BREAKAWAY SPEED FOR CLEVELAND.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT WE KNOW
WHERE THEY ARE.
IF YOU EVER THE JUICE TO GET
OUTSIDE, PLANT YOUR FOOT IN THE
GROUND, FIND THE HOLE AND GET
DOWNHILL.
THAT'S WHAT JEROME FORD DOES.
HE WAS A TOP TEN BACK FOR ME.
THIS IS AN A-MINUS FOR
CLEVELAND.
THIS IS A ROSTER WHO UNDERSTANDS
HOW TO FIND VALUE IN THE
BACKFIELD, AND THEY'VE DONE IT
AGAIN.
>> THIS JEROME FORD CAN PLAY.
WE TALK SO MUCH ABOUT
CINCINNATI'S DEFENSE, FORD SORT
OF GOT LOST IN THE WASH.
HE IS A BIG REASON THAT ENGINE
WENT.
HE IS A DOWNHILL RUNNER SO HE
LOOKS FOR SPACE THAT HE CAN PUT
OWL.
HE CAN EM.
DON'T KNOW THAT HE'S GREAT IN
PASS FIELD, BUT HE'S VERY GOOD
AT CATCHING OUT OF THE BACK
FIELD.
THAT'S A POSITIVE FOR HIM.
THEN WHEN YOU WATCH HIM RUN
THROUGH TACKLES AND THE BALANCE
THAT HE BRINGS.
WE TALK SO MUCH ABOUT VISION, WE
TALK SO MUCH ABOUT SPEED, BE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT BALANCE OF
RUNNING BACKS.
WHEN GUYS START PICKING AT YOUR
LEGS AND GET A LITTLE CHIP ON
YOU, A LOT OF GUYS HAVE THE
TENDENCY TO KICK THEIR OWN
HEELS, A LOT OF GUYS HAVE THE
TENDENCY TO STICK IT OUT AND NOT
FALL.
>> TERRY HOLT WAS THE GUY WHO
FIST BUMPED ME.
>> HE CAN PROVIDE VERSATILITY ON
THE OFFENSE.
DRAW A LINE AND TAKE YOUR
FAVORED ONES OUT OF THE BOX FOR
DeSHAWN WATSON, AND WHEN YOU
LOOK WHO HE WILL BE ABLE TO BE
BEHIND, THERE'S A VERY HIGH
LEVEL BEHIND THESE TWO GOOD
RUNNING BACKS.
I LOVE THE SPEED, AND I LOVE THE
PASSING.
PLAYER COMP FOR ME, LAMAR
MILLER.
SIMILAR GUYS THAT HAVE BREAK
DAGS.
DESIGN McCOLLUM FROM SAM USE TON
STATES.
TODD BOWLES ONE OF THE BEST AT
DWIN
DWINGING.
208 NOUNDS.
THE 3 CONE IN THE 90th
PERCENTILE.
.
I KNOW HE STAFFORD R STARRED A
LOT OF FOOTBALL GAMES, BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE TAG.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO WILL BE ON
YOUR KICK COVERAGE TEAM, PUNK
COVERAGE TEAM BECAUSE HE CAN FLY
DOWN THE ELAD.
THGS THE DO I UNDERSTAND OF
PLAYER I VALUE ONLY SOMEDAY 3.
I LOVE THIS KIND OF SELECTION.
>> I DO, TOO.
HE KIND OF FITS INTO THAT
TARIQUE WILLIAMS PLAN, GOOD
SIZE, QUICK.
HE'S A LITTLE MORE STURDY THAN
TARIQUE.
THE BIG KEY FOR ME IS GOING TO
BE, HOW DOES HE FIX THE NEXT
THING.
HOW DOES HE HANDLE THE NEXT --
HOW DOES HE HANDLE THINGS AT THE
NEXT DELVE.
I'M ALSO GOING TO GO WITH LANAE.
IF YOU CAN GET GOOD SPECIAL
TEAMS PLAY OUT OF HIM, AND THE
SPECIAL TEAMS.
IF YOU CAN FWET THAT RIGHT,
WE'LL TAKE YOU FRAR.
WE'LL WORK IN THE OFF-SEASON TO
GET READY FOR YOU TO TAKE OVER A
CORNERBACK MANICALLY MANY.
PUCK TAP INTO SOME OF.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
299 POUNDS CHLTD WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE TAPE, VERY IMPRESSIVE AS
A GUNER.
VERY, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
I PLAY WITH A GUY NAMED TONY
HORN.
HE WAS A FANTASTIC GUY.
WENT OUT TO CATCH.
TOUGH AS NAILS.
WE PUT GUNNER IN THE BUNNY
POSITION, HE WREAKED TALENT.
WE CAN PRESENT VALUE OF THE
TAMPA BAY BUCCANEERS TO BE
REALLY SPECIAL ON SPECIAL TEAMS
AND DEVELOPING AS A CORNER AT
THE NEXT LEVEL.
HIS SPECIAL TEAM RIGHT AWAY TO
TAKE NOTICE.
>> I LIKE IT.
I'M A BIG FAN.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE BIG
BOARD.
WE'LL SEE HOW LONG IT TAKES.
MARCUS RODRIGUES.
I VALUE THE PLAYER AS A STARTING
PLAYER IN ROUND 3.
NICK BARRI WE TALKED ABOUT.
WALKER A LITTLE BIT OF A
DEVELOPMENTAL TACKLE.
HE'S ALSO GOT SOME NASTY TAPE
AGAINST THE RUN.
>> WE HAVE A COUPLE PICKS THAT
HAVE JUST COME IN.
WE HAVE TYREEK SMITH WHICH IS
ANOTHER ONE.
SOMEONE CERTAINLY EYE WINNER ON
THAT FOOTBALL FIELD.
THERE IS A LOT OF GOOD PLAYERS
STILL IN THIS DRAFT.
THAT'S THE SCARY PART AS WE LOOK
ON THE BIG BOARD.
SHOUTOUT TO ARKANSAS FANS.
JOHN RIDGEWAY, BABY.
IT WAS EARLY THIS MORNING WHEN I
WROTE JASON, WE GOT IT, JOHN,
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT, BABY.
RACITA SMITH.
>> OUR SHOW IS SPONSORED BY
ROCKET MORTGAGE.
THEY'VE ALSO MADE IT POSSIBLE
FOR YOU TO GET A HOME LOAN RIGHT
HERE ON YOUR PHONE WITH A
PROCESS BUILT AROUND YOUR NEEDS.
WHEN YOU NEED A HOME LOAN THAT
FITS YOU, ROCKET CAM.
>>> LET'S KEEP THIS THING
MOVING.
WE HAVE TO CATCH UP ON SOME
PICKS RIGHT HERE BECAUSE THIS
THING STARTS TO FLY.
WE TALKED BRIEFLY ABOUT TYREKE
SMITH GOING TO SEATTLE.
ERIC JOHNSON FROM SEATTLE STATE.
HE CAN RUSH THE PASSER.
>> WHAT'S HE GOING TO PLAY?
>> I THINK HE'S GOING TO PLAY
TECH.
LET'S TALK ABOUT ERIK JOCHB SON.
HE'S A PLAYER THAT A LOT OF
OFFENSE MIGHT NOT BE FAMILIAR
WITH.
HE'S SOMEONE IN THIS DRAFT THAT
MAYBE PEOPLE WEREN'T WANTING TO
HEAR TODAY.
ABOUT 300 POUNDS.
THIS IS A BIG MAN THAT CAN FLY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TAPE,
THERE'S NOT AYTON OF SACKS THERE
ON FILM.
VERY, VERY, OFF THE BALL.
WHEN YOU'RE 300 POUNDS AND YOU
CAN GET OFF THE BALL AND RUN,
YOU'RE GOING TO WREAK HAVOC WITH
OTHERS WHO KACHBT KEEP UP.
FORI CAN JOHNSON.
THIS IS ONE OF MINE IN THE
DRAFT.
THIS IS WHAT ED DODDS AND CHRIS
AND PASS RUSH SPECIALS.
YOU'RE SAYING KEEP IT SIMPLE.
BE THE GUARD AND CENTER IN FRONT
OF YOU.
WE THINK YOU'LL NEED THAT ONE ON
ONE OPTION.
THIS IS A B FOR ME AND HE LOOKS
GOOD IN THE SECOND ROUND.
>> I THINK THE KEY FOR ME IS
BEING A PASSER IN SPECIALS BUT
ALSO BEING ASKED TO PENETRATE.
PENETRATE, PENETRATE, PENETRATE.
DON'T TRY TO LOCK OUT AND RUSH
THE GUARD.
FIND WAYS TO GET PENETRATION.
I'M GOING TO THROW MY GRADE ON
THIS, TOO.
I THINK HE'S A B MIB-MINUS.
I THINK HE HAS THE ABILITY TO
GROW AND DEVELOP INTO A PLAYER.
>> SO KEEPING THINGS MOVING, WE
SAW THE COLTS TAKE ERIC JOHNSON.
THE CHARGERS BACK ON THE CLOCK
AND I BELIEVE THEY HAVE MADE THE
PICK HERE AS WE GO TO -- OH,
TITO OBONYA.
ANOTHER TACKLE OFF THE BOARD.
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT PLAYER
THAN ERIC JOHNSON.
I THINK THIS GUY, TO ME, HE'S
GOING TO LIVE ON THE INSIDE
LEIKER I L
LIKE ERIC JOHNSON.
TEETER OBONYA.
HIS ABILITY TO TAKE ON BLOCKERS,
OPEN UP LINEBACKERS BEHIND HIM
WILL BE HIS ROLE AT THE NEXT
LEVEL.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS IN THE DRAFT
ALL THE TIME.
THERE AREN'T A LOT OF GUYS THAT
CAN MOVER THE WAY THEY CAN BUT
ALSO HAVE CONSTRAINT.
THAT IS THE PLAY RIGHT THERE
DWRUR
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
EAT THE SPACE AND LET SOMEBODY
ELSE GET THE STAT SHEET.
THIS ONE FOR ME, THIS IS PRETTY
GOOD VALUE HERE.
THIS IS A CLASS WE'VE SEEN
EVAPORATE.
I'M GOING WITH A B-MINUS IN THIS
SPOT.
>> THE THING WITH TITO, I DON'T
THINK THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN HIM AND FERRELL.
I'M GOING WITH A B-PLUS BECAUSE
THERE IS VALUE HERE.
FIRST AND SECOND DOWN.
AGAIN, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS,
THE ATHLETICISM IS THERE FOR
HIM.
SAME THING WITH FARRELL.
IT'S REMARKABLE TO SEE A GUY
CARRY THE WEIGHT THAT WELL.
PUSH THE CENTER BACK INTO THE
BACKFIELD.
HE CAN PUSH THE POCKET IN THE
PASS GAME.
HE CAN DO ALL THOSE THINGS.
THIS GUY IS A FIGHTER AND HE
STICKS TO THE INTERIOR.
HE CAN PLAY THAT SHAPE.
HE MIGHT BE ABLE TO PLAY A 3 IF
YOU'RE A HEAVY PACKAGE, BUT HE
CAN GET THE JOB DONE.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHO
REMIND ME OF MY OLD TEAMMATE.
CAM THOMAS FROM USC PLAYED FOR
THE STEELERS FOR A WHILE, AND HE
WOULDN'T GET IN THE WAY.
HE GOT ALL THAT STUFF DONE.
>> KEEPING IT MOVING, WE HAVE
ANOTHER DEFENSIVE PICK.
BEFORE WE DO THAT, LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT THE CHARGERS AND WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE IN THIS NFL DRAFT
SO FAR.
WE'VE HEARD STANLEY TALK ABOUT
IT A LOT.
THEY GOT GUARD HELP EARLY ON
WITH JOHNSON.
THEN YOU SEE A GUY WITH BALL
SPILLS FROM THE BACK END.
THEY WILL GIVE HIM MORE POWER IN
THE RUN GAME.
OBONYA, HELP OUT COLBY MACK IN
THE MIDDLE.
>> WHICH TEAM ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT NOW?
>> THE CHARGERS DEFENSE.
THEIR DRAFT AS A WHOLE.
>> THEY PICKED UP A SAFETY IN JT
WOODS.
THEY WENT AND GOT TITO OBONYA.
WE PULLED UP THEIR DRAFT NEEDS
ALREADY.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT, WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO DO, DO THEY GET
MORE EDGE?
WHAT DID THEY DO TO GET MORE
HELP?
>> THEY OBVIOUSLY -- THEY'LL BE
BACK ON THE CLOCK ESSENTIALLY,
BUT OBONYA HELPS THEM ALONG.
>> THEY ADDRESSED SOME OF THE
OFFENSIVE LINE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET REAL
OFFENSIVE LINE, ANYWAY.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT WANTS TO WIN
RIGHT NOW.
DO YOU GO GET WEAPONS OR DO YOU
GET MORE POSITION OR SCHEMATIC
PLAYERS DEFENSIVELY THAT CAN
HELP OUT DIRWIN JAMES AND THE
REST OF THAT TEAM.
COMING OFF THE BOARD AND BEEFING
UP THE CHARGERS DEFENSIVE LINE.
>> THE REASON WHY I LIKE IT,
WHEN I LOOK AT THE L.A. CHARGERS
AND I LOOK AT THEIR DEPTH CHART
WITH AUSTIN JOHNSON, SEBASTIAN
JOSEPH-DAY, JERRY TILLERY.
IN LAST YEAR'S DRAFT, YOU ADD
OBONYA, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ADDING DEPTH HERE IN THE LATER
ROUNDS, THE LOS ANGELES CHARGERS
SURELY DID THAT WITHOBONYA AND
HIS ABILITY TO BRING IT UP THE
INTERIOR.
THIS GUY HAS THE SKILL SET TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO ANOTHER GOOD PICK FOR THE
CH
CHARGERS IN THAT SPOT.
LET'S KEEP THINGS MOVING HERE.
LET'S GO TO JACKSON FOR THE
SAINTS.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT ON THE
SHOW THAT LIGHTER LINEBACKERS IS
WHERE THE NFL IS GOING.
132 POUNDS, WHEN I THINK ABOUT
JACKSON, HE CAN COVER THEM OUT
IN THE SPOTS.
I THINK HE CAN RUN THE SCENE
WITH TIGHT ENDS AND THAT'S HOW
HE RUNS THE FIELD.
>> QUALITY FOOTBALL PROGRAM, YOU
KNOW HE'S WELL TAUGHT.
THE BIG KEY FOR ME IS THE WAY HE
RUNS.
HE CHASES GUYS DOWN, HE MAKES
PLAYS.
HE DOES ALL THOSE THINGS THAT
YOU ASK A GUY TO DO AND HE'LL
CONSISTENTLY DO IT.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT HE'S
RELENTLESS IN PURSUIT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT GETS GUYS
DOWN ON THE GROUND BUT IT'S ALSO
SOMETHING TO GROIRT TEAM OFF THE
FIELD.
>> HE'S GOING TO GROW INTO
SOMEONE YOU CAN'T GET OFF THE
FIELD.
ONCE HE GETS ON THE FIELD, I
THINK HE STAYS ON THE FIELD.
HE'S GOING TO GROW INTO THE ROLE
AS AN EVERY DOWN BACK AS HE
SIZES UP THE NFL.
>> TOREY HOLT, I KNOW YOU HAVE
SOME OPINIONS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HERE?
>> YOU HEARD ABOUT THE JOB
THEY'RE DOING IN DEVELOPING
THESE PLAYERS.
I LIKE THIS PICK OF DeMARCO
JACKSON.
HE'S A TEAM CAPTAIN.
HE SHINES ON SPECIAL TEAMS.
AGAIN, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PLAYERS BEING DRAFTED IN THESE
SPOTS AND WHAT THEY HAVE TO
PROVIDE.
SPECIAL TEAMS IS ONE OF THEM.
HE'S A GUY THAT SHINES ON
SPECIAL TEAMS.
AND CONNOR, YOU MENTIONED IT.
THE SIDELINE SPEED AND
ANTICIPATION IS THERE.
SO NEW ORLEANS, DEFENSIVELY THEY
GOT SOME TALENT ON THE DEFENSIVE
SIDE OF THE BALL.
THEY BRING IN MORE WITH DeMARCO
JACKSON AND THEY BRING IN A GUY
WHO CAN SHINE ON SPECIAL TEAMS.
>> I LIKE IT.
THE BOARD IS FLYING RIGHT NOW,
GUYS.
WE HAD TWO PICKS BACK TO BACK.
WE'RE GOING TO BREAK DOWN THE
SECOND ONE.
THE FIRST ONE WAS THE BRONCOS,
MONTREAL WASHINGTON.
HE DID NOT MAKE MY TOP 100.
HE HAS SOME TURN EXPERIENCE.
LATE IN THE FIFTH ROUND, THE
BRONCOS ARE A TEAM THAT CAN
AFFORD TO DO THAT.
THEN PHILLIPS, FROM L.A., HE
COMES OFF THE BOARD.
WE KNOW TENNESSEE WAS LOOKING TO
ADD TO THE BACK ROOM THERE.
PHILLIPS, THE CLASSIC CASE OF
HE'S NOT BIG.
>> THAT'S THE BIG THING WITH
TYLER PHILLIPS.
THIS IS AGAINST LSU.
REMEMBER, AN LSU TEAM THAT HAD
MULTIPLE DEFENSIVE BACKS TAKEN
IN THIS DRAFT AND HE'S ABLE TO
GET THE JOB DONE.
HE'S STILL TRYING TO CONCENTRATE
AND MAKE A PLAY.
HE'S A WEAVER.
HE'S NOT GOING TO SET YOU UP
LIKE DEVIN HESTER, BUT HE SEES
DAYLIGHT, RUNS TO WHERE HIS
JERSEYS ARE AND FINDS A WAY TO
GENERATE BIG PLAYS.
I LIKE HIM A LOT.
I THINK HE'S SOMEONE THAT FINDS
SPACE ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
I THINK AT THIS POINT IN THE
DRAFT, YOU HAVE TO CALL THIS A
SOLID B AT MINIMUM BECAUSE HE'S
SOMEONE THAT'S GOING TO BE OPEN,
SOMEONE THAT'S GOING TO BE
CONSISTENT.
HE HAS LOW EXPECTATIONS, BUT
PEOPLE WILL HAVE LOW
EXPECTATIONS FOR HIM BUT HE HAS
HIGH EXPECTATIONS FOR HIMSELF.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> IT CERTAINLY DOES.
IT'S SOMEONE WHO HAD A GOOD
TRYOUT WEEK.
IF YOU WERE LOOKING FOR A SLOT
KIND OF PLAYER, I LEAN MORE
TOWARDS THE DYNAMIC EDGE OF
MULLEN.
I THOUGHT HE WAS A BETTER PLAYER
ON TAPE.
RUTGERS COULDN'T FIND THE WAY TO
GET HIM THE FOOTBALL, AND THAT'S
NOT HIS FAULT.
BUT I LIKE WHERE YOU KNOW HE'S
GOING TO COME IN, HE'S GOING TO
MAKE THE CATCHES AND HE CAN WORK
THE SLOT.
THIS IS A C-PLUS JUST BECAUSE
I'M A BIG MULLEN FAN.
FROM UCLA, NICE PLAYER.
WHAT DO WE THINK, MAN?
>> NICE PLAYER.
I THINK HE'LL BE ABLE TO PLAY
OVER THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
HE FINDS A WAY TO CONSISTENTLY
GET OPEN.
HE'LL BE ASKED TO DO THAT.
AND WHAT VALUE CAN HE BRING TO
SPECIAL TEAMS AS WELL?
THAT WILL BE SOMETHING FOR HIM.
BUT HE UNDERSTANDS LEVERAGE, HE
KNOWS HOW TO GAIN SEPARATION.
DOES A GOOD JOB OF THAT,
CONSISTENTLY DOING THAT, AND
THEN RETURNABILITY, SPECIAL
TEAMS ABILITY WILL ALSO BE A BIG
FACTOR FOR HIM GOING FORWARD.
>> AWESOME.
I THINK WE'LL SEE A LOT OF WIDE
RECEIVERS COME OFF THE BOARD
HERE BEFORE WE WERE OFF THE
CLOCK IN THE FIFTH ROUND.
YOU SEE THE TITANS DRAFT HERE.
LISTEN, I KNOW TITANS FANS ARE
PROBABLY DOWN AND OUT THAT THEY
TRADED TYLER BROWN.
B
BERKS OBVIOUSLY ON OFFENSE.
TENNESSEE -- THIS DRAFT IS
EVERYTHING TENNESSEE WANTS TO
BE.
THEY WANT TO BE PHYSICAL.
IT'S THE MARK RIVAL IDENTITY.
>> IT'S THE BIG KEY.
I GUESS THE CHARGERS TRADED UP
FOR THIS PICK.
LET'S GET READY TO ROCK AND
ROLL.
EXCUSE ME, THE RAMS.
THEY NEED TO CHANGE THE LOGOS,
CHANGE THE COLORS.
>> WE'RE DOING THIS PICK BECAUSE
THIS PICK IS FREAKING AWESOME.
>> TAKE IT AWAY.
>> FOR SOME REASON, ONE OF THE
MORE OVERLOOKED PLAYERS IN THIS
DRAFT.
MAYBE BECAUSE HE DIDN'T TEST
WELL, I'M NOT SURE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT KYREN WILLIAMS,
ONE OF THOSE THEY KEPT VERY LATE
IN THE DRAFT.
PICK 164.
THIS GUY, AS MICHAEL FELGER
SAYS, IS A FOOTBALL PLAYER.
I DON'T CARE THAT HE DIDN'T RUN
FAST ON THE TRACK, I DON'T CARE
THAT HE'S SMALL.
HE HAS EXCELLENT CONTACT
BALANCE, HE HAS EXCELLENT
VISION.
HE IS A TEAM LEADER.
HE IS, DESPITE HIS SIZE, THE
BEST PASS-PROTECTING RUNNING
BACK IN THE ENTIRE DRAFT.
GET OUT IN THE FLAT, MAKE A
MOVE, GET IN THE END ZONE.
I'LL BULLY YOU TO THE PYLON.
THAT'S FINE.
HE'S A TOUGH GUY.
HE FOOLS PEOPLE IN THE SENSE
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIM, YOU
EXPECT NOTHING, BUT HE'S SO
SMART, HE'S SO STRONG.
THE LOW TO THE GROUND RUNNING
STYLE IS EXCELLENT.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE VALUE.
I THROW UP THE A-PLUS RIGHT NOW
TO NOT WASTE ANY MORE TIME
BEFORE MICHAEL FELGER JUMPS IN
HERE.
HE MADE IT TO THE FOURTH ROUND
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T TEST VERY WELL
AND HE'S SMALL.
GUESS WHAT?
HE GETS ON THE FIELD AND NOBODY
CARES ABOUT ANY OF THAT.
>> HE IS NOT SMALL.
HE'S SHORT, BUT HE IS NOT SMALL.
THIS IS SOMEONE THAT WATCHING
HIM PLAY, HE'S A LITTLE PINBALL.
THIS IS SOMEONE THAT BOUNCES OFF
PEOPLE.
GOOD VISION TO SEE.
HE'S GOING TO LEAD RUNS.
HE'S GOING TO GET UP ON THOSE
GUYS RIGHT UP ON THEIR BUTTS AND
THEN HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CUT OFF WITH THEM ONCE THE
DEFENDERS OVERCOMMIT AND THE
BLOCKERS GET OUT OF THE WAY.
THIS GUY WILL STICK HIS NOSE IN
THERE, HE WILL ANCHOR, HE WILL
TAKE TWO STEPS AND COLLISION A
LINEBACKER THAT HAS EIGHT STEPS
ON HIM, AND HE WILL MAKE THAT
LINEBACKER WEAR IT.
I LOVE IT, THAT'S WHY IT'S AN
A-PLUS.
>> A-PLUS FOR ME, A-PLUS FOR
FELGER.
KYREN WILLIAMS TO THE SUPER BOWL
CHAMPS HERE.
PRETTY GOOD, MAN, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> YEAH, IT IS, MAN. RE
REALLY GOOD PICK FOR THE RAMS
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE STYLE
OF RUNNERS THEY HAVE FOR SONNY
MICHELLE LAST YEAR.
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT KENNY
STAFFORD.
HE'S BEEN A TEAM CAPTAIN.
I KNOW HE'S 5'9", BUT THIS DUDE,
MAN, IS A WORKLOAD.
HE LOVES CARRYING THE LOAD.
HE DID IT AT NOTRE DAME.
THE PATIENCE, THE SPIEED, THE
ABILITY FTO FINISH RUNS.
HE'S A LIMITED BLOCKER, VERY
TALENTED.
HE'S A ST. LOUIS KID.
I PLAYED TEN YEARS IN ST. LOUIS,
SO I KNOW HOW TOUGH THOSE KIDS
ARE IN ST. LOUIS.
THE L.A. RAMS ARE GETTING A
TOUGH, REALLY GOOD FOOTBALL
PLAYER, A TEAM CAPTAIN, A GUY
THAT I THINK WILL FIT THE
CULTURE VERY WELL.
>> AWESOME.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE KYREN WILLIAMS
ON THE RAMS.
HE'LL HAVE A ROLE RIGHT AWAY.
JUST BECAUSE HE'S DRAFTED THIS
LATE IN THE DRAFT, HE COULD BE
THERE AS SOON AS HE WALKS INTO
MINI CAMP, NOT TRAINING CAMP.
>>> LET'S LOOK AT THE BIG BOARD.
KYREN WILLIAMS WAS RIGHT THERE,
THE FIFTH PLAYER ON THE LEFT.
HE'S GONE NOW OVER THERE.
CARSON STRONG, OBVIOUSLY, THE
LAST QUARTERBACK ON THE BOARD WE
THINK WILL GET DRAFTED TODAY.
McKINLEY, ONE OF FELGER'S
FAVORITES.
JEFFREY GUNTHER, BRING SOME PASS
RUSH JUICE.
LET'S RESET HERE.
FELGER, I THINK WE SHOULD KICK
BACK TO FELGER'S FAVES ONE MORE
TIME AS WELL.
WE TALKED ABOUT SAWYER, WE
TALKED ABOUT VERONE McKINLEY A
LOT.
WHO IS THE GUY BESIDES McKINLEY
AND SAWYER ON THE RIGHT SIDE
HERE THAT YOU'RE WAITING TO COME
OFF THE BOARD.
>> I THINK TYLER CHANDLER.
HE'S NOT QUITE AS SKILLED IN
PASS PRO BUT SOMEBODY THAT IS
SKILLED IN CATCHING THE BALL IN
THE BACKFIELD, AND HE'S A
QUALITY RUNNER OF THE FOOTBALL.
I THINK CHANDLER SCOTT MIGHT BE
THE NEXT THING OFF THE BOARD.
ASAZE AUTOMAWO.
KIND OF A BIG PICK FOR SOMEONE
WHO INVESTED A LOT OF CAPITAL IN
THE DEFENSIVE LINE.
LY --DARION SMITH.
>> I'LL BE CURIOUS TO SEE.
KIM HAS A TRADITIONAL 3 TECH OR
A Z GUY THAT'S GOING TO SLIM
DOWN AND BE A TYPICAL EDGE
RUSHER WHERE HE'S GRANTED THAT
TIME TO DO SO.
>> WE GOT YOUR GUY.
THE BENGALS PICK TYSON ANDERSON.
>> WE'RE DEFINITELY GOING TO
BREAK THIS DOWN.
THEY'RE MOVING UP FOR HIM.
AS OUR GUY SAID, HOLD ONTO YOUR
BUTTS.
JOEL SCHULTZ SAID THEY'RE TAKING
TYSON ANDERSON.
THIS IS SOMEONE TO ME WHO HAD
BEEN OVERLOOKED IN THE PROCESS
FOR A LONG TIME.
STRONG SAFETY.
KIND OF A SLOT CORNER AS WELL
FROM TOLEDO AND BIG PLAYER RIGHT
HERE.
F
RAN IN THE FOUR 3.
THREE-TIME CAPTAIN.
HE HAD BEEN THE DUDE FOR A LONG
TIME.
YOU LOOK AT SPECIAL TEAMS
EXPERIENCE, OVER 800 SNAPS ON
SPECIAL TEAMS.
THEY'VE USED HIM AT BOTH SAFETY
SPOTS.
SLOT CORNER IN THE BOX.
THEY'LL PUT HIM RIGHT ON THE
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE AND SAY NOSE
TO NOSE WITH THE BIG BOYS.
WE TRUST YOU.
HE'S GOT THE ALPHA MENTALITY.
HE PLAYS EVERY SINGLE POSITION
ON DEFENSE.
YOU WANT HIM TO PLAY LINEBACKER,
HE CAN GAIN TEN POUNDS AND PLAY
LINEBACKER.
HE'S A MATCH-UP PLAYER AGAINST
TIGHT ENDS THAT IS GOING TO BE A
SUPERSTAR ON SPECIAL TEAMS.
I LOVE WHAT THE BENGALS GOT
HERE.
THEY GOT ONE OF THE MOST
VALUABLE PLAYERS FOR ME.
WE ARE AT THE END OF THE FIFTH
ROUND IN THE 160s.
THIS IS AN A-PLUS.
SMALL SCHOOL, HIGHLY PRODUCTIVE,
THREE-YEAR TEAM CAPTAIN.
>> I LOVE THE THREE-YEAR TEAM
CAP
CAPTAIN.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT A B-PLUS.
I DO THINK HE'S AT HIS BEST
COMING DOWN, NOT GOING
BACKWARDS.
THAT IS A VERY SPECIFIC SAFETY
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR.
I THINK HE WOULD BE GREAT.
ESPECIALLY EARLY ON, IF YOU'RE
IN GOAL LINE, IF YOU'RE PLAYING.
THE BIG THING I'M LOOKING FOR
OUT OF HIM IS WHAT TO GET FROM
THESE SUPER TIGHT ENDS.
ISAIAH LIKELY, WHEN THEY GET A
CHANCE TO LEAK OUT AND MAKE A
PLAY, WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE
ON THE FIELD AND HOW DOES HE
HANDLE THAT, BECAUSE THESE GUYS,
THEY'RE NOT JUST BIG, THEY'RE
ALSO FAST.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW, FELGER, I LIKE THE
CHEST MATCHUP, RIGHT, WE'RE
SEEING IN THE AFC NORTH.
TOREY AND GOING TO JUMP IN HERE
IN A SECOND.
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH PAT
FREIERMUTH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE TIGHT
ENDS IN THIS CONVERSATION?
>> SOMEONE HAS TO BE ABLE TO
COVER THOSE GUYS.
I THINK TYSON ANDERSON CERTAINLY
CAN DO THAT.
AS YOU ALL MENTIONED, HE CAN
PLAY EVERY POSITION ON THE DEEP
SIDE OF THE BALL.
PAIR HIM UP WITH JESSE WRIGHT,
SO HE'S GOT SORMT GUYS BECAUSE
HE CAN ADD SO MUCH.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO HIM
BATTLE WITH HIS TIGHT ENDS IN
HIS DWCHLT WITH THAT BEING SAID,
WE'LL TAKE A MINI BREAK AND A
LITTLE REMINDER FROM OUR FRIENDS
AT ROCKET MORTGAGE.
>>> A FELLOW TO ME, SIZE, HE'S
GOT SPEED, FOUND THE FOOTBALL.
THAT KPIEXCITES ME IN THE FIFTH
ROUND.
YOU DON'T SEE THE SIZE OF THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF COMPETITION,
BUT I THINK IT'S GOING TO
TRANSLATE BECAUSE HE FOUND THE
WAYS TO MAKE PLAYS ON THE BALL.
>> THE BIG KEY FOR ME IS THAT HE
ALSO FWAS THE GUY WHO PRTRANSFED
IN TO FRESNO STATE.
THE BIG THING HE DOES IS HE'S
BEEN AROUND MULTIPLE SCHEMES,
BEEN AROUND DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PLAYERS, BEEN AROUND --
BASICALLY HE'S JUST BEEN AROUND.
SO THE BIG KEY FOR ME IS THE GUY
WHO STARTS OFF IN THE FCS AND
THEN TRANSFERS UP TO FBS IN
FRESNO STATE.
FRESNO STATE'S DEFENSE WAS
NASTY.
THEY MADE BIG PLAYS, FOUND WAYS
TO BE DISRUPTIVE --
>> PLAYED FAST.
>> YES, PLAYED FAST.
HE IS SO CAPABLE AND I THINK
HE'S GOING TO BE SOMEONE THAT
WILL BE A SURPRISE WHEN YOU GET
INTO CAMP.
HE'LL SURPRISE SOME OF THE VETS
THAT, WOW, OKAY, THIS IS WHAT
THEY'RE TEACHING YOU OUT THERE
IN THE VALLEY?
>> I'M BACK ON THE CLOCK HERE
FOR THE BEARS AS THE BEARS WANT
TO SHOW MORE OF THAT DEFENSE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE COWBOYS AND
THE COWBOYS HAVE HAD A REALLY
INTERESTING DRAFT.
OFFENSIVE LINE MAN FROM TULSA,
JAKE FERGUSON 2.0.
MATT WALESCO.
FOR DALLAS THEY'VE LOST SOME
GUYS IN FREE AGENCY.
NOW THEY'RE LOOKING TO REPLACE
THEM WITH THE DEEP DRAFT.
YOU LOOK AT THE BOARD FOR
DALLAS.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU.
>> I LIKE WILLIAMS.
THEY'VE DEVELOPED A LINE
EXCESSIVILY WELL, AND BLAND IS
SOMEONE THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE HIM A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TO SEE
HIM PLAYING OBVIOUSLY SPECIAL
TEAMS BUT SOME SIGNIFICANT
ACTUAL SNAPS THIS YEAR BECAUSE
OF THE LENGTH AND BECAUSE OF THE
ABILITY TO GET THREE CORNERS,
FOUR CORNERS OUT THERE ON THE
FIELD, BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
TEAM -- IF YOU GET FIVE WIDE,
WHY NOT HAVE HIM IN THE GAME AS
PART OF YOUR PACKAGE?
>> I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
DEFINITELY SOME SPACE TO FIND A
WAY TO GET ON THE FIELD.
SO THE BEARS ARE ON THE CLOCK
RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE PICK TO
COME IN.
WE HAD KYREN WILLIAMS FINALLY
COME OFF THE BOARD AND THE
OFFENSIVE LINE IN BRAXTON JONES
FROM SOUTHERN UTAH.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE BEARS AND
THE OFFENSIVE LINE.
>> HE IS PROBABLY NOT READY TO
PLAY HERE.
THERE HAVE BEEN EYES ON THIS
GOOR FOR A LONG TIME.
NOW, WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
BRAXTON JONES.
THE NOTABLE THING FOR ME, GUYS,
OUT OF THE STANDS.
HOW QUICKLY CAN YOU SHOOT OUT OF
THE STANDS?
WHEN YOU'RE OVER 300 POUNDS, CAN
YOU GET YOURSELF IN POSITION
WHERE YOU'RE A STEP AHEAD OF THE
DEFENSIVE E■ND?
HIS ABILITY, I THINK, TO MOVE,
FELGER, STANDS OUT TO ME.
HAND PLACEMENT PROBABLY NEEDS A
LITTLE WORK.
I WOULD HAVE LIKED THEM TO
ADDRESS THIS EARLY BUT THE VALUE
CHECKS OUT.
PLAYER 172 FOR ME.
WE ARE AT A PICK RIGHT IN THAT
170 RANGE.
THIS IS A B FOR ME.
THE BEARS NID A DEFENSIVE
LINEUP.
HE'S NOT READY TO BE ON THE
FIELD JUST YET BUT THIS IS A
2003 DEVELOPMENTAL PICK.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO KNOCK THE GUY
DOWN, NOT HAVE THE GUY SHOCK
YOU.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO MAKE HIM GO
BACKWARDS.
THAT'S THE WHOLE GOAL HERE.
I THINK THAT WATCHING HIM PLAY,
THE BEARS WILL TRY TO KEEP HIM
IN TACKLE AND GROW HIM INTO THE
POSITION SO HE CAN BE A
REPLACEMENT LONG TERM.
THE BIG KEY IS GOING TO BE HOW
HE TAKES THE COACHING AND HOW HE
TAKES THE NFL STRENGTH PROGRAM
SO HE CAN GROW AS A PLAYER.
I THINK THIS IS A B.
I THINK THE BIG KEY IS GOING TO
BE -- THE ONLY REASON I'M NOT
GIVING IT A HIGHER GRADE IS
BECAUSE I DO LIKE THE PLAYER.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE IN A
POSITION TO BE BUILDING DEPTH.
BUT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
BUILDING DEPTH BECAUSE THEY'LL
BE WINNING NOW.
>> THE MINNESOTA VIKINGS GOT A
LITTLE BIT OF DEPTH PIECE THAT
WORKS AROUND ALVIN COOK.
TY CHANDLER COMES OFF THE BOARD
WITH FELGER'S FAVES LIST.
>> THIS IS A GREAT PICK FOR
THEM.
WE SAW HIM BE EXPLOSIVE.
LOOK AT HIM HERE, PUSH WIDE,
PUSH WIDE AND SEE THE HOLE, AND
HE EXPLODES THROUGH IT.
HE'S WILLING TO GET TO THE
SIDELINE.
PUNISHING A GUY AGAINST THE U.
LITTLE SPEED ON THE FLIPOUT SIDE
TO GET TO THE PYLON BEFORE
SOMEONE ELSE.
HE CAN ALSO CATCH A BALL IN THE
BACKFIELD.
HE'S A LITTLE HIDE AND SEEK
RUNNING BACK, AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS I LIKE ABOUT HIM.
YOU SEE HIM SPRINTING FAR WIDE.
HE'S GOT A FOOT ON THE GROUND
AND HE'S GETTING BACK INSIDE OF
YOU.
HE'S A FELGER FAVE.
HE'S GOING TO BE A WELCOME
ADDITION TO THAT RUNNING BACK
ROOM.
>> THREE QUICK THINGS BECAUSE WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM TOREY HOLT.
PASS CATCHING, CATCH THE BALL,
GET UPFIELD.
CATCH THE BALL, GET UPFIELD AND
MAKE PLAYS, SPECIAL TEAMS
CONTRIBUTOR.
THIS IS A B-PLUS FOR ME, A
PLAYER THAT MAYBE IS A SMIDGE
EARLY FOR ME, BUT I LOVE HIM IN
A WIDE ZONE, I LOVE THE STRAIGHT
GAS SPEED.
I HEARD A LOT OF PRAISE FROM YOU
ABOUT THIS GUY BEFORE WE EVEN
WENT ON.
WHAT DO YOU GOT FOR US?
>> I WAS FORTUNATE.
I LIVE HERE IN ACC COUNTRY, SO I
WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO SEE TY
CHANDLER PLAY WITH SAM HOWELL.
I THOUGHT THEY COULD HAVE GIVEN
THE BALL TO AMORE.
FULL SPEED, PATIENT, GOOD HANDS.
THE MINNESOTA VIKINGS ARE ADDING
MORE OFFENSIVE WEAPONS FOR KIRK
CAN Y
COUSINS.
YOU HAVE COOK IN THE BACKFIELD,
YOU HAVE TWO GOOD BACKS THAT CAN
PLAY OFF EACH OTHER, BUT LOOK AT
HIM RIGHT THERE GOING UP AGAINST
THE ONE-HANDED CATCH, THE
CONCENTRATION, THE ABILITY TO
PLAY IN THE BACKFIELD AND THEN
THE PATIENCE DOWN IN THE RED
ZONE.
HE CAN GIVE YOU VALUE THERE.
I LIKE THE PICK.
AGAIN, I THOUGHT CAROLINA COULD
HAVE GIVEN IT TO HIM MORE, BUT
MINNESOTA SAYS, YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE'S FAIRLY FRESH.
WE'RE GOING TO USE HIM AS MUCH
AS YOU CAN TO ELEVATE HIM.
>> TY CHANDLER COMING OFF THE
BOARD TO THE MINNESOTA VIKINGS.
THAT'S A SCHEME BUILT FOR HIS
SKILL SET.
>> HE'S NOT DeVON COOK, BUT THEY
RUN IN A SIMILAR STYLE.
>> WHEN SOMEONE PLAYS WITH COOK,
THEY KNOW HOW TO RUN THE RUSH
LANE AND TY CHANDLER CAN RUN
THOSE.
MOVING TO HOUSTON, TEXAS, WE'RE
BACK ON THE CLOCK.
WE HAVE ANOTHER TIGHT END PICK.
IT'S BEEN A TIGHT END DAY.
TEIGEN TEKORIONDO.
I THINK HE CAN SURVIVE IN LINE,
AND I THINK HE CAN GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF A PASS CATCHER AS
WELL.
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT RUN
HERE FOR TIEGEN.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING TO
GRADE THIS ONE, BUT WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF HIM AS A PLAYER COMING
OUT OF OREGON STATE?
>> 19 CATCHERS THIS SEASON.
NOT A LOT OF TARGETS.
THE BIG THING FOR ME IS THIS IS
THE GUY YOU GET TO MOVE BODIES.
HE'S YOUR HEAVY PACKAGE
TIGHT END.
HE'S THE GUY THE OTHER TEAM
KNOWS, WE'RE MEANT TO RUN THE
FOOTBALL, OR IF WE'RE GOING TO
TH
THROW IT, IT'S GOING TO BE A
MASS PROTECT THROW.
HE'S A BY GUY, EVEN CLOSER TO
265 AT THE NEXT LEVEL, SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT HE
BRINGS TO THE TABLE.
>> KEEPING THINGS MOVING HERE,
WE HAVE THE CLOCK FLYING.
THE DENVER BRONCOS, LUKE
WATTENBURG FROM WASHINGTON,
FELGER, DID NOT MAKE MY TOP
CENTER IN THIS CLASS.
WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT WA
WATTENBURG?
>> HE'S SOMEONE WHO KNEW WHAT HE
WAS DOING.
YOU KNOW YOU DIDN'T HAVE HIM ON
THE BOARD, BUT THIS GUY STARTED
THE MAJORITY OF THE GAMES.
I WANT TO SAY HE DIDN'T START
ONLY SIX GAMES.
PLAYED AYTON OF FOOTBALL.
HE IS SOMEONE THAT HE'S NOT
REMARKABLE FROM AN ATHLETIC
STANDPOINT, BUT WHAT HE IS IS
REMARKABLY CONSISTENT AND
PATIENT.
HE'S GOT A GREAT ANCHOR.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET MIDDLE
PRESSURE ON HIM UNLESS YOU BRING
IN AN EXTRA LINEBACKER.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I LIKED
ABOUT HIM, IF HE CAN PLAY WITH
YOU ONE ON ONE, HE'S GOING TO
WIN THAT BATTLE ENOUGH TO GET
THE QUARTERBACK OFF.
>> HE STARTED AS TACKLE, STARTED
AS GUARD, THEN PANDEMIC SEASON,
YOU'RE A CENTER.
LIKE FELGER SAID, HE'S PLAYED A
LOT OF FOOTBALL.
THE DENVER BRONCOS LOOKING FOR
HIM.
MAYBE THEY SAY, HEY, PUT THE
WEIGHT BACK ON.
WE THINK YOU CAN FLEX GUARD
CENTER AS WELL.
>>> THE NINERS ARE BACK ON THE
CLOCK AT 172 HERE.
LET'S PULL UP THE NINERS' PICKS
HERE, GUYS, AND THEY ARE ALL
OVER, TY CHANDLER, WE'VE HAD A
LITTLE MINI TIGHT END RUN GET A
LITTLE CRAZY HERE, LUKE
WATTENBURG, AND WE HAD THE NEXT
PICK FROM -- THE NINERS ARE
STAYING THERE.
SAMUEL WOLMACK IS COMING IN THE
PICTURE HERE.
WE ARE AHEAD OF THE TV HERE.
WE'RE AHEAD OF THE PICKS THAT
I'M FOLLOWING AS WELL HERE.
THE NINERS GO OFF THE BOARD ALL
THE TIME, MAN.
SAM WOLMACK, NOT A PLAYER
EXPECTED TO GO EARLY ON DAY
THREE.
A LITTLE BIT OF A SMALL CORNER
HERE BUT AN EXPLOSIVE ATHLETE.
MY FIRST THOUGHT IS THEY'RE
LOOKING TO DEVELOP A LONG-TERM
SLOT.
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE THE ONLY
ANSWER HERE.
HE'S A SMALLER GUY BUT HE IS
QUICK.
THE BIG KEY FOR ME IS HOW HE'S
ABLE TO WORK THAT SMALL SPACE,
THAT BUBBLE THAT EXISTS BETWEEN
THE WIDE RECEIVER AND THAT LINE
OF SCRIMMAGE.
HE'S A GUY WITH SHORT AREA
QUICKNESS AND HOW HE'S ABLE TO
GROW INTO THAT ROLE WILL BE
CRITICAL.
PUSHING UP TO THE GUY IN THE
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE OR BE PATIENCE
ENOUGH TO HMIRROR AND REROUTE T
CUT OFF THOSE EASY PASSES.
>> THEY'RE VERY POPULAR AT
TAKING DAY THREE CORNERS,
DEVELOPING THEM.
THE NEW YORK GIANTS ARE BACK ON
THE CLOCK.
LEGA
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE FULL
LOAD.
THEY MADE THREE PICKS ON DAY
TWO, AND NOW, MICHAEL FELGER, WE
SIT HERE ON DAY THREE AND THEY
HAVE BEEN PRETTY BUSY.
THE NEW YORK GIANTS, YOU SEE IT
RIGHT HERE, GUYS.
MICHAEL McFADDEN BEEFING UP THE
DEFENSE.
MICHAEL DAVIDSON, CORDELL FLAW,
A SLOT GUY.
MICHAEL FELGER, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THIS BOARD, ARE YOU SEEING ANY
KIND OF IDENTITY THEME WITH THE
NEW YORK GIANTS?
>> PRESSURE ON THIBODAUX.
STOUT IN THE MIDDLE.
>> OR A RELIABILITY WITH NEILL.
>> ALSO DJ DAVIDSON.
THEY WANT TO WORK OPTIONS, AND
THAT'S WHY SLOT IS A DEFENSIVE
OPTION.
YOU CAN CREATE MISMATCHES OR YOU
CAN CREATE PLAYS -- YOU CAN
CREATE MISDIRECTION.
MISDIRECTION LEADS TO BOTH
MISMATCHES AND BLOWN COVERAGES.
THEY'RE LOOKING TO MAKE LIFE
EASIER FOR DANIEL JONES SO THEY
CAN CREATE BIGGER PLAYS SO HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO FIVE YARDS,
FIVE YARDS, FIVE YARDS, FIVE
YARDS, ALL DOWN THE FIELD.
EVAN KNEEL IS GOING TO GIVE THEM
TIME TO HILT THOSE BIGGER PLAYS
DOWN THE FIELD.
>> MARCUS McKEITHEN IS THE PICK
FOR THE MIAMI DOLPHINS.
THIS IS SOMEBODY IN THE TOP 300.
MARCUS FELGER IS VERY FAMILIAR
WITH HIM.
A MAMMOTH OF A GUY.
6'6", 340 POUNDS.
LONG, LONG ARMS.
I LOOK AT FELGER AND THINK HE'S
GOING TO BE A GUARD IN THE GIANT
SYSTEM AND DRY BLOCKING IS WHAT
I THINK OF RIGHT AWAY WITH
McKEITHEN.
I LOOK AT THE NEW YORK GIANTS
AND GO EVAN NEALL.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET BIGGER,
STRONGER.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO GIVE SAQUON BARKLEY A
CHANCE.
THIS IS THE SECOND UNC OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN THEY HAVE TAKEN IN THIS
DRAFT, I BELIEVE, NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF MARCUS
McCETHAN?
>> THE BIG THING FOR HIM IS
PUSH.
AS LONG AS HE KEEPS THOSE HIPS
LOW, HE HAS THE ABILITY TO MOVE
ANYONE OFF THE POINT.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THEY WORK IS BASIC
TECHNIQUE THINGS TO MAKE SURE
HE'S NOT JUST RELYING ON THAT
SIZE.
HE HAS TO WORK ON TECHNIQUE SO
HE CAN GET THE JOB DONE, BUT IF
HE RELIES ON TECHNIQUE AS WE SAW
TWO SEASONS AGO.
A SEASON AGO WITH FLASHES IN THE
RUN GAME, HE'S ONE OF THOSE GUYS
THAT CAN HELP OPEN THINGS UP FOR
THE NEW YORK GIANTS.
>> HIM AND AZUZO RIGHT NOW, THE
GIANTS ARE TRYING TO GET BIGGER
AND STRONGER.
TOREY HOLT, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING
WITH THIS GIANTS TRIP?
>> THERE IS AN EMPHASIS ON
RUNNING THE FOOTBALL.
AND THEY WANT TO MAKE THINGS A
LOT MORE COMFORTABLE FOR DANIEL
JO
JONES, MAKE THE PASSING LANES A
LITTLE CLEARER.
THEY'RE FOCUSED ON PROTECTING
THE BOX BECAUSE THE RUN GAME IS
GOING WELL.
THEY'VE ADDED MORE OFFENSIVE
LINEMEN, THE GIANTS, BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO CONTROL THE
OFFENSIVE LINES.
THE GIANTS ARE SAYING, NFC EAST,
WE'RE GOING TO BE VERY, VERY
PHYSICAL.
WE'RE BIG GUYS THAT CAN MOVE
WHICH GIFRZ COVES CONFIDENCE TON
BARKLEY AND AY TON OF COUGHS FO
JONES.
>> YOU CAN SEE RIGHT THERE WE
TALK ABOUT SAW -- JAMAREE
SALYER.
A VERY SUCCESSFUL PASS RUSHER
FROM MIAMI AND OHIO.
I'M SURPRISED HE'S ON THE BOARD
HERE.
I THINK WE CAN DIVE INTO
DOMINIQUE DOTSON.
HE REMINDS ME OF JOSH SWEAT.
>> HE'S GOT THE SKILLS, HE'S GOT
THE ABILITY.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE HE USES
LEVERAGE.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE HE RUNS
THE HUMP.
YOU WANT HIM RUNNING THAT HUMP
TO GET TO THE QUARTERBACK.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO RUN THE
HUMP EARLY, EARLY, EARLY.
THAT'S HOW HE'LL HAVE TO SET UP
THE INSIDE MOVE BY RUNNING THE
HUMP, BEATING SOMEBODY TO THE
EDGE.
THE NEXT STEP FOR HIM IS
DEVELOPING MORE THAN THAT PASS
RUSH MOVE AND DEVELOPING SOME
CORE STRENGTH AND SOME
FUNCTIONAL STRENGTH TO
TRANSITION SOME OF THE SPEED HE
BRINGS TO THE TABLE TO POWER.
>> CONVERTER WIDE EDGE RECEIVER.
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU WON'T HEAR
ON THIS SHOW, YOU WON'T HEAR IT
ON NEXT YEAR'S SHOW.
HAND IN THE DIRT, HE CAN DO
BOTH.
THE JOSH SWEAT COMPARISON, THAT
EX PLOEPLOS
EXPLOSIVENESS.
PRODUCTION CAME FROM STUNTS AND
BLOCK RUSHES.
HE'S GOING TO WORK ON A TWO-HAND
SWIPE.
WE'RE GOING TO RUN THE FILM
RIGHT NOW.
DOMINIQUE ROBINSON, THAT'S THE
ABILITY TO USE HIS ATHLETICISM.
YOU'RE TRYING TO SIMPLIFY THINGS
FOR HIM ON THE FIELD.
DOMINIQUE ROBINSON, THIS IS AN
A+ FOR ME.
I LOVER  THE VALUE.
I THINK YOU COULD CAPITALIZE OFF
THAT ATHLETICISM AND SAY, YOU
NEED TO BE EXPLOSIVE ON THE
FOOTBALL.
THIS IS A GREAT PICK FOR
CHICAGO.
>> BEARS FANS ARE GOING TO LOVE
DOMINIQUE ROBINSON.
I THINK HE'LL TURN OUT TO BE ONE
OF THE STEALS OF THIS DRAFT.
I THINK THE KEY WILL BE MUSCLING
HIM UP.
I DON'T SAY THAT WITH ANY
DISRESPECT, WHAT HE'S BEEN ABLE
TO DO IN MIAMI OR OHIO OR ANYONE
ELSE, BUT THE KEY WILL BE
GETTING COMFORTABLE WITH BEING
TOUCHED ALL THE TIME, GETTING
COMFORTABLE WITH PEOPLE PUTTING
THEIR HANDS ON YOU AND FINDING A
WAY TO GET THEIR HANDS OFF YOU,
BEING EXPLOSIVE, RECOGNIZING YOU
CAN MAKE YOUR OWN HAY WITHOUT
COMING INTO A STUNT.
HE HAS TO GET COMFORTABLE WITH
ALL THOSE THINGS.
I WANT TO SEE MORE OF THIS
TAKING ON A BLOCK AND ENGAGING
WHICH MEANS HE HAS TO GET
STRONGER IN THOSE HAUNCHES.
THE KEY WILL BE MUSCLING UP --
WHEN YOU PLAY, AND I'M GIVING
THIS ONE A B+.
WHEN YOU PLAY ALONG THE FRONT,
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T THINK
ABOUT FOOTBALL THIS WAY, BUT I
DO.
I PLAYED SAFETY.
NOT MANY PEOPLE TOUCHED ME, AND
I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
WHEN YOU PLAY ON THE LINE, IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN BEING A RECEIVER.
ON THE LINE, SOMEBODY IS GOING
TO BE TOUCHING YOU.
I THINK HE HAS TO GET
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT,
COMFORTABLE WAY LACK OF SPACE.
HE'S EVOLVING INTO THAT AND THAT
WILL BE THE POINT WHERE YOU
START TO CRAVE THE CONTACT AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU CAN REALLY
OPERATE IN A PHONE BOOTH AND
CREATE YOUR SETUP MOVES.
>> THEY ARE LOOKING FOR PASS
RUSHING.
WE HEARD SOME RUMORS ABOUT
ROBERT QUINN, WHICH IS INSANE
CONSIDERING THE SEASON HE JUST
HAD.
>> AS A DEVELOPMENTAL PLAYER,
YOU GUYS HAVE TALKED ABOUT
TRANSITIONING FROM RECEIVER TO
NOW, DEFENSIVE END.
HE'S CERTAINLY AN ATHLETE, HAS
PLENTY OF SPEED, 205, AND IN
TIGHT SPACES THAT'S DIFFERENT
WHEN YOU'RE OUT WIDE AND YOU
HAVE A LOT OF SPACE.
THAT WILL BE SOMETHING HE'LL
HAVE TO ADJUST AND ADAPT TO.
WHEN HE PUTS ON THE WEIGHT AND
GETS STRONGER, MAYBE YOU CAN
KICK HIM INSIDE A LITTLE BIT AND
HE CAN USE HIS ATHLETICISM AND
SPEED TO GET TO THE QUARTERBACK.
I THINK THIS IS A DEVELOPMENTAL
PICK FOR SURE WITH DOMINIQUE
ROBINSON WHO IS A REALLY GOOD
ATHLETE, HAD A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF SPEED AND HE LOOKS LIKE HE
HAS A REALLY HIGH MOTOR.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE
BEARS HAVE DONE IN THE
OFF-SEASON SO FAR.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS HOPE FOR
JUSTIN FIELDS IN YEAR NUMBER
TWO, AND AS WE LOOK AT IT, THEY
ARE BUILDING THROUGH THE DRAFT
ON DEFENSE FOR NEW HEAD COACH.
OFFENSIVE LINE BACKGROUND.
WE LOVE THE JaQUANI BRISKER PIC.
>> I LOVE JaQUAN BRISKER.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE SAFETIES ON
THE BOARD.
NALUS JONES IS ANOTHER ONE.
HE'LL HELP YOU AS A WIDE
RECEIVER.
FIELDS NEEDS PROTECTION AND HE
NEEDS WEAPONS.
HE NEEDS GUYS HE CAN GET THE
BALL TO.
JONES IS A BIG REASON WHY THEY
PICKED HIM.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIDDEN YARDAGES
BEFORE, WE'LL GET A LITTLE BIT
OF THAT HIDDEN YARDAGE IN THE
RETURN GAME.
>> WE'RE WAITING FOR THE RAIDERS
WHO ARE ON THE CLOCK, PICK 175.
MATTHEW BUTLER, THE BIG
DEFENSIVE LINEMAN FROM TENNESSEE
COMES ON THE BOARD.
KEY VALUE HERE FOR MICHAEL
FELGER.
PLAYER 149.
REMINDS ME OF JaJUAN WEED.
I THINK HE'S STRONG, HE CAN
CONTROL THE RUN.
YOU'RE SEEING HIM ON THE OUTSIDE
THERE.
MATTHEW BUTLER GETTING THE
RAIDERS.
HE MADE A BIG TRADE FOR DaVONTE
ADAMS AND IT KIND OF FORCED
THEIR HAND WHERE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF PICKS.
THEY FOUND A WAY TO CAPITALIZE
ON A GUY AND GET SOME VALUE
HERE.
A FIVE-YEAR PLAYER IN COLLEGE
AND A GOOD ATHLETE AS WELL.
>> IT'S NOT SITUATIONALLY BASED.
GIVE THE OTHER GUYS A BREAK AND
TRUST THE GUY YOU'RE PUTTING ON
THE FIELD.
WITH MATTHEW BUTLER OF
TENNESSEE, YOU CAN TRUST HIM ON
THE FIELD.
I LIKE THE VALUE, I LIKE
ADDRESSING THE NEED, AND HE'S
ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHO WILL BE IN
THE LEAGUE FOR EIGHT YEARS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T NOTICE BUT
HE DOES HIS JOB.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT.
THE BIG THING FOR ME COMING
OUT -- IMMEDIATELY PEOPLE TRIED
TO COMPARE HIM TO CHAI TUTTLE.
HE'S A LITTLE BIT MORE LEAN.
CARRIES THAT WEIGHT A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY AND I LOVE THE FACT
HE'S GOT THE ABILITY TO SLIP IT
AND MAKE A PLAY.
HE STAYS BLOCKED BUT HE CO
CONDENSES THE HOLE SO SOMEBODY
ELSE CAN MAKE A PLAY.
THAT'S WHAT I LOVE ABOUT HIM.
HE NEVER LOSES GROUND.
HE ALWAYS CONDENSES THE HOLE SO
HE DOES HIS JOB.
I THINK THAT'S THE KEY TO HIM
PLAYING AS A ROTATIONAL PLAYER
EARLY IS HE'S GOING TO DO THE
JOB.
HE DOES HIS JOB, AND THEN YOU
SEE HIM THERE IN PURSUIT.
HE'S GOING TO GIVE YOU EFFORT AS
WELL.
THEY LOSE JONES, THEY ADD GUYS
WHO WILL HELP THEM OUT.
YOU LOSE A GUY LIKE CASEY
HEYWARD.
THEY HAVE ANOTHER GUY WHO WILL
BE A ROTATIONAL PLAYER.
I HAVE TO GO B+ HERE.
I THINK MATTHEW BUTLER, FIFTH
YEAR PLAYER, HE'S SOMEONE THAT
COMES IN AND UNDERSTANDS.
LISTEN, I WAS NEVER THE STAR AT
TENNESSEE.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE THE STAR
FORT RAIDERS.
>> HE'S OKAY WITH THAT.
>> I'M FINE WITH THAT.
YOU KNOW WHO I'M GOING TO BE?
I'M GOING TO BE A GUY WHO NEVER
GETS YELLED AT.
CAN WE BRING TOREY IN BECAUSE
THERE IS A LOT OF VALUE TO BEING
THE GUY WHO NEVER GETS YELLED
AT.
>> ESPECIALLY FROM A NEW ENGLAND
COACHING STAFF.
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR TOREY'S
THOUGHTS.
THEY LIKE GUYS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE IN THE CLASSIC.
DO YOUR JOB.
>> MATURE GUYS.
YOU WANT MATURE PLAYERS THAT CAN
COME IN AND CAN ADJUST
THEMSELVES TO THE WAY THAT YOU
DO THINGS, ADJUST THEMSELVES TO
THE COACH IMMEDIATELY.
IF YOU'RE A GUY NOT GETTING
YELLED AT A LOT, THAT MEANS
YOU'RE DOING YOUR JOB.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT YOUR ROLE
IS, YOU UNDERSTAND YOUR JOB AND
YOU'RE TAKING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PRIDE IN GOING OUT
THERE EVERY SINGLE DAY TO GET
THAT DONE.
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF PLAYERS
THAT BILL BELICHICK AND HIS
STAFF LIKE.
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND A
FEW MONTHS IN NEW ENGLAND BEFORE
RETIRING, AND IT IS AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT COMPETES.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW YOUR
ASSIGNMENT.
IT'S ABOUT RESPECTING YOUR
TEAMMATES, AND IT IS ABOUT
RESPECTING THE GAME OF FOOTBALL.
THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN CREATED THERE
IN NEW ENGLAND.
I THINK THESE GUYS CAN COME IN
AND FIT RIGHT IN RIGHT AWAY,
BEING THAT THEY ARE MATURE
PLAYERS.
>> I LIKE IT.
YEAH.
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE FOR THE
RAIDERS AND YOU'LL SEE THAT BE A
THEME IN THE COACHING STAFF.
WE HAVE THE COWBOYS DOING A COOK
IN DAMON CLARK.
DAMON CLARK, LINEBACKER FROM
LSU.
HE CAN RUN AND CHASE, HE'S
EXPLOSIVE.
HE CAN RUN DOWNHILL AND MAKE
PLAYS.
DERICK STINGLEY DID NOT PLAY A
LOT THIS YEAR, SO IT WAS DAMON
CLARK.
IT SOUNDS LIKE HE WON'T BE ABLE
IN THE 2022 SEASON DUE TO
SURGERY.
FOR ME WHEN I WATCHED DAMON
CLARK ON TAPE, I SAW A SECOND
ROUND TALENT, A 3-DOWN
LINEBACKER THAT COULD DO IT ALL.
HE WAS NOT AN EVERY TEAM SPORT
BECAUSE THE UNCERTAINTY THAT HE
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO PLAY
FOOTBALL AGAIN, OBVIOUSLY THE
COWBOYS ARE OKAY WITH THIS IN
THE FIFTH ROUND.
THAT'S A GREAT SIGN FOR HIM,
ROOTING FOR HIM, AND YOU MOVED
MICHAEL PARSONS.
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THIS GUY CAN
COME IN AND BE A 3-DOWN PLAYER.
I LIKE TAKING A GAMBLE ON THE
FIFTH ROUND.
THIS IS AN "A" FOR ME.
>> HE TACKLES PEOPLE AND THEY GO
BACKWARDS.
>> YES.
>> HE DOES HAVE TREMENDOUS SPEED
BUT THE REALITY OF IT IS, HE
TACKLES PEOPLE AND THEY GO
BACKWARDS.
THIS IS A GUY PATIENT IN
COVERAGE.
HE'S WILLING TO RUN AND THEY'LL
CHASE YOU DOWN, GET YOU DOWN ON
THE GROUND.
HE UNDERSTANDS WHERE RUN FITS
WORK, HOW RUN FITS WORK.
THAT'S READING A PLAY AND GOING
TO MAKE A TACKLE ACROSS THE
FIELD.
THIS IS AGAINST ALABAMA.
HIM IN THE HOLE AND HE'S CHASING
DOWN BRIAN ROBINSON.
HE GELTS THE JOB DONE.
THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW,
HE'S NUMBER 18 AT LSU.
GUYS WHO HAVE WORN 18, JACOB
HESTER, TRASAVIUS WHITE.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT A B+
BECAUSE OF THE MEDICAL, BUT IF
HE'S HEALTHY, HE HAS AN AMAZING
NFL CAREER AHEAD OF HIM.
>> TO CLARIFY THAT SITUATION,
AFTER AN MRI HE UNDERWENT SPINAL
FUSION SURGERY AT THE END OF
MARCH.
HE IS EXPECTED TO MISS HIS
ROOKIE SEASON BUT IT EXPECTED TO
MAKE A FULL RECOVERY.
>> HE SHOULD MISS HIS ROOKIE
SEASON.
>> THEY CAN AFFORD THAT AT THE
LINEBACKER POSITION.
THAT'S OKAY FOR DALLAS.
AS WE SEE DALLAS' DRAFT
POSITIONS HERE, IT'S A LONG
LIST.
WE ARE WAITING FOR THE LIONS TO
MAKE THEIR PICK AT 177.
IT'S SOMETHING THE MAN SITTING
NEXT TO ME LIKE VERY MUCH.
THE COWBOYS PICKED JOHN
RIDGEWAY, I BELIEVE.
WE NEED TO GET THE LIONS' PICK
AS WELL.
>> JAMES MITCHELL FOR TIGHT END.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT INJURED
GUYS.
JAMES MITCHELL IS SOMEONE THAT
HAS HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS AS
WELL.
LET'S DIVE INTO MITCHELL AND
THEN WE'LL GO LONGER ON
RIDGEWAY.
IT'S ALWAYS INTERESTING TO ME,
FELGER, WHEN A GUY IN HIS LAST
YEAR OF COLLEGE HAS THE
UNFORTUNATE INJURY, OBVIOUSLY.
THE LONG STORY SHORT IS HE TORE
HIS ACL IN SEPTEMBER, IT COST
HIM A SEASON AND IT COST HIM THE
ALL-STAR GAMES.
THIS IS A SENIOR THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN AT THE SENIOR BOWL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT KIND OF
CATCH AND RUN TALENT.
IN A BIG SEASON IN A SEASON
BOWL, HE COULD HAVE BEEN UP
THERE WITH THE GREG DULCHES OF
THE WORLD.
EVERYONE COMES BACK FROM ACLs,
THAT'S NO SURPRISE.
HE HAS A GOOD CATCH RADIUS, A
GOOD BUILD.
WE'LL GET TO RIDGEWAY IN A
SECOND.
FEL
FELGER, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
RIDGEWAY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> ONLY FIVE CATCHES IN TWO
GAMES, REALLY, ONE AND A HALF
GAMES IN 2021 BECAUSE OF THE
INJURY.
LOSES THAT SEASON.
ELECTED NOT TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
HE SAID, THIS IS IT FOR ME, I'M
GOING TO SEE WHAT I CAN DO AT
THE NEXT LEVEL.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WATCHING
HIM GET HEALTHY.
THIS IS A GUY WHO RUNS AWAY FROM
PEOPLE, CATCHES THE JUMP BALL.
A POORLY THROWN PASS.
YOU SEE HIM THERE, BIG TARGET.
HE'S GOT THE ABILITY TO GET THE
JOB DONE.
6'3", 6'4".
SHIFTINESS RIGHT THERE, STOP ON
A DIME.
HE CAN GET THE JOB DONE.
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD PICK.
HE'S SOMEONE WHO, IF YOU GIVE
HIM AN OPPORTUNITY, HE'S GOING
TO MAKE YOU PAY AND I THINK HE'S
A MISMATCH GUY.
I LOOK AT THIS AND OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF THE INJURY, I'M GOING
TO GIVE IT TO B.
BUT AS YOU MENTIONED, IF HE'S
HEALTHY THROUGH THIS YEAR, HE
PROBABLY HAS 30 CATCHES.
MAYBE VIRGINIA TECH IS A BIT
BETTER AS A FOOTBALL TEAM, AND
HE GETS THAT PRE-DRAFT
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX.
>> IT'S BEEN THE DAY OF TIGHT
ENDS.
TIGHT END, TIGHT END, TIGHT END.
FELGER, WHAT TO ME STICKS OUT IS
NO JASON LATTIMORE.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WE'VE BEEN
EXCITED ABOUT WATCHING IN A
COLLEGE FOOTBALL LEVEL AS A
CATCHER AND BLOCKER FOR A COUPLE
YEARS NOW.
A LOT OF TIGHT ENDS HERE, GUYS.
WE HAD TREY MCBRIDE, JOHNNY
WOODS, RUCKER, ALL THESE GUYS
COULD BLOCK.
DANIEL BELLINGER, TEN TIGHT
ENDS, NO WADEMEYER YET.
I DO THINK HE'LL COME OFF THE
BOARD, BUT YEAH.
FOR ME, MY FAVORITE TIGHT END IN
THIS GROUP IS MCBRIDE.
MY SLEEPER IN ALL OF THIS,
THOUGH, IN MY OPINION, IS WHAT
JAKE FERGUSON IS WATCHING INTO.
>> HE CAN SIT IN THE MIDDLE ON
GAME KOVRNL.
I'M HOPING HE CAN NURSE HIMSELF
BACK HEALTHY, BECAUSE IF HE
DOES, HE GIVES THAT DETROIT
LIONS' OFFENSE ANOTHER TIGHT END
TO GO ALONG WITH THE GUY THEY
HAVE THERE NOW, I'M HAVING A
BRAIN FREEZE, HAWKESON.
THEN I LIKE MCBRIDE, THE
TIGHT END YOU MENTIONED.
I HAD A CHANCE TO SEE HIM AT THE
COMBINE, TREMENDOUS TALENT.
GREG DULCHES, I HAD A CHANCE TO
SEE HIM AT THE COMBINE AND I WAS
VERY, VERY IMPRESSED WITH HIS
PHYSICALITY.
HE IS SUCH A PHYSICAL SPECIMAN.
HE IS HUGE, GREAT SIZE,
TREMENDOUS WORK ETHIC.
HE'S AN ■ENERGY GUY.
HIGH TEMPO TYPE OF PLAYER.
THOSE ARE THE TWO TIGHT ENDS FOR
ME THAT COME TO MIND.
>> GOOD STUFF FROM TOREY HOLT.
FELGER, WE HAVE THE FINAL TWO
PICKS OF THE ROUND.
WE HAVE TO START WITH YOUR GUY
JOHN RIDGEWAY GOING TO DALLAS.
TALKED ABOUT IT EARLIER IN THE
DRAFT.
A TRUE GUY THAT CAN TAKE UP A
LOT OF SPACE AND CONTROL THE
POINT OF ATTACK.
WE KNOW HE GOT THE JOHN RIDGEWAY
FOOTAGE.
LET'S GET RIGHT INTO IT.
A TRUE ZERO.
I BIG GUY, A TOUGH GUY.
ALWAYS WANTS TO BE INVOLVED IN
THE PLAY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT RIDGEWAY, WHAT
DOES HE BRING TO DALLAS.
>> THIS IS A BIG PICKUP FOR
THEM.
THAT'S WHY HE'S ONE OF MY
FAVORITE PLAYERS.
HE WAS A HEART AND SOUL DEFENSE.
EVERYTHING WENT THROUGH HIM.
WE TALK ABOUT PLAYING IN THE
MIDDLE.
LOOK AT HIM MOVE FROM SIDE TO
SIDE.
HE'S NOT JUST GOING TO EAT
SPACE, HE'S GOING TO EAT YOUR
FACE OFF.
THIS GUY PLAYS HARD FOOTBALL.
GET UP FIELD, GO BACK DOWNFIELD
TO MAKE A TACKLE.
HE IS A TRUE, TRUE -- I THINK
HE'S GOT AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
A TRUE IMPACT ON THIS FOOTBALL
TEAM THIS SEASON.
HE IS A PLAYMAKER, A GUY THAT
WANTS TO DISENGAGE TO GO MAKE A
TACKLE, BUT ALSO A GUY THAT
UNDERSTANDS HIS ROLE IN THE
DEFENSE.
IF YOU NEED ME TO OCCUPY TWO, I
CAN OCCUPY TWO.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO LET ME SLIP
AND GET THE QUARTERBACK, GET THE
RUNNING BACK, I WILL CHASE HIM
DOWN.
THIS IS AN A+ FOR ME.
I HAVE TO GIVE HIM THE PLUS
BECAUSE YOU'RE GETTING A GUY I
RANKED A LITTLE EARLIER.
I LOVE THE WAY HE BECAME THE
HEART AND SOUL OF THAT TEAM AND
A TEAM THAT FOUND THEIR IDENTITY
UNDER SAM PITMAN.
NOT IN THE SENSE OF RECRUITING,
BUT THIS IS THE SENSE THAT HE
WANTED FOR HIS FOOTBALL TEAM AND
HE'LL BE LOOKING FOR JOHN
RIDGEWAY AS HE PROGRESSES AS A
COACH IN ARKANSAS, BUT HE CAN
FLAT OUT PLAY.
>> HE REMINDS ME OF Ta'QUON
JONES.
WHEN THEY LET HIM GO A LITTLE
BIT, HE CAN MAKE PLAYS.
PLAYER 151 ON THE BIG BOARD, AND
THEY'RE PICKING ALL THE WAY IN
THE DRAFT DOWN TO 180.
A SOLID, SOLID PICK FOR THE
DALLAS COWBOYS THAT NEEDED
INTERIOR DEFENSE IVE LINE HELP.
THE FINAL PICK OF THE FIFTH
ROUND, THE GREEN BAY PACKERS
FINALLY TAKE KINGSLEY AND
IGBARRA.
HE'S SOMEBODY THAT PLAYS HARD.
GUYS LIKE THAT CAN HANG AROUND
THE LEAGUE FOR A LONG TIME
BECAUSE YOU CAN TRUST THEM TO
SET A HARD EDGE AND YOU CAN
TRUST THEM TO MAKE EFFORT AS A
PASS RUSHER.
I
IGBARI, LONG ARMS.
NOT THE MOST DYNAMIC ATHLETE BUT
I THINK HE'S EXPLOSIVE ENOUGH.
VIOLENT STAND-UP RUSHER.
HE DOESN'T POSSESS THE BEND
WHERE YOU GET EXCITED ABOUT THE
LACK OF TWITCH AS A RUSHER.
HE'S STRONG ENOUGH, HE'S NFL
STRONG.
THAT WILL CARRY OVER ON A ROLE
FOR GREEN BAY.
THIS IS A VALUE PICK FOR ME.
THIS IS AN "A."
HE'S BEEN REALLY PRODUCTIVE.
WHAT CAN HE DO?
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT ELSE HE CAN
DO.
I'M SEEING THERE UNBLOCKED.
HE'S GREAT UNBLOCKED.
SET THE EDGE AGAINST THE RUN.
I LIKE THAT, TOO.
DISENGAGE AND MAKE A PLAY.
I DO LIKE THAT.
WHAT ELSE CAN YOU DO FOR ME?
WHAT CAN YOU DO?
CAN YOU GET TO THE QUARTERBACK
WHEN THEY PUT SOMEBODY ON?
ARE YOU GOING TO BE TWITCHY
ENOUGH TO HELP ME ON SPECIAL
TEAMS?
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT WOULD BE
ON THERE BECAUSE I WONDER WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN HE GETS ASKED
TO DO OTHER THINGS.
WHEN THEY THINK, OH, THIS GUY
MIGHT GET TO OUR QUARTERBACK,
THEN I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S NEXT
FOR HIM.
I WANT TO SEE HIM DEVELOP MORE
AND THAT'S A BIG KEY FOR ME IS
THE FUTURE DEVELOPMENT, AND I
WONDER HOW MUCH MORE HE CAN TAKE
ON, OR IS HE MAXED OUT?
>>.
>> HE'S AN SEC PLAYER.
IS THERE A CREATIVITY THERE THAT
CAN BE UNLOCKED?
>> I THINK OF DANTE FOWLER.
HE WAS AN INCREDIBLY VIOLENT
PLAYER.
I THINK HE'S A LITTLE MORE
ATHLETIC BUT STILL HAS HAD A
ROUGH TIME TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT HE ACTUALLY IS IN THE NFL.
>> ONCE THE POWER GOT STOPPED,
IT'S NOT LOSING INTEREST BUT
IT'S ALSO WHAT CAN I DO?
HOW DO YOU COUNTER?
>> I LOVED FOWLER COMING OUT,
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> I DID, TOO.
>> I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE A
REVELATION, THEN ONCE THE POWER
WAS STOPPED, THE NEXT STEP WAS,
OH, NO, WHAT DO I DO?
AND THAT'S THE QUESTION I HAVE
ABOUT IGBARRO.
>> WE ARE ALMOST THROUGH THE TOP
200 OF THE NFL DRAFT, AND WE
HAVE TO TELL THEM WHO THE FIRST
PICK OF THE SIXTH ROUND WAS, I
DON'T THINK HE EXPECTED TO BE
THE FOURTH PUNTER TAKEN OFF.
THE BILLS HAD A LEGITIMATE
PUNTER PROBLEM LAST YEAR.
WE'RE NOT DOING THE JOIE DE
VIVRE, WE'RE NOT SHOWING YOU THE
PUNK GOD FOOTAGE, ALTHOUGH THAT
WOULD BE PRETTY SICK.
I LIED.
WE DO HAVE THE PUNK GOD FOOTAGE.
THERE IS NO BETTER WAY TO GO OUT
THAN SHOW THE PERFECTLY TIMED
KICK.
YES, FOLKS, HE KICKS.
HE'S GOING TO PUNT AT THE NEXT
LEVEL.
MONSTER LEG.
TOREY, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
PUNK GOD?
>> I LOVE THE NAME.
THE PUNK GOD.
>> FIRST ROUND NAME.
>> FIRST ROUND NAME FOR SURE.
>> ALL RIGHT, GUYS, WE ARE GOING
TO RECAP WHAT WE SAW IN THE
FIFTH ROUND.
A LOT OF TALENT ON THE BOARD, A
LOT OF TEAMS CAPITALIZED ON TOP
OF IT.
WE SAW THE RUN ON TIGHT ENDS, WE
SAW THE RUN ON RUNNING BACKS.
I'LL THROW IT TO YOU LIKE THIS.
I'LL START WITH YOU, FELGER, AND
THEN I'LL GO TO TOREY.
WHETHER IT WAS A THEME OF THE
DAY IN A CERTAIN POSITION,
WHETHER IT WAS SOMEBODY WHOSE
NAME WAS NOT CALLED OR WHETHER
IT WAS SOMEBODY WHO WAITED TOO
LONG TO GET CALLED.
>> I DID THESE NOTES, CONNOR,
THESE ARE THE NOTES THAT I DO AT
1:00 IN THE MORNING.
1:00 IN THE MORNING WHEN I GET
BACK TO MY HOTEL ROOM AFTER LAST
NIGHT.
THE BIG THING I WROTE WAS WHAT'S
THE BIG NEWS WE'RE GOING TO SEE?
ONE, RUNNING BACKS.
WE SAW SPILLER, WE SAW PIERCE,
WE SAW ALLGAIER, WE SAW JAMIR
WHITE.
RUNNING BACKS, THAT'S ON THE
LIST.
YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO READ THE
HANDWRITING, BUT IT'S ALL THERE.
THEN WHEN YOU GET TO THE TE'S,
WIDEMIRE.
McKINLEY AND SMOKE --